We are live, welcome, welcome back.
We're continuing our March meeting and before we get started I want to congratulate members
Lewis and Olken and Orozco-Gonzalez on their confirmation by the Senate last week.
The breadth and depth of knowledge they displayed was just incredible and it was obvious that
the Senators on the Rules Committee were all very impressed and congratulations, I'm proud
to serve with each and every one of you and we're thrilled that you are back with us.
I'd like to welcome all the board members, staff and members of the public who are attending
this board meeting in person.
This is the first in-person meeting of the SBE for several months and hopefully we'll
be able to continue meeting in person this year.
That being said, I'd like to strongly encourage everyone in the boardroom to wear masks.
Masks are available in the back of the room if you need one and thank you for your consideration.
There is one item on the agenda that has an addendum.
Item two, the State Board of Education Screening Committee recommendations regarding appointments
to the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
The proposed waiver consent items are W1 through W12.
The proposed regular consent items are items 6 through 8.
There are no public hearings on this agenda.
We will reopen item two, State Board Priorities before lunch to hear from State Superintendent
Tony Thurmond.
We will reopen item two again later this afternoon to take action on the preliminary report
of actions, draft January 2023 meeting minutes and to take up appointments to advisory commissions
and to report on our liaison assignments.
I will note that because of the impending weather that everyone is probably aware of
if you've been watching the news, that we are going to try to move expeditiously through
our agenda with the hope of ending a bit early so that people can get safely on their road
home.
And we may not take as many breaks, I want to also encourage members of the board to
take a break when you need one and we will try to keep things moving along.
I'd also like to call your attention to corrections to W5 that were posted last Friday and a correction
to item 10 and item 10 attachment one to correct errors regarding the charter school revolving
loan amount from $86,002 to $86,668.
The corrected figures are on page five of item 10 and page four of item 10 attachment
one.
The corrections to item 10 were posted on Tuesday, March 7th, 2023.
In terms of public comment, we will accept public comment either in person or by phone.
Members of the public wishing to call in for public comment should view the live stream
of the meeting to know at what time public comment will occur for each item.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number, entering our participant
access code, and then following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We will also ask callers to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they
are following the live webcast to avoid an echoing effect.
Members of the public wishing to provide public comment in person should sign in using the
binder at the table just outside the room.
The binder is on the table with separate pages for each item number.
This will help ensure that the staff is able to track the in-person speakers for a particular
item.
Public comment will be limited to one minute for each speaker.
Item 11 is the general public comment item during which members of the public may provide
public comment on matters that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
I'll now open item 2, which is our state board projects and priorities item, and I will give
my report and then the superintendent will give his report later today.
So we are in March, and there is an old saying that March comes in like a lion and goes out
like a lamb.
I think we're ready for the lamb, given our unusually severe winter weather, but we're
not there yet.
So as you know, the succession of winter storms that we've been experiencing has impacted
almost everyone with a range of issues from power outages to dangerous road conditions
to flooding.
Our schools have not escaped impact.
Flooding earlier this year led to the destruction of schools in some rural areas where creeks
and rivers crested their banks.
Extreme weather does keep on coming.
On Monday, 334 schools across 24 counties were closed due to the impacts of snow levels
that we have not seen for decades.
Those school closures affected 91,000 students.
I want to thank our school administrators, facilities teams, teachers, and parents for
working hard to put the safety of students and staff first despite this seemingly never
ending series of storms.
And unfortunately, the forecast calls for more bad weather this week.
So more lion until we get to the lamb.
We're in for another atmospheric river effect starting this afternoon through the weekend.
So as I noted, I will try to expedite today's meeting so that we can get everyone home safely.
Because of the ongoing climate disruptions we can expect to have, I believe we should
be considering how to rekindle the continuous instruction plans that we ask districts to
develop during the height of the pandemic.
So there is a plan for moving to online instruction whenever students are prevented from coming
to school, whether it's because of illness, quarantine, flooding, mudslides, fires, or
anything else.
So I think that's something we can be thinking about in the months to come.
On the good news side, of course, March is more than a month of fickle weather.
It's a month full of school celebration days.
One is Read Across America Day, which was celebrated last Thursday.
Read Across America Day is an opportunity for adults to demonstrate to children just
how much joy can be derived from sitting down with a good book.
And it's also an opportunity to reflect on everything the state has been doing these
past four years to ensure that California students become proficient readers who enjoy
reading.
Some of the highlights of those investments include the $7.9 billion for learning recovery
support, including both before and after school instructional time, summer school, and tutoring,
$250 million for literacy coaches and reading specialists, and a request in this budget
for an additional $250 million, $15 million to support teachers to receive their supplementary
state certification in reading and literacy, $50 million for teacher professional development
on learning acceleration in literacy, mathematics, and language development, $68 million for
Dolly Parton's Imagination Library.
Kids get a free book mailed to them every month to ensure book-rich households, $28
million for early literacy through a partnership with First Five California.
Of course, more needs to be done, and all of this work needs to continue and deepen.
In this year's budget, Governor Newsom has proposed to launch a literacy roadmap that
will provide more explicit guidance about how the state's curriculum framework can
be translated into instructional practices in elementary school classrooms, serving both
native English speakers and new English learners.
And as TK, Transitional Kindergarten, begins its expansion, we're also deepening the PK
foundations in literacy and math so there'll be a seamless learning continuum with useful
teaching and assessments from preschool through the primary grades.
I had the opportunity to discuss the state's literacy work last week when I was invited
to make remarks on the state of public education before the assembly education committee.
It was a privilege to address Chair Maruzuchi and other members of the committee and take
stock of where our students and schools are in the wake of the pandemic and our efforts
to support them in full recovery.
One point I raised is that while literacy is very important, we also need to do more
to improve student performance in mathematics.
California is further behind in math than in literacy.
We lost almost no ground in literacy during the pandemic, and none at all in eighth grade.
But in math, we lost less ground than other states, but we still fell backwards from where
we had been, both on state and national assessments.
And we have too few students succeeding in launching careers in STEM to meet our state's
economic needs.
As you know, teams are working on a new mathematics curriculum framework to provide guidance on
best instructional practices to help students master our rigorous Common Core math standards,
and we hope to have the opportunity to consider that framework at one of our very soon upcoming
meetings.
Once we have a new framework, we'll need to expand professional development to help teachers
more effectively reach and teach all of their students.
And thinking about the joy of math brings me to the next March celebration day.
March 15th is Pi Day.
And there will be places all around the state that not only are celebrating 3.1416, whatever
it is, but also eating pies.
So I hope that our math teachers can be very creative with Pi Day parties, and I look forward
to hearing about the fun activities planned for students.
And finally, March is Women's History Month, a time to look back on how four women have
progressed, marvel at the brave women who often defied the establishment to inch the
world closer to equality.
Yesterday was International Women's Day.
This year's theme, DIGITAL, Innovation in Technology for Gender Equity, highlights the
role of innovative technology in promoting gender equality and meeting the health and
developmental needs of women and girls.
If you want an inspiring and educative opportunity to recognize this theme, I recommend celebrating
by watching or re-watching Hidden Figures, the true story of a group of brilliant black
women who began working as mathematicians at NASA in the 1960s as part of the Mercury
Project.
Working under segregated conditions, they were hired to calculate complicated aeronautic
data, even before computers were available to determine launch and landing coordinates.
In 1962, Mary Jackson, Katherine Johnson, and Dorothy Vaughn were among those who helped
to send John Glenn, the first American astronaut, into orbit.
And Glenn himself said that if Katherine Johnson reviewed the equations and the numbers for
the flight, he felt safe and was ready to take off.
Johnson was awarded the Presidential Medal of Freedom by President Obama in 2015, and
last year, in 2022, she was honored at the age of 97 by NASA when they dedicated a building
in her name at the Langley Research Center in Virginia.
However, she and her colleagues worked in obscurity and in great odds for many, many
years.
And women all over the world do extraordinary things that help their families, the children
in their classrooms, and the members of society every day, usually without recognition or
reward.
So I do want to thank all the women here and across our state for everything you've done
and will do to make a difference in the lives of California students and families.
And Naomi, you have some great role models here, and we have some great expectations
for you.
And with that, we are ready to launch our March meeting.
As I said, we'll resume this item when Superintendent Tony Thurmond joins us and move on to item
three.
Item three is the update on the implementation of the integrated local, state, and federal
accountability and continuous improvement system.
And the California Department of Education recommends that we provide guidance on the
proposed 2023 accountability work plan and take additional action as deemed necessary
and appropriate.
And this item will be presented by Cindy Kazanis of the CDE.
Cindy, please begin.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, President Darling-Hammond.
It is wonderful to welcome you all to this building at the California Department of Education.
I just began my 20th year here, and there has been so many changes in those two decades.
I'm super excited to have people in the building and to be able to see you in person as well,
so welcome.
Today we are going to cover a couple of topics related to accountability.
Last year we spent a lot of time trying to, I think, bring you all up to speed on what
the accountability system has been, how it was developed since it was done with a prior
board, and where we were headed.
And so today is really that time to reflect on what happened last year, what our student
outcomes were, potential revisions to the Dashboard, as well as our numerous opportunities
for engagement with the field, with practitioners, and our colleagues across the street and the
legislature, as well as education advocates.
So these are the three attachments that you see in your agenda today, and the recommendation
is that the Department of Education recommends the State Board provide guidance on the proposed
2023 Accountability Work Plan and take additional action as necessary and appropriate.
Just to pause here, this is your opportunity to weigh in on our work plan.
We have six months between this meeting and September when you will make decisions that
will influence what we do to process the data that we receive from local educational
agencies over the summer and start working through the metrics to produce the Dashboard
in December.
So each of these topics have been planned to the week, I think.
Kimberly will talk a little bit more about that with the mindset of having, we've worked
through what kind of stakeholder engagement we need to do, and ultimately bringing it
to the California Practitioners Advisory Group in August.
Due to, again, this limited timeframe, if there's things that you want to add, this
is the meeting to do that and have that conversation, as opposed to if we come back in May or June
or July, rather, and there's things that you're interested in doing, we would have
to probably wait until the 2024 Dashboard.
So let's move into what happened this last year, and just as a great reminder, because
we saw a variety of things come through in the correspondence, the purpose of the Dashboard
is to provide parents and educators with information on school and district progress so they can
participate in decisions to improve student learning.
That said, the Dashboard is our metric to also identify or show which schools and districts
may be eligible under accountability for support.
It's also used to provide awards to districts.
It's used for grant purposes.
It's used to designate schools that will be visited through the Williams Act, and so
the life of the Dashboard goes well beyond the original purpose, but just to frame what
the intent was when you all adopted this or the previous board adopted it, this is what
we have today.
And so in summary, we have, of course, this last year we were able to report out on five
of our six indicators.
We talk about English language arts and mathematics as the academic indicator.
Of course, our college and career indicator we're not able to report out on because our
graduating 12th graders did not take the CASP at a widespread rate because there was flexibility
provided by the Board of Education.
You can see that the metrics shift, the labels shift for chronic and for suspension because
we are not looking for, the goal is to get to very low on chronic and suspension, not
to have very high, as opposed to when we're looking at our English learner progress indicator
and our mathematics indicator, we're making sure that we want to see very high.
That said, we saw strong performance for a couple of indicators.
We still have, of course, a lot of room to go, but between our suspension rates, keeping
those low and making sure that our students are graduating within that four or five year
period for our graduation rate.
So just a couple of pieces around chronic absenteeism because that is going to be the
focus of my remarks on student outcomes today.
We have two different metrics or two different reporting opportunities for these data.
The dashboard is adopted because of the Every Student Succeeds Act requirement to have a
balance of indicators for grade spans.
The metric for K-8 is chronic absenteeism.
The equivalent for high school is our graduation rate.
And so there's another resource that the department supports called DataQuest, which
has been around longer than I have in this department.
And so that particular resource provides static data or rather data without a metric attached
to it.
So that's going to be the raw data on DataQuest.
We also provide information around our nonpublic schools and through their LEA reports.
And then there's a series of filters on DataQuest.
So I wanted to just point out that this is available and we're going to walk through
a couple of reports that will show the DataQuest data as well as Dashboard.
So for Dashboard, we of course saw that 30 percent of our students in K-8 were chronically
absent, which of course resulted in a very high status on the Dashboard.
The equity report, as you can see on the bottom left-hand side, shows that of our 13 student
groups, 11 of those student groups were very high and the remaining two student groups
were high.
So we didn't see any at the state level, any student groups in medium, low or very
low, which is very concerning.
You can see on the right-hand side, the reason I included this in here is when you click
through, view more details, this is what shows up.
It also gives you the short description of what the definition of chronic absenteeism
is on the Dashboard, which of course looks at students who are absent 10 percent or more
of the instructional days enrolled.
So if a student was there for 40 days and they were absent more than 10 percent of those
days, they'd be considered chronically absent.
We capture all of that through our student notable data system.
And so these couple of slides are information that is taken from DataQuest, and what I like
about this information is it provides you the historical pre-pandemic levels.
So the first year of this data collection for chronic absenteeism was 2016-17.
That first year, we knew it was going to take a bit of a lift for districts to report out
on this data, and in fact, we had a couple of larger districts that said that they didn't
have any students that were chronically absent.
And so we knew that there were some data quality issues we needed to work with our local educational
agencies on.
So you see this very slight shift from 2016 to 2017 to 2018, very small increments of
increase in chronic absenteeism.
In 2019-20, we were unable to determine that the data was valid or reliable because of
the way students were exited out of the system when schools shut down in March due to COVID.
So that information was not processed, and we did not report out on that information.
For 2020-21, that first year of students starting to return to the classroom after the winter
break and when vaccinations sort of started to become available, maybe for adults I think
was more so the case, the chronic absenteeism rate at that point was 14.3, and then of course
we hit this record number in 2021-2022 of 30%.
This is K-12.
So let's go into a different report.
This is something that is unique to California.
I'm very proud of this report.
We've gotten actually researchers that have done work on this, and I know that Attendance
Works has spent a lot of time looking at these numbers and uses these publicly.
And so the absenteeism by reason is using information we receive from districts when
they report to us around how many days a student attended, and then how many days they did
not attend.
So it's expected days and then actual attended.
We don't know if those are Mondays or Tuesdays or Wednesdays.
We don't know if it's due to COVID.
We don't know if it's because they went out of state on a vacation.
But we do know the number of absences, and we do know the reasons for those absences.
So these next two slides show both of those things.
And I think this report is really significant because you see between the pre-COVID years
of an average rate of under 10, 10 days absent, 9.3 and 9.8 respectively for 2018 and 2019,
increased to the COVID, post-COVID year, or middle of COVID year rather, at 13.3 days,
and a jump to 16.7.
We also see over a million students who had one or more absences.
So this shows you the breadth and the depth of the effect on chronic absenteeism.
Superintendent Thurman was asked last week at a hearing around like, what are the trends?
What regions does this affect?
It affected every single region in the state of California.
It affected every single state in the United States.
So we're not an island in California for this particular issue.
And in fact, by displaying this data and then the next data slide, I think it really provides
a call to action for how we can help districts, how we can show that looking at whether an
absence is excused or unexcused may provide districts and, again, those that are helping
our students advance a more preventative problem-solving and equitable response to poor attendance
practices.
These reports also provide some bright spots.
And while the department doesn't often do that kind of work, we partner with researchers.
We partner with researchers in every major institution in California and mostly are starting
to do more nationally to do these kinds of studies.
So specifically, this report shows the amount of unexcused absences, whether or not the
absence was due to out-of-school suspension or incomplete independent study.
And you can see, again, those shifts in last year, or rather in 2021, having majority of
unexcused absences to a slight shift over to the majority of absences being excused.
So these are, again, important data points.
But the department and the state only gets this after the fact, after a student maybe
has left a school, maybe they've left a district, maybe they've left the state.
And so on a daily basis, local educational agencies have access to students who are not
in the classroom.
And there's an obligation for them to follow up with those particular students and their
families.
And so the superintendent, in releasing the dashboard, along with President Darlene Hammond,
put together a dashboard summary back on December 15 that provided local educational
agencies about information and factors to consider when we go through the reports.
And there was a lot of information in there around the chronic absenteeism concerns and
the high rates.
Again, I talked about that this definitely mirrored national trends.
We are definitely in line with other large states.
And in this summary, which was included, part of it was included as attachment to,
Superintendent Thurman provided guidance and resources on best practices and ways to counter
chronic absenteeism.
He also began a webinar series in January of 2023 that included Aaron Simon from Long
Beach Unified and Sherry Hanny from Butte County Office of Education.
And they really provided a really nice balance of the urban setting versus the rural setting
and strategies that they had are using currently to engage students and try to get students
to school.
Because, of course, if you are chronically absent, you're not getting an opportunity
to learn.
So with that, I wanted to move over to our LEAs and schools that are eligible for support.
Of course, the dashboard, again, while it's meant to be used for giving parents access
to information about how their schools and districts are doing, we also have to use it
as our metric to determine who's not doing well and how they can be provided support,
which are requirements under the Local Control Funding Formula and the Every Student Succeeds
Act.
So for the Local Control Funding Formula, you all adopted the one-time metric using
a status only to determine schools or other districts and county offices of education
that were eligible for differentiated assistance.
2022 saw an absence of looking at charter schools because of previously adopted or previously
signed into law legislation that it excluded them for one additional year.
They will be brought back into the fold in 2023.
So of our over 900 districts, we saw 617 eligible for differentiated assistance.
And the top student groups have been consistent with the exception of the last one.
So for the last 2017, 2018, and 2019, when we previously provided the eligibility for
differentiated assistance, it's always been students with disabilities, homeless and foster
are the student groups that have propelled those districts to be eligible.
The addition this year is English learners, and it's almost 250 districts that are eligible
for English and for their English learner population.
So county offices are now talking to these districts, assisting them.
The California Department of Education is doing the same for county offices who have
been identified.
But this is very significant for the state.
It is a shift from prior years where we've been in the high 300 range for districts eligible
for differentiated assistance.
Of course, this feeds into the Every Student Succeeds Act.
ESSA and the US Department of Education have been very eager to see how the department
and the state board will have implemented for this COVID year, eligibility for comprehensive
support and improvement and additional targeted support and improvement.
And while the adoption of the metric that you all approved for this one year did lower
or did rather yield 333 schools with the low graduation rates, that's under 68 percent
for a three-year average, our CSI low performance at 474, and that's capped, right?
So we have to identify a minimum of 5 percent of schools, so we do our best to hit that
number as closely as possible.
There is no cap or minimum for additional targeted support and improvement, and we have
a record 6,209 schools.
And I can tell you thousands of schools, rather represented by districts, have been reaching
out to us because they are not used to accountability.
They have not been included in prior accountability systems because they are middle or high performing.
And so districts that struggled under the No Child Left Behind criteria and are now
in the Every Student Succeeds Act criteria, this is sort of normal to them, as normal
as possible, but you have a whole new group of schools that have maybe their entire schools
included as ATSI.
And this has been a very difficult release, not only for the department, but I think for
the field, in understanding why are they identified, why is it only one indicator.
And so we talked through the student groups for differentiated assistance.
As the criteria shifts a bit, the student groups under ATSI did as well.
So we see students with disabilities, two or more races, black or African-American,
and our homeless population.
So it is a shift in those metrics.
Of course, for CSI, schools get funding.
There is funding that is provided through Title I, and there is support and plans that
you all are aware of through my colleagues in our Student Achievement and Support Division.
And for ATSI, while there is no money, there is definitely attention and support around
those schools as well.
So last year, well before this summer, I want to say it was your March meeting, maybe it
was even your May meeting, there was this idea of a dashboard toolkit, and I think it
was actually the Association of California School Administrators and maybe the County
Superintendents who suggested it.
And we took it and we ran with it.
And this has provided, I think, it provided a lot of pre-work to the field on this is
what these scores are going to look like, these are how these metrics are determined.
All of that leading up to a release on December 15th.
And I think now that the information is out as far as student outcomes, the toolkit has
become even more valuable and we are still making, we are still adding things to it to
make sure that it is relevant for not only educators, but the public to talk through
what do these outcomes mean and through our system of support, how can we help schools
and districts, you know, help to improve student outcomes moving forward.
So President Darling-Hammond, I just wanted to make sure you did not want me to pause
during this presentation unless...
You are also welcome to breathe when you need to.
Do you want to see if there are any clarifying questions at this juncture?
This has many parts, so I appreciate you offering that.
You've been very clear so far, I don't see any clarifying questions.
Feel free to proceed.
Well maybe just one caveat.
I cannot predict what's going to happen in 2023, but we do continue to read the media
reports and information that schools are sharing with us and districts are sharing with us.
And I did want to acknowledge that I do believe chronic absenteeism is going to continue to
be an issue.
We heard from a rural district in Northern California who said they just hit their 100
day mark and their chronic absenteeism rate for kindergarten is 45%.
So these big issues around attendance, which of course again will impact other student
outcomes, I think will continue to rise to your attention and will continue to be in
the media nationally, absolutely, I've seen it in some of the national publications.
So just for you all to be aware and just to acknowledge that that is a consternation
in the field.
Can I raise a clarifying question about it since you're raising these considerations?
So we do have all of these events that are climate related events that are happening
that will close schools, that will require people to figure out how to move their homes.
How is that treated in the chronic absenteeism?
Yes, so a good question.
So the question around when do we determine if a student, the methodology for chronic
absenteeism, and if a school is open and they expect a student to attend, that's the metric.
So if a school is closed, there is no expectation that those students are expected to attend
and that would not contribute to their chronic absenteeism rate.
That said, I do not handle waivers around the minimum number of school days for the
state, that is my colleagues and other divisions, but in terms of accountability, the metric
is number of days expected to attend over number of days actually attended or vice versa.
If the student's family experienced some aspect of the disaster themselves, that still
would be counted as part of chronic absenteeism if the school was open.
So if a student has been impacted and not been able to attend a school that was open
that they were enrolled at, yes, and if a student has transitioned to a new school and
has not been able to attend school, that would be catalogued as well, that would be documented
as well.
Excused and unexcused absences are counted?
Excused and unexcused absences are counted because the student didn't have an opportunity
to learn regardless of the type of absence.
So I think one of the things that we will want to be considering given the fact that
we're seeing the effects of climate change and of course we're still experiencing the
effects of the pandemic is how do we want to think about that in a way that's productive
for identifying schools and what kind of supports then attend to that because of these
very different rationales.
So calling out the issue that we're going to have to confront.
Just a clarifying question?
Yeah, please.
You shared that report that is average days absent, is that something that's available
on DataQuest?
Absolutely.
So we released this, actually it was one of the newest reports when Superintendent Thurman
first took office in October that year, was that 2019?
I can't even remember, 2019.
It actually came out of the foster youth community.
The foster youth community has really spent a lot of time and focus to make sure that
our students who need to be at school and are most vulnerable students are receiving
that opportunity.
So this has been on DataQuest now for several years and it is available as a downloadable
file.
We do have researchers that are using it through the downloadable file and I know that there's
a publication pending on this very report.
At the school level?
At the school level, it's at the district, it's at the county, it's at the state.
And you can filter, I know you're interested in charter schools, you can filter by charter
schools or non-charter schools and so there is lots of opportunities to look at the data.
Okay, so let's shift over to 2023, present day.
We have been waiting for this to come because some of these projects have been on hold since
COVID happened.
And so we had fully intended to have a full-blown English under progress indicator and other
metrics collected for college career and the pandemic really put this work on hold.
What you're going to see today is looking back at things that we've been wanting to
work on that we'll finally get to in 2023.
Last fall, you all adopted 11 dashboard principles and I'm happy to share with you that information.
We just recently added it to our webpages so you can find it on our website and those
were designed to serve as an anchor for your decisions moving forward.
So in the item we did reference which dashboard principles each individually were relevant
to and I'm not going to go through these because you spent so much time on them last
year but they are in the slide deck in case we need to refer back to them.
So as with all of our work plans that we've brought before the board each March, we are
still focused on continuous improvement that has been a tenet of the system and the dashboard.
And so our plans look not only at the state and local indicators, you are going to hear
your next item is all about a local indicator that of course is not in our work plan because
the timing was off but this is your opportunity again to suggest revisions or updates for
the plan.
This plan has been reviewed not only by the California Petitions Advisory Group which
you're going to hear about towards the end of the presentation but we have taken it to
multiple partners early.
We took it to the equity groups back in October, we've taken it to the County Superintendents
Association for their curriculum subgroups and their assessment subgroups and so we have
tried to actually be proactive well beyond you all seeing this today.
So what's at hand today and we're going to walk through is our English Learner Progress
Indicator, the completion of it, our updates to state indicators for graduation rate, college
career and then looking at our priority one teacher assignment data and additional data
on the dashboard in lieu of us having enough data to add things to the dashboard.
And so we will also talk a little bit about the growth model and some updated business
rules we're going to ask you to weigh in on this fall.
So let's start with the English Learner Progress Indicator and talk through the components
of not only this indicator but how this is what we do for each indicator.
So we of course for every state indicator on the dashboard we have a status methodology,
we have status levels and cut scores which include five levels of only for current year
performance from very high to very low, we have the five levels of change again looking
at from increase significantly to decrease significantly and then our five by five color
grid and so this is really I think the first time for many of you to weigh in on a conversation
around cut scores and so forgive me if I'm taking this a little slow but I think it's
an opportunity for us also to help the members of the public understand the process as well.
So the English Learner Progress Indicator was reported on the first dashboard in 2017
and we had a color back then.
In 2018 the board approved a three-year plan to shift because of course we changed assessments
for this indicator and so we were gearing up for creating status for the LP in 2018.
In 2019 the board approved the methodology to create six English Learner Progress levels
based on the LPAC, the English Learner Proficiency Assessment for California and the cut scores
for this indicator and we had really hanging over us because of a waiver that the U.S.
Department of Education denied after arguing in person and going to great lengths during
that process.
The original LP actually had long-term English learners in it and the U.S. Department of
Education did not find that to be in compliance with the federal statute and so part of the
reason that you see the second bullet here that I wanted to point out is we had an obligation
from the U.S. Department of Education to make sure that we were still using this indicator
even though we just had status only for making determinations for schools eligible for assistance.
So this was important because when the U.S. Department of Education sends you a letter
saying your grant is at risk you better pay attention and so that's what the board made
it just you know we brought options to you and that's what was used.
So you did see schools being determined eligible based on specifically on just that status
information.
Now it seems sort of normal because we did a whole dashboard just based only on status
in 2022.
So for 2020 and 2021 dashboards of course everything was suspended and you didn't see
data on the dashboard due to Senate Bill 98 and Assembly Bill 130 because of the pandemic.
So again components that were approved prior for the English Learner Progress Indicator
were the status methodologies adopted in 2019 and again the status is measuring the rate
of English learners who are moving towards English language proficiency.
That is the whole purpose of this indicator.
There is one student group in this indicator English learners not long term English learners
just current English learners and so the status cut scores that were approved in 2019 have
the five levels of the current year performance from very high to very low and of course this
in keeping with your dashboard priority five which talks about having the five levels based
on percentile distributions on actual based on actual district and school performance
to create the five by five grid.
So for 2023 we are looking to finally bring the English Learner Progress Indicator back
on the dashboard with color.
And so we will our plan to you is to evaluate the data look at the data and reestablish
that grid and make sure that we're incorporating for the first time students who take alternate
English Learner the proficiency assessment again for our most severely cognitive disabled
students that that one percent that it that test was not around back in 2017 and so we
are really excited to be able to bring that population of students into this measure.
So as far as LP change we are looking at again measuring the year to year rate of that change.
We need to have three years of data so we are finally in 2023 capturing that third year
of summative assessments for the LPAC and then we are going to be analyzing that those
multiple years of data to determine the change or place the change cut scores based on the
methodologies that you've provided in the past or adopted in the past.
We have a standard group of stakeholders that we look to for policy considerations technical
considerations and then under the Ever Student Succeeds Act we have to take it to the California
Practitioners Advisory Group because they're your committee of practitioners.
That is not the only groups that we talked to and so I know we're going to talk about
this at the very end but we are going to the CABE conference at the end of this month.
We talked to the regional assessment network we talked to CISC the county superintendents
we go to the bilingual coordinators network and then anybody who wants to invite us to
a meeting to talk about accountability we pretty much show up so I would just say you
know this is not limited we've had a lot of conversations around this and English
learners as you can see is at the core of the students that we need to serve because
we see them identified through differentiated assistance this year at numbers that we're
not used to seeing.
So in terms of the 5x5 color grid again we need to we're calling it reestablished because
you had already adopted and our state plan actually includes a 5x5 color grid under the
Every Student Succeeds Act for this indicator.
We are looking at those multiple years of the LPAC summative and so we are also going
to be looking at past and current LP data to I think this is a duplicate slide to produce
the colors.
So in terms of the alt LPAC and the LP again we've traditionally we've not had access
to these test scores so for the first time we have access to the information this is
an assessment that you adopted back in 2019 and so we are able to look at the two years
of summative from well we had the field test in 2021 the operational is this year.
So as far as plans for looking at these data we need to review the data from the assessments
results from 2022 and we are in the process of doing that currently and so reviewing that
information again with the workgroups we've already talked about and then with the availability
again of those the second year of data we can incorporate it into the calculation of
the LP status at least for the 2023 dashboard so again really fully making sure that every
student is included that has the opportunity to be included.
This topic has received a lot of attention not only from previous board meetings but
the current board meeting and so I just wanted to address some of the concerns directly about
the request to revisit the status cut scores which is not currently on our work plan.
So we did hear from the California Britishers advisory group and the letters from the field
have said asking some of them have asked for a reset of the status cut scores that were
adopted back in 2019 and the really one of the arguments that keeps being brought up
is that this is based on the amount of school districts that are in the very low and of
course there's not a predetermined number of districts or schools that need to be in
the very low there is no minimums especially when you get to differentiated assistance
there is no minimum number of school districts that need to be or local educational agencies
that need to be eligible for differentiated assistance that's not how the methodology
that was adopted by the board works but I wanted to make sure that we walked through
some of these considerations. So the concerns also talked about that the significance of
this indicator would be diminished and give districts a false impression as to how other
students have progressed in learning English. The other piece that we saw and we've heard
this in a couple of different ways is that the performance expectations to align they're
asking for the performance expectations to align with what we know from research and
not based on a normative distribution of our school systems under performance in this
area and those comments really remind me of the no child left behind era where you were
looking to hit a certain bar for students and instead what the board has adopted again
is percentile distributions based on actual district and school performance so that you
can see achievable progress for our students especially in that middle set that's where
a lot of that is concentrated and then also see some schools or districts in the very
high or the very high status and so just as a you know going back to our July meeting
we talked a little bit about how we created or the methodology that we've used to create
the status levels for every single indicator. This is not different for any of the indicators
that you have on the dashboard today whether it's graduation rate or academic performance
indicator suspension college career indicator so we look at the results for all LEAs and
charters again based on student level data we order those results from highest to lowest
and then we look at four cut points established based on percentile distribution so we look
at a very low status point set on a small percent at the lowest end of their distribution
usually under ten percent and again this performance level is equivalent to an unacceptable performance
level and may likely result in intensive or focused support. The high we were looking
at for each of our indicators meaning that every student succeeds act requirement for
states to set ambitious goals so this is again in line with we're looking at LEAs to obtain
this this ranking for each of the state indicators that's the aspirational goal and the remaining
cut points were established again based on this percentile distribution. So in terms
of looking at the status cut scores and the history of resetting them for other indicators
in 2018 the state board did look at status cut scores for academic indicators so for
mathematics and English language arts because there was a change in the distribution that
year so due to the change in distribution of status and so the board did adopt adjusting
those cut scores. We see in 2022 that the distribution for this particular indicator
is similar to that distribution that you adopted back in 2019 so we are not seeing the large
changes that could be made to the cut scores and there's no large changes in the overall
distribution so this is the reason that we have not brought this back to you for reopening
otherwise we would have you know looking at the data and we've again spent a lot of
time talking about this indicator in prior meetings we would have brought it to you and
so just a quick revisiting of what the current status levels are for this indicator at the
very high we're looking at 65 percent students are more making progress towards English language
proficiency and at the very low end it's 34.9 percent or less and of course if we were
to honor the request from the California Patricia Jones advisory group or those that have advocated
for this change you would you know we're looking back at the principles for each of
the other indicators and it would mean moving towards a criterion referenced cut scores
as opposed to percentile distribution and again that would require that it be sent on
a predetermined performance level that you all would get to determine so percentile distribution
allows you to work off of actual data and that's how those distributions were made.
I'm going to step down and I'm going to have my colleague come up unless you wanted
to pause for clarifying questions.
Are there any clarifying questions on that? Kim you look like you want to ask a question.
I can see the furrow in your brow.
In terms of understanding the distribution across the five the current cohort of folks
or districts that are identified for in the lowest represents about is it about 20 percent
or is it higher than that? I'm just wondering if it actually tracks to a roughly proportional
distribution across the five.
I realize in looking at some of the documents and Kimberly gets here to help with some of
the more technical questions is that we in some of our documents we did not show at least
at a state level the distribution including charter schools so when we think about differentiated
assistance this year we didn't have charter schools in the mix and when you include charter
schools and when you originally adopted the status cut scores back in 2019 they actually
make up a bulk of what is considered on the very low piece so when we think about the
distribution being a little bit under 10 percent for very low it's made up not only of not
only our traditional districts and county offices but charter schools and so that piece
is missing from deliberately missing from differentiated assistance this year because
we were prohibited from thinking about including charter schools in the mix so it is when we
look at it it is it does come up to similar numbers but because again differentiated assistance
this year was only for traditional districts you don't see that in our document in our
in our memo to you all from December.
Thanks and I'm just going to remind all the board members to pull your microphone close
and be sure you turn it on when you are speaking and Vice President Glover Woods.
Cindy just to clarify the districts that will be eligible based upon the 2023 budget and
the dash board the LP data we will be looking at will be based on the performance grid now
that we have status and change cut scores as opposed to when we did not have change
cut scores is that correct?
That's correct we'll bring in we'll bring in change cut scores this year and we'll
bring in of course charter schools to the fold for differentiated assistance.
Okay thank you for that clarification.
All right let's move on ahead.
Thank you everybody so I have my timer I'm not going to try I'm going to slow things
down a little bit but you guys have a lot of the rest of this plan in the item so I
do want to let you know that there are brief slides on everything here but if there are
additional questions at the end I'm more than happy to go through all of them.
So nice to see everybody in person and see your faces as well and I'm going to try not
to fog up my glasses today.
So the graduation rate indicator is also very familiar to you because we have been dealing
with some bumps in the road around the graduation rate indicator specifically in the last year.
So since 2017 with the adoption of the dashboard the graduation rate indicator calculation
has really varied each year for both traditional non-DAS schools and for DAS schools.
So originally we had a four-year cohort rate across the entire dashboard for all of our
schools that were on the dashboard actually you know I think I'm going to have to do this
I apologize it's not going to work that way and then the four and five-year combination
rate came into play in the 2018 dashboard for all of our traditional schools and then
the one-year graduation rate in 2019 debuted for our DAS schools as a modified method that
we're able to include and then we had merges of a four-five-one-year rate in 2019 as well
for our LEAs.
So we have seen a cavalcade of methodologies for actually measuring how students are graduating
and matriculating at our schools on the dashboard.
Now as we remember back in 2022 in July we had submitted a waiver which took a lot of
time in last March at this meeting to request that we could continue to use modified methods
for calculating the academic and graduation rate indicators for our DAS schools.
Unfortunately ED did not agree with that waiver and specifically requested that it did not
sufficiently demonstrate how the request would advance student academic achievement.
So unfortunately we were left with the inability to apply that one-year DAS rate methodology
to our DAS schools and to merge that into our LEA rates as well.
So with this shift in federal accountability for DAS schools you approved a recommendation
for us to work on developing long-term options to support these schools.
So we're happy today to be here to present some of those options to you and specifically
we were going to review the options presented in the letter which was very kind of them
to offer some suggestions and asked that they specifically stated that we could propose
to incorporate multiple extended year adjusted cohort graduation rates to give credit to
schools and students that are receiving a regular graduate high school diploma in six
or more years hint hint.
So we wanted to enable in this last system cycle as Cindy just displayed to you to utilize
any sort of one-year or modified rate for DAS schools for federal identification purposes
and specifically under comprehensive support we have to identify schools that have the
lowest graduation rate in our state under CSI graduation rate identification.
And so we knew collectively that changing that graduation rate methodology was likely
going to impact the number of schools that were identified for support.
And so I want to show you exactly what that did over the time.
So in the 2020-21 school year we saw 236 DAS schools identified utilizing our modified
methods even for graduation rate on the dashboard.
In 2021-22 that was 151 schools but this year for 2022-23 support we see 293 DAS schools
collected within our CSI low graduation rate identification process which is a significant
number of them and obviously is measuring for some schools and some schools students
that had a long past their fifth year of eligibility right we're grabbing students
that they can't even capture in a graduation rate at those schools.
So therefore our work plan for 2023 is that CDE plans to review and analyze data with
our educational partners and workgroups to identify options and methodologies to calculate
a multiple extended year rate and to look at how specifically this multiple extended
year rate would affect DAS schools.
And while we know that this multiple extended year rate will apply to all schools right
well we're going to have to if we develop something and we want to apply it to DAS
schools it has to apply to all of them.
The intended outcome really that we're looking for is an advantageous rate for DAS schools.
We're not looking to layer on additional complexity if we're not seeing right an advantageous
result for these schools in that way and in turn we might want to look at other methodologies
and see what we're going through so that's what we're going to be devoting our work
to within the graduation rate this year.
Next up on the docket the college career indicator and as Cindy pointed out on our summary the
CCI wasn't published in the 2021 statewide summative because of the summative assessments
in 2021.
We had flexibility and therefore as those summative assessment results are an integral
part of the CCI we did not report on any status for the 2022 dashboard.
However we will be releasing shortly this spring the results of how LEAs in schools
did perform on the metrics within the CCI so look forward to that in our school dashboard
additional reports coming soon.
Now in the 2023 dashboard CCI will come back and we've already developed some lovely cell
phone bar graphics so it can have a status only for 2023 and then change or performance
levels will not be reported for the CCI so it's still going to stand alone as its own
special indicator on the 2023 dashboard however in 2024 it will return with status change
and performance levels similar to those reported in 2019.
Now specifically for 2023 we have a lot of work ahead on the plate and as Cindy mentioned
essentially this is the stagnated back loaded workload that we were unable to work on for
the past couple of years.
So specifically we're looking at analyzing and validating data for four new career measures.
Those are internships, student led enterprise, simulated work based learning and the Armed
Services Vocational Aptitude Battery as FAB armed forces qualification scores.
Those are all career based measures that the board had actually asked us to look into and
had walked through in the 2020 meeting in March to look forward and explore options
of inclusion in the CCI.
Unfortunately over the past couple of years in collecting data on these indicators options
for students to engage in career level participation at a high school have as we kind of know been
limited.
So our data collection in this way has been limited over the past few years so we're hoping
that this year the collection is even more robust and the cumulative information that
we have over the past few years can assist us in figuring out if that is something that
the board wants to incorporate into the CCI.
So we will look to see whether or not that these are valid for inclusion with all of
our partners as well as what would be prepared or approaching prepared criteria and present
that to you in September for a decision.
Additionally over the past few years we want to explore some modifications to the currently
CCI measures.
Specifically looking at the expansion of work based learning activities in schools and also
the impact of implementing work based learnings during the COVID-19 pandemic and what schools
are currently available to offer.
So there was a lot of fluctuation and change which was going on with work based learning
over the past few years and we want to make sure that we update that and subject to our
continuous improvement goals and responsibilities within the CCI and make sure that our terminology
and what we're asking for from all of our schools and districts matches what we're looking
to see.
And then finally we also want to establish some data collection guidelines for two new
CCI measures specifically civic engagement and also for industry certifications.
At this time we do not collect any information formally within a formal data collection as
we do from LEAs on civic engagement.
We have you know some kind of you know seal reportings and such of counts and who's requesting
things but we don't have any student level data that we would need to be able to fold
that in to the CCI and or evaluate measure validity across student groups, participation
right schools and LEAs all of the work that we do for validity and reliability.
We don't have that yet so we would look at how we would get that and additionally same
with industry certifications the process that we would go through to do that.
Then we also have outside of our indicators some additional data on the dashboard and
specifically over the past few years we've been asked to add additional information to
the dashboard based both on requirements from statute as well as prior state board action.
So from statute we have a requirement to add least restrictive environment data as well
as teacher assignment data under priority one and then from prior board action in your
requests we have a request to add science data to the dashboard as well as information
on student growth.
So first up least restrictive environment.
So we have a request on or before November 30th of this year to publish data related
to federal measures of least restrictive environment for pupils with disabilities on the web on
our website and included as a resource for the dashboard and that information needs to
be disaggregated by race, ethnicity and LEA so we will be looking at the best options
for this and be presenting those options for you for approval in September.
As far as priority one teacher assignment data is concerned this is another priority
that you have been a part of and folding into.
For the 2022 local indicator resources we just want to point out that we do as Cindy
talked about our tool kit have multiple resources available to parents and educators around
how things work and the purpose of things on the dashboard.
So we specifically have a flyer entitled information on local indicators for parents it's on our
dashboard tool kit and additionally our other offices have a self reflection tool document
available on the local indicator web page and we wanted to link those resources here
for you to have access to.
As we can remember senate bill 75 requires that the standards for local indicators on
which the department collects or otherwise has access to relevant reliable school data
for all schools statewide shall to the extent practicable be based on objective criteria
and they may include but are not necessarily limited to the extent of disparities across
school sites within a school district county office of education or performance relative
to statewide data.
So specifically we are going to be developing objective criteria for reporting the teacher
component of priority one this year and we've spoken to how this work has already started
with a work group the formation of a work group who's already met once and will meet
again once the release of the second year of teacher data is available that has not
been published or made available yet so when that is out we will be able to evaluate that
developing that objective criteria.
Additionally will be gathering feedback for reporting the information and additional resources
that we need to develop for the two thousand twenty three dashboard in order to communicate
this information clearly to the public and to all of our constituents.
Science data on the dashboard so first off let's just remember that the first operational
test of our cast our California science test was in twenty eighteen and then obviously
we had some little interruptions going through but at the March state board meeting when
none of us thought anything was going to be you know bumps or bruises coming ahead in
twenty twenty this was the first time we talked about incorporating science on the dashboard
formally and then in two thousand twenty two last March we had an update specifically to
you about the feasibility and timeline of incorporating science data on the dashboard
and walked through that and in September you approved adding a link to our on the dashboard
for additional reports page specifically to the science data and that is available right
now and live on the dashboard.
This prior year's assessments in two thousand one twenty one twenty two was the first year
that we had a significant proportion of eligible students take the cast so we had ninety one
point eight percent of eligible students take the cast that year as well as seventy
two point eight percent of eligible students taking our alternative assessment for science
which is also important right for us to look at and incorporate into the overall results
as well.
So therefore this year our work plan includes continuing the process of providing the link
on for each school and lea through our additional reports website and we have a flyer in fact
helping people identify where that information is and then in late two thousand twenty three
twenty four when we are in receipt of another additional year of data and will evaluate
the inclusion of science into the dashboard so we will you know that information will
come through and our ability to engage in that information will I promise begin right
after we get that data in and move forward late this fall and then finally an update
on a student level growth model.
This process began in January twenty seventeen when the state board discussed the initial
criteria for selecting a student level growth model to be used for school and district level
accountability and if my memory serves pretty much every state board meeting after that
and both some update on the growth model moving forward until we reached May twenty eighteen
when the state board directed the CDE specifically to explore residual gain models for possible
inclusion in the dashboard and right after that we took a small pause in developing things.
We came back in May of two thousand twenty one and approved the empirical best linear
prediction the EBLIP model weighted average methodology for measuring student growth and
that fall we were able to release all of our the data that we use to evaluate and adopt
the EBLIP for use and so we released that historical data from two thousand seventeen
to two thousand nineteen for folks to preview and get a sense of what growth data would
look like when in two thousand twenty four we are able to release that data again.
So the first official set of student level growth data will be released in the fall of
two thousand twenty four utilizing the two thousand twenty one twenty two twenty two
twenty three and twenty three twenty four data.
The weighted average and the necessity for using a weighted average if anybody needs
a refresher on that I would go back to the May twenty twenty one meeting to walk through
how we really need those three years in order to provide valid and reliable results for
student level growth model so therefore just that's the first time we can do it is in
fall of twenty twenty four.
However that doesn't mean that we can't do anything this year and therefore we are working
as we speak on soliciting feedback from focus groups educational partners as well as you
this year on the best approach on how to display growth data to various audiences and specifically
we are looking at parents or looking through and speaking to parents or looking to speak
to more invested researchers right a little bit you know LEA users and such and get all
of the perspective that they can share on the best way for us to access and display
information in a clear and cohesive way because if this information is going to be accessible
through the dashboard in some way we feel that onus and responsibility that it is clear
and it makes sense to everyone that's engaging with it we don't want to add any additional
confusion and as you know from the dashboard right we are looking for a clear and cohesive
way to be able to share that information with all of our parents and educational stakeholders.
Now finally this is the last point before I bring Cindy back up is our work plan for
addressing data quality issues and this has been you know something that Cindy spoke to
earlier about our chronic absenteeism data right things coming through in the bumps and
bruises that we have in data collection in those early years.
So this year we are looking to specifically explore the alignment of implications for
both schools and LEAs that fail to certify their data in our California Longitudinal
Pupil Achievement Data System or CALPADS or if they identify issues in their data submission
following that submission and report to the CDE that that data is incorrect.
This year we have had many instances of that occurring and happening and we are looking
for some direction on how we would like to universally handle and work with the implications
of what that means in either not submitting data in a timely way or any data in the system
or identifying that it's incorrect after the fact.
So we're also going to in trying to align all of the indicators on the dashboard review
our participation rate penalty for the LPAC and provide suggestions and alignment for
the participation rate and how it's incorporated into the LP specifically in alignment with
how we currently measure participation on our English language arts and math indicators.
So we would like to have some consistency across all our indicators and expectations
for participation on our assessments and we would like to align that participation rate
so we'll be looking with our workgroups and working with our educational partners to see
how best to do that and with that I will invite Cindy back up to close this out.
Thanks Kim and I think Kim failed to mention that she is a manager in our division.
She is the manager of the Accountability Development and Policy Analysis Unit.
She has a colleague Ryan Lamb who is responsible for measurement and technical analysis
and those two together produce the dashboard so we have a fantastic team
at the department that the administration has consistently supported with more positions and
funding when asked for to put out what you see today to respond to again numerous questions
from not only the public but our local educational agencies to support them with these efforts.
So just to close out the California Petitioners Advisory Group is your title one committee of
practitioners which is required under the Every Student Succeeds Act.
They meet a couple of times a year and we always take first to them anything we're going to take
to you and we get their feedback. So member Glover Woods is your representative or liaison to that
group and she participated in the meeting last month but specifically just wanted to briefly
give you their feedback. They do not vote on anything they simply have a lot of ideas about
how we can do things differently or suggestions for improvement. So they did discuss the revisiting
of the cut scores for the English Learner Progress Indicator and again looking at actually
splitting the cut scores into the school type. So elementary, middle versus high school which is
what we have actually for our suspension indicator. They also talked about chronic absenteeism
and looking at support determinations that their words saying not fair due to COVID that students
need to stay home because of the requirements from local health departments. Also looking at
the growth model as support for that looking at school climate which you're going to hear a lot
about in the next item and then not only support for science but support from links to the science
assessments. There was also interest in looking at a long-term strategy for the college indicator.
You may hear about that at a future meeting. We did have a lot of some consternation about where
we're at right now with that. Additionally looking at a balance of new information
and just an overwhelming amount of information that's being asked to be added to the dashboard.
So sometimes we don't get to make that decision. The legislature sometimes tells us
things that need to be added and with your feedback we make sure that we meet those
requirements. But there is limited resources or limited real estate rather on the dashboard
and it can become very overwhelming if we add every single data point that someone asks for.
So that was a consideration from one of the practitioners on the group who I believe is a
local superintendent in the Sacramento area. Also interest in looking at the criteria
for differentiated assistance and specifically looking at our dashboard alternative school status
schools. There was support for exploring the multiple extended year graduation rate
and then there was also interest in refining the dashboard look for an easier view
and access and so even though we've done a revamp of this once there still is interest in
again continuous improvement. So for next steps for you all we'll be back we'll be back probably
between September and now to talk about other things but for September specifically our goal
is assuming that you'd like us to proceed with this work plan that we complete the English Learner
Progress Indicator and we provide you updates and suggested revisions to state indicators
as needed. We also Kim Kim talked about the business rules updates and then finally some of
these pieces that you would that you would potentially make decisions on require us to
reopen the Every Student Succeeds Act state plan and submit an amendment. So we have had some early
discussions with the U.S. Department of Education they are very aware of what we're doing in
California it's nice to have that open dialogue and they are ready to help expedite those
amendments should should you all approve them in September. And so just to close out we have
been busy we've gone to a lot of conferences we've done a lot of virtual meetings and so
you can see just the amount of of efforts for those activities for the time in which we last
updated you back in November. I also just wanted to give you a preview of some things that we're
tracking when we look at the dashboard itself. We use Google Analytics and we're seeing an average
for the last three months of about 500,000 views as far as unique users of course that's a much
smaller number but we are able to look at you know which pieces folks are looking at which
districts they're looking at sort of like a top 10 list who's using the pdf function which has been
something that districts like to use especially as they're preparing their local control and
accountability plan. So those are things that we'll try to incorporate in future items but I just
wanted to give you a heads up this tool is being used of course it has to be used for certain
things but we do believe that you know members of the public are are utilizing it as well and with
that I will put up the recommendation and I do have the slide for public comment.
All right having taken account of the recommendation why don't we go ahead and
put up the slide for public comment and so we'll open the phone line for the public comment queue
while we then take some public comment in person. Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so in person or by calling the telephone number and using the access code
provided on the slide that's shown now while we're waiting for members of the public to call in I
want to ask our liaison vice president Glover Woods if she has any initial comments for me
and then I'll add some we'll see if we have any clarifying questions before we go to public comment.
Yes thank you president Darlingham and just a couple of points to bring forward for consideration
as we go into our discussion but let me pause and just first thank Cindy and her team for the
phenomenal work that goes into ensuring our accountability system reflects what the board
both present and previous have called to do it's they make it look easy and it is not I realize
that very very much and I also appreciate Cindy and her team for the way they are really on a
road show if you will they don't just stay here in Sacramento but they make themselves available
at a variety of conferences and meetings to be able to share as well as to be able to get feedback
so thank you so very much and I will say that I believe our 2023 work plan is indicative of the
philosophy we have for our accountability system which is continuous improvement and we continue to
look at pieces that are working in the way designed and expected and also look at how we
might be able to do things improve that's what continuous improvement is so just a couple of
very quick areas for us our consideration I want to start first with the LP and just to encourage
and help us to remember that this will be the first year the 2023 dashboard is going to be the
first year that I since we've had a break that we're going to have the performance level grid
that's going to be based on both status and change similar to some of our other indicators so as we
are considering where adjustments may need to be made as it relates to cut scores on the status
side and even on the change side I just encourage us to let's get the first full performance level
grid let's take a look at how that indicates where our schools our LEAs are as far as eligibility
for differentiated assistance and other support and then as necessary engage in conversations
about making changes but we we don't have the full picture in front of us just yet and I think it
will be important for us to do that before moving forward as it relates to the graduation rate
indicator just to encourage our partners at CDE to keep us informed on how the modeling goes
when we are looking at applying that multi-year graduation rate I think it's a great step that
we're going in that direction and we want to be sure that our DOS schools are benefiting just as
well as the other schools so it'll be important to similarly to how we had that modeling for
differentiated assistance when we knew there were going to be some changes and we kind of got a
preview of this is how many the number of LEAs that are going to be eligible in comparison to
past years I think something like that will be helpful as we explore utilizing a multi-year
graduation rate but quite excited about going down that road as well and I'll close my comments
with chronic absenteeism and again thank you Cindy for including and spending the first portion of
the presentation to clarify how the chronic absenteeism indicator is determined as well
as giving us the data that is available on data quest and I want us to be sure
especially in light of the comment that was made at the close of the presentation that people are
accessing this step the dashboard and utilizing that dashboard to make decisions how might we
indicate on the dashboard the impact of the data well the impact that the data has had
based upon what we know has been the the messaging and expectation for student attendance as it
relates to the pandemic so let me clarify because I want to be very very clear our chronic absenteeism
rate of course is including much more than just what has happened as a result of the pandemic
but we also know that the messaging has been when students returned and especially with the vaccines
not being available that it was safe to stay home students should stay home for their safety as well
as the safety of staff so I do have a strong belief that that has had an impact on the past
chronic absenteeism data that we've had in the past year or two knowing that and moving forward
looking out the windshield and not the rear view mirror if you will LEAs need to very much so
really dig into why their chronic absenteeism data is what it is to ensure that it's not just
the assumption that it's a it's a result of the pandemic there may be some other causes as well
as the county offices that are supporting those that are eligible for differentiated assistance
as chronic absenteeism is one of those data priority areas to really again just dig into
let's not assume it's just the pandemic but we do need to acknowledge that the pandemic and the
response and the messaging that we have given to schools and to families has had some impact so
I'm wondering on the dashboard is there a way that we might be able to indicate I don't know
quite what that might look like but considering the use of it and I'll close my not so brief
comments at this time thank you very much I'll add mine simply to say that yes I think we're
we're going to have to think about chronic absenteeism differently it's not that that year's
I don't think we can assume that that year will be a blip from the pandemic I think we're going to
continue to see climate related disasters and other things that confuse the question
as you put it of what is something that is students not getting to school when they could
and should versus not being able to be in school and so I do think that we're going to have to
re you know continue continue to think about how to evaluate that that indicator and maybe even
consider whether we want to change the way in which we disaggregate or collect the data
I mentioned in my earlier remarks too that you know we asked districts during the first year
of the pandemic to prepare a continuous instruction plan so that they were prepared you know to be
able to get laptops to students and you know keep them learning that idea originally came from
to me from Miami Dade where they had done that because of flooding and where it's a continuous
part of the planning so I think there are these kinds of issues that we're going to need to take
up I really want to give appreciation as well to the team that's been doing this work they're doing
amazing work and you can see the work plan is very ambitious we appreciate it I think the
directions that you're going in terms of thinking of additional indicators are all things that are
going to be very helpful to us in terms of the extended graduation rate in terms of expanding
the CCI in the ways that you described I think we'll need a new acronym for eBLIP
we'll have to figure out what we're doing with that and I'll just simply note at this point
that I would love for us to plan down in the near term future for some additional
presentation to the board about that indicator I know when we looked at it you know a couple
of years ago as we before the pandemic there are going to be issues because you're trying to link
the same student to their own record in the same school there are places where you get a very small
sample size and you cannot maintain an indicator for some schools and so we're going to have to
think through how we handle those kinds of things and so I just love for us to get something on the
agenda in the next couple of meetings so we can begin to think about about how we're going to
take advantage of the possibility of a growth measure and get a new acronym
and with that I'm going to see if there are people who are ready to provide public comment in person
we have one person in the room Andrea Ball from Orange County Department of Ed
hi good morning thank you Andrea Ball here on behalf of the Orange County Department of Education
I was here three years ago at your last in-person meeting I'm pretty sure I was speaking on behalf
of Orange County Department of Ed anyway it's great to have you all here in person so thank you
President Darling-Hammond, Chief Deputy and board members the Orange County Department of Education
supports the points made in the letter you received from the county superintendents
related to item three and I just want to call out two points and examples from Orange County
on the English language progress indicator we support the CDE's recommendation on the work plan
and I just want to say that Orange County Department of Education has been the state lead
on the multi-tiered system of support grant program the statewide grant program for about
eight years and as you all are familiar with that's a program or a framework to really provide
support whole child approaches to all students and Orange County has taken that approach in
the work they do across areas topics academic social emotional to support the districts the
28 districts in their county I saw that firsthand during the pandemic and so I want to say that
in relation to the English language learners for example Orange County is actually
a national and regional center for the guided language acquisition design model known as guide
and they work using research-based methodologies to support English learners in the 28 districts
the over 400,000 students in their county and we think this approach is really important and to
keep in mind so we do support the CDE recommendation for this indicator to continue working on that
before making a change second I want to thank you I want to thank the department for the work
on the graduation indicator for the DOS schools Orange County has a large alternative education
program working with students referred from different districts involved in the juvenile
justice system and really support the work the department has been doing and trying to do with
this federal department of ed on this indicator so we look forward to being a part of that
ongoing work group thank you again for all your work and the department too for this great presentation
thank you and I think at this point we can move to the caller queue on the phone
uh it looks like we have a roughly around 34 people signed
up for a public comment on the phone I will open the phone right now
good morning state board of education please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
good morning my name is Vanessa Calderon assistant principal at Chano Island
high school over Ventura county over the last several years the one item from um fpm instruct
instrument that has consistently call out of compliance is designated and integrated ELD
sadly there's a lack of urgency to improve the district and school site ELD programs
and with only 24 school districts having to address their students progress
in learning English as designated by the ELIPI status results the evidence from the federal
program monitors should urge us to revise the ELPI status cut scores large improvement in the
district and school English language development program and instruction as a former ELD student
learning English as a second language at the high school level I firmly believe that our
high school ELD students deserve quality ELD programs that are going to support students to
achieve English proficiency to be able to move into higher education we request a review of
the ELPI status cut scores so that ELD in my county can be supported thank you thank you
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time
starts now
caller with the last president board members go ahead yes my time good morning madam president
board members my name is dr kovionetta hovenfellas and i'm calling on behalf of the law school
district we support the cd's work plan to maintain the ELPI cut score methodology
Los Angeles is unified as closely monitoring the performance of English learners students as
we strive to support their academic and social emotional needs we provide support to teachers
to professional development and model high quality ELS and regarding the college career indicator we
are pleased to see the integration of additional measures that reflect the experiences of high
schools today we have concerns on the ability of aptitude tests to demonstrate college career
readiness we believe the other three proposed measures have the potential to demonstrate much
greater significance in college readiness than aptitude tests aptitude tests may be great indicators
of the military but they should not be an appropriate college and career readiness indicator
we support the inclusion of industry certifications however the state needs to identify these
certifications for each industry sector estimated colleges offer a wide variety of certifications
but they are not necessarily industry recognized lastly we wonder whether paid and unpaid
internships will be considered and look forward to providing additional feedback as cd continues
to update the cci thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi good morning my name is marisol madrigal uribe and i'm a school board member for the
monobel unified school district because it does appear that time community school is attempting
to blame part of its fiscal mismanagement on monobel unified i do feel compelled to provide
a public comment on this matter monobel unified school district has always and we continue to
by the requirement yes i'm sorry color i'm going to stop you right there if you don't mind calling
back in for item 10 please thank you oh okay okay thank you very you're welcome next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
morning president darling hammon and members i'm carlos machado with california school boards
association which represents nearly a thousand school districts and county boards of education
statewide cspa is a member of the coalition that supports the cde's 2023 work plan for the english
learner progress indicator echoing echoing board member uh board vice president glover woods
comments we ask the state board to retain the cut scores as previously set for at least the 2023
dashboard cycle a complete lp indicator will be an important tool to lea's to identify improvements
that will help serve the needs of english learners thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning my name is erica cervantes calling on behalf of alliance for better community we
are a latino policy and advocacy organization here in la we work closely with parents and
families in la county and la usd recognizing that latinos make up almost 75 percent of students in
la usd and looking at the unique needs of these students especially their linguistic needs
we recognize that although not all latinos students in our english learners a large
majority are in their places a prioritized population for us we raise similar concerns
that have already been highlighted by some partners again according to lp nearly half of
el's did not make progress toward english language proficiency in la county less than half of el's
made progress toward english proficiency or scored at performance level four based on the lp we
request a review of the lp status clip scores so that el's in our county can be supported and
attain english proficiency thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
madam president members this is eric greenack with charter school development center calling
in support of the work on the alternative graduation rate methodology and thanks cde staff
for their hard work on that they correctly noted that the one role of the dashboard is to identify
schools in need of support what they haven't mentioned though is that the dashboard is also
used for very high stakes charter school renewal decisions and we would like to see
the work plan expanded to review whether the indicators that are used in the charter renewal
process are sufficiently stable coming out of the pandemic and methodologically sound for use in
that high stakes purpose and we would like to see the work plan broadened to address that those
issues as well thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
hello my name is melanie morales vanhecht and i am an assistant director at lmu center for equities
for english learners our center recommends that the lp cut score thresholds be adjusted to expect
that more students attain annual growth our l cap analysis and statewide compliance reviews point
to a widespread need for lea's to focus on comprehensive eld for english learner students
however the lp is not speaking to that same need current cut scores that assign a very low status
when less than 35 of el's make one level growth set low expectations and do not provide district
data to create the needed urgency to improve el programs we request a review of the lp status
cut scores so that the lp can be a catalyst that sounds the alarm for lea's and moves them towards
more supportive practices so english learner students in california can be supported in
attaining english proficiency thank you thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello i'm sally fox representing the california association for bilingual education i'm also a
native san diegan a retired bilingual educator and a certified trainer for ocde project glad
as you know california public schools serve over six million k-12 students over a million of whom
are emergent bilinguals my comment today relates to the lp scores not being focused
on equity for these linguistically diverse students advocates for english learners continue
to warn that the current cut scores for the lp create complacency in our system when only half
of el's make annual progress towards english proficiency and that doesn't raise any alarms
for district administrators we're missing opportunities to improve programs and the
quality of instruction our expectations should be set in order to produce equitable outcomes
not to maintain gaps from years past please prevent this inequity so districts that need
to improve their programs will be supported to do so thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello good morning good morning i'm carla santa cruz formerly known as carla herrera when i was
an iqc member title three los angeles county office lead and a district el program specialist
los angeles county is home to 22 percent of el's in california among my previous laco positions
my title three team and i provided technical assistance to districts who had not made
sufficient el progress however now according to lp no districts in my county are going to receive
support this despite the fact that in la county less than half of the else made progress towards
english proficiency or scored at performance level four based on the lp lp should this low
bar be considered sufficient for math or english for your children or any group of our students
we request a review of the lp status cut scores so that el's and my county can be supported
to attain english proficiency thank you thank you next caller please state your name and
affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello my name is melissa martucci and i am a high school teacher in the series unified school
district my district serves a high number of latino and economically disadvantaged students
i was excited to see the cast results linked to the on the california dashboard for 2022 and
2023 indicating the importance and relevance of science in our communities however i feel it is
of the utmost importance to place science on the dashboard in a way that highlights and supports
the need to make science a priority in all districts especially at the elementary grade
level districts rely heavily on indicators from the dashboard for guidance on setting
budgetary priority thus i urge the state board of education to include a visible performance
level for the cast or even a status only icon and 2023 so that all districts and principals
can make science a priority as they develop and refine their l cap plans and treat the core areas
equally especially in elementary every year we wait to add science is another year science is
underfunded and or de-prioritized contributing to an overall state looking for highly qualified
scientists and engineers from other states or even other countries now is the time to change that
and provide greater opportunity for our students and strengthen our economic growth for our
community in some ways increase equity and opportunity thank you call your time is up
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts
now hello my name is leticia gracia on behalf of riverside county superintendent of schools
we support the education management coalition letter to maintain the lb cut scores through our
county level one support for our 23 school districts we offer monthly network meetings
where district el leaders focus on best practices and legal requirements to support their el students
whether in da or not we also intentionally reach out to districts with consistently low
performance on the lb and offer data and root cause analyses program evaluation training on
evidence-based practices workshops for district leaders principals teachers instructional coaches
one-on-one sessions with new district level el leaders customized services such as designated
and integrated eld support demo lessons intense intensive intervention again we ask that will you
stay the course on the lb cuts course at this time and if changes are necessary at a future date
we look forward to being part of that conversation thank you thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello my name is judan from go public school we and the families we serve are concerned about
the performance of english english learner students and as such we want to add our voice
to those who are encouraging the board to revisit the english learner progress indicator
standards to set higher expectations for district districts in their service of english learner
students the current status performance levels are inconsistent with students reaching
classification within the standard five to seven years which allows for schools to fail in supporting
nearly half of these students from making adequate progress on the road to reclassification
because of this the board should add to the work plan a revisit to the el pi performance expectations
prior to finalizing the change component
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time starts now
hi this is patty chavez with c l s e a l dot org acronyms are for reals thank you for your
presentation and your comments we look forward to seeing you at kabe the number of english learners
will only continue to grow ceo has provided professional development in more than 200
elementary and preschool and we're seeing success and through our work we know that whole school
strategy encourages district leaders critical educators to establish systems and practices
that support language development literacy and engaging joyful learning for all our students
and specifically our eels are thriving and succeeding we need this for our students
and for the future of the state a state where right now nearly half of the else do not make
progress toward english language profusion proficiency according to lpi this is alarming
it should give us all pause i joined my colleagues today to ask them to just go down
let's do this right for our students we request a review of the lp status cut scores
so all el can be supported to attain english language proficiency and we create a strong
foundation for now and into the future thank you thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
My name is Kim Moreno and I'm an educator with over 20 years of experience in San Diego County
where only three of 37 LEAs were identified as needing assistance for their english learners
so while I understand there is no minimum quota for identifying districts with very low status
there is a need to continuously revisit these scores when districts with only 50 percent of
their EL showing progress receive medium status it does cause concern my mind immediately goes to
this being a recipe for a continued creation of long-term english language proficiency
continued creation of long-term english learners in the state with the current cut scores over 99
percent of all California ELs were enrolled in districts that are not sized for needing attention
indicating our accountability system is not capturing the need of ELs for more support
this lends itself to EL programs not being given the attention needed to refine practices that
serve their students with district resources being diverted to other areas revising cut scores will
identify more EL LEAs needing support and hence their EL programs will have the support to
continue to improve I support the continued review of LP status prep scores so that our ELs in my
county can be supported to change english proficiency thank you for all the work that you do
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now
Pete Ahern president of the California Association of Science Educators speaking on behalf of the
coalition of science educators and organizations we are meeting tomorrow at the Exploratorium if
any of you would like to join us we are energized by what we heard about assessment yesterday and
especially our good friend Stephen Pruitt's insights we thank CDE for its work on adding
science to the dashboard let's talk about what we know about science education we know that
many careers and the future of California's economy are in STEM fields and the next generation science
standards are all about STEM engineering data science integration of math and technology
and computer science it's in the NGSS and we know that in learning to read students need to
engage with rigorous and compelling content like science we know that hands-on science with the
proper supports is a powerful vehicle for english language learning and despite this we have heard
from districts and administrators over and over again all over the state that they won't invest
in science because it's not on the dashboard and their priorities are set by the dashboard
please help us give students the science education they deserve by putting a science
status-only icon on the dashboard let's do this thank you thank you next caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning my name is Sarah Lillis I'm executive director of Teach Bus California
I want to thank the staff for all their hard work on the 2023 accountability work plan we're
really excited to see the development of the visualizations and communication materials for
the student growth data as well as the plan to begin objective criteria for the teacher
assignment monitoring outcome we share concerns about the need to revisit the lb
direct expectations we don't believe we can wait because we are worried about the message we're
sending if we are not setting up our students to be able to reclassify within the five to seven
years we also are eager to support the department in this year's work to develop communications and
visualization tools for the growth model but we would also ask the work plan reflect the outline
and timeline for the work necessary to add student growth to the dashboard itself as well as perhaps
revisiting a name change and as it relates to the college career indicator we urge the
board to direct staff to develop a plan and timeline for establishing a fourth level of
preparedness well prepared which would allow us to transform this into a college and career indicator
thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now my name is good morning my name is Lori Johnson
I'm an EL support teacher in the world academy newcomer program at Mount Diablo high school
in Concord California and I'm here this morning representing Contra Costa County
home of 28,000 English learners according to ELPI only one district in my county
is going to receive support for helping EL's in learning English thanks to the ELPI
this despite the fact that in my county less than half of English learners made progress
towards English proficiency or scored at performance level four based on the LP this year
in our specific newcomer program we have had over 100 newcomer students arrive in just six months
many are coming to us unaccompanied or with traumatic
backgrounds we respectfully request a review of the ELPI status cut scores so that English learners
in my county can be supported to attain English proficiency thank you so much thank you next
caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
now
caller and good morning my name is go ahead my name is Viviana Martin
good morning my name is Viviana Martin I'm a former English learner but today I'm here as one of the
U.S. California policy strategists one of the U.S. previously known as the National Council of La
Raza is the nation's largest Latino civil rights non-profit benefit network of over
300 community-based organizations we work to advance the academic needs of Latino and
more bilingual students across the country and in California it is imperative we support English
learners and the best way to do that is by making sure ELs with the lowest initial proficiency
receive the necessary support that will only be possible with the review of the LP status
cut scores our research shows that Latino families have high expectations
for their children including seeing them advance in English skills and academics
only those U.S. advocates for states to ensure that ELs are making meaningful gains in English
proficiency and set ambitious achievable goals for ELs California and we know that California
deserves a model for the rest of the nation we request a review of the LP status cut scores
so that California's ELs can attain English proficiency thank you thank you next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning president Darling-Hammond and members of the board Angelina Gutierrez representing the
LA county office of education we are in support of the recommendations for the 2023 accountability
work plans especially keeping the methodology for calculating the LP cut scores in alignment
with the other indicators we would also like to advocate that the SBE revisit the differentiated
assistance eligibility criteria specifically considering how to shift differentiated assistance
identification for county offices to ensure that eligibility effectively targets those with
county or in school thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning good morning this is Liz Guian with public advocates
Ms. Kazanis did a fabulous presentation and really emphasized that the dashboard
serves to inject urgency for improvement we believe strongly in the equity coalition that the
English learner performance indicator needs that urgency I echo comments by Sally Fox of CAVE which
are included in the equity coalition's written comments as the department and commission on
teacher credentialing continue to work on the teaching assignment monitoring data the TAMO
released last year we encourage them to conduct an analysis of the available teacher assignment
data by student group and include that information on the dashboard and an additional report such as
the school accountability report card we think that will help the establishment of objective
criteria by which to judge teacher quality and equity that was required by the legislature
at the school and the district level thank you thank you next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning my name is Araceli Simeon with the parent organization network we have been leading
campaigns to improve outcomes for English learners in three school districts for the past two years
we learned that teachers need support to provide ELD instruction and districts need better systems
to monitor progress furthermore we learned that many of our members who are engaged parents and
serve on ELACs and DLACs have children who have become long-term English learners despite having
A's and B's on their report cards and occasional fours on their LPAC tests overall there's an
incoherence in the system the reclassification requirements hold EL to a very high standard
for they must prove three different ways that they're fluent in English but the current LP
only looks at LPAC scores and the current CUT scores at low standards for LEAs our
recommendation is to align the LP to reclassification requirements otherwise the only
ones being held accountable to high standards and held back for it are the very students that it's
the LCFF is supposed to help thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning chair darling hamson board i am ken falls you have board member of action i would
do say unified school district a small rural district north los angeles county we're at the
competent direction of dr eric sahaki and as you know the annual publication of challenges at the
state level can be seen by some as an opportunity to compare and paint out LEA or even local county
levels as not as bad as most unfortunately percentile achievement bar comparisons inherently
discount and exclude success at the individual student level i agree with the vice chair who
just noted that consideration of individualities and responsibilities at the local level is key
as a solution to performance at the state level because local performance feeds state level
success tonight at the board meeting i will share my altruistic take on this part of CDE
meeting today and ask staff to compare our LEA numbers against the state trend and to celebrate
the successes that make our district unique in the statewide data and to take those successes
to work on the other parts of the pie chart that are not so desirable while taking advantage of the
state that will support the thank you your time is up what's in place thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
caller ending with the last four digits 7704 you are now live please start your public comment
yeah
okay moving on next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now good morning lindsey tornatory calling on behalf of the california
county superintendent thank you cindy and kim for your presentation especially for always making
very complex topics accessible for all of us as explained in our letters we support the cd's
proposal for the lp we want to point out that lea's do not wait until they are identified for
differentiated assistance to provide support to their english learners for example county
offices have found great value in sharing the work of the e-week el roadmap with their district
specifically around disaggregating el data through the l cap which we all learned about during the
november board meeting also in our letter we request the board re-examine the da criteria so
that county offices with the highest needs are identified as opposed to all county offices being
identified in perpetuity we appreciate the attention to the grad rate particularly as it
pertains to dap however currently we do remain concerned the multi-year rate will not make a
difference but of course eager to discuss once data is run thank you very much thank you next
caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi this is robert manoring from children now first i want to commend the board and the cd staff for
their continuous improvement approach particularly around the teacher assignment monitoring science
assessment and growth models we look forward to seeing how these indicators are eventually
found find their way to the dashboard i also wanted to address the performance standards for
the lp as other public comment has suggested there's a need to readdress those the suggestion
the suggestion that there's a standardized process for looking at performance on a pure
percent distribution is is not true past boards have deviated substantially from that as an
example the very low cut score for one indicator is at the fifth percentile for another indicator
is at the 24th percentile similarly for the state performance levels the high bar that varies from
31 percentile for one indicator and 87th for a different one there's dramatic board input
in these standards and we hope that this board will relook at the the standards that you've set
for this uh and adjust them upward thank you thank you next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello my name is michael pelikowski i am the director of curriculum and technology for
gridly unified school district and i believe we are the small rural school district that
cindy kazanets referred to earlier in her presentation where currently at day 100 we see
54 percent of our tk students with chronic absenteeism and 47 percent of our k i call
today in reference to the criteria that are utilized for atsi determinations and how those
negatively affect small districts our mckinley elementary school is a tk through grade one
which as a result of its grade spans and small size really only has one indicator its chronic
absenteeism rate so it was identified for atsi on the basis of a single indicator chronic absenteeism
this also affects our gridley high school of about 650 students because we have small numbers of
english learners at the high school and students with disabilities uh they do not test in 11th
well they test but there is not enough students with disabilities or el to register
so also gridley high school was identified for atsi on the basis of a single indicator that of
suspension rate for its special education and el students i want to raise the board
awareness thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
hello i'm dr lena bocchi mccain board secretary for the california association of science educators
and executive director of the non-profit stem for real a professional learning organization
i also served as a former california science teacher and administrator i want to ensure that
science is seen as a prominent indicator on the california school dashboard i say prominent
because the indicator cannot be a series of clicks like the movie inception where the indicator is
hidden under various web pages schools and district administrators must view science as having equal
footing with mathematics and ela instructions otherwise science is not taught teachers have
explicitly stated that they cannot teach science every day because their time is focused on math
writing and ela demands our accountability system must support science as teaching every day
watch the magic that happens with decreasing chronic absenteeism and increasing language
acquisition for emergent bilingual students supported with research
thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
hi um my name is samantha schmidt and i am the teen and teacher coordinator for a non-profit
called gintana's wildlife society that provides outdoor education for youth and families along
the monterey peninsula and i'm also a member of the california association of science educators
environmental literacy committee i would first like to thank the school board of california for
allowing the space to speak on the importance of science and for me specifically the role of
environmental education within that field it would be so meaningful to see a science status
owing icon on the california dashboard as it would provide data links and other helpful resources
whether nature is brought into the classroom or on impromptu teachable moments on nature walks
environmental education has proven that there is an abundance of benefits for younger generations
school and especially educators environmental education also helps with social emotional
learning ecological culture and economic issues thank you so much for your time and consideration
with adding science on the california dashboard thank you next caller please state your name and
affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good evening this is manuel buenrostro with california together and we are again raising
concerns about the low expectations that are being set by the lp indicator and urge the board to not
rubber stamp low expectations for our el's we cannot claim to have an equity focused system
when despite the fact that nearly half of el's do not make progress towards english proficiency
we are still okay with only identifying 24 school districts and five county offices of education
this represents less than one percent of el's statewide this is also not even close to an
equitable distribution of leas as we're only identifying four percent of school districts
and coes that are eligible for an lp rating again according to lp nearly half of el's
are not making progress towards english language proficiency we again urge the board to look into
revising the lp cut scores and ensure that our lea's get the support that they need thank you
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now
good morning my name is angelica and i'm a resident in riverside county i have been a
bilingual educator for 30 years i have been a bilingual teacher district and site administrator
and presently i'm a county office of education administrator where i lead multilingual programs
and i provide services to 33 districts i attended the bilingual coordinators network
on february 16th where the discussion on the lp cut scores occurred most of my colleagues
are concerned for our english learners because the current lp cut scores will not reveal the
real need in all districts in california we believe in our english learners and have high
expectations for them we urge the board to improve the status cut scores for english learners and
revise the lp status cut scores before developing the change and the five by five grid for change
again we request the review of the lp status cut scores so that el's in my county can be
supported to attain english proficiency thank you thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
you
caller ending with the last four digits 0 4 1 4 you are now live please start your public comment
good morning my name is elissa nimichkova fairfield i am affiliated with the california
association of science educators as a former board member and current policy committee member
i'm an elementary instructional coach in palm springs unified school district
and a parent of a california student with special needs i would like to first thank the cde and
state board for their commitment to all of california students we need to see an icon for
science on the dashboard this would be a clear indicator clear signal to lea that they need to
invest in science education at all levels science results in a tab or pull down menu are not
sufficient to signify science education as a priority and because of this lea's have not
adequately invested in science professional learning for teachers science can be integrated
into daily elementary and education to support improving california students literacy skills
science provides authentic and common experiences that give students equitable background knowledge
they require to be able to comprehend the text that they read students love science but unfortunately
are not given access to it daily due to the prioritization of subjects that do appear on
the dashboard please help us give our students the education they deserve by placing a science
icon on this year's dashboard thank you thank you next caller please state your name and
affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning my name is ruth barajas with californians together we're very concerned
that the cda's work plan does not include a review of the lp cut scores for status
we believe the current status performance levels are far too low and inconsistent with
the research findings that el should be expected to reach reclassification within five to seven
years others have mentioned and i will reiterate that those current cut scores only identify one
percent of el's for support yet california has nearly half of the el's 49 not making progress
or who are below four level four proficiency if we look at identifying numbers based on
percentile distribution which is based on the actual data some people would call this
maintaining the status quo this is a big concern especially if you want to prevent high numbers
of long-term english learners in the future shouldn't a system of accountability hold all
of us accountable to our student success we're asking you to slow down and revise the status
cut scores for lp please thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi sarah kennedy at the california association for bilingual education
previously i've worked in multiple california charter schools as an educator and el coordinator
and now collaborate with counties and districts across the state so i know the importance of
ensuring that all students get the support they need to progress in english proficiency
looking for progress each year a student is with us should be the bare minimum and i'm concerned
about the low bar set by the current cut scores as so many others have mentioned as an educator
and advocate having less than half of students making progress would indicate a clear need for
support and further analysis but the current cut scores that is labeled as medium status is
progress for less than half of our students acceptable for california we request a review
of the lp status cut scores so that eels in our state can be supported to attain english
proficiency thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now good morning patty Herrera on behalf of the
association of california school administrators as part of a statewide education coalition
access support cde's proposed work plan for the english learner progress indicator
furthermore lea's proactively assist english learners well before they are identified for
differentiated assistance if ever for example one of our districts offers daily eld through a
deployment model based on lpac performance levels and domains they provide on-demand model teaching
or side-by-side teaching moments and integrated eld professional development to all teachers in
order to support their english learners throughout the comprehensive program parental support is
also offered through literacy nights and through a nine-week course that shows them how to better
support their students and how to navigate the education system as a whole therefore we think
the answer to better supporting our english learners is in leveraging the level one universal
resources that are available available to all lea's regardless of da status thank you thank you
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts
now my name is arlene laurason i am a 912 science teacher from elk Grove unified school district
and a member of the california association of science educators on the ngfs committee
we appreciate the work that you have done in promoting science education in california
thank you as a 912 educator who has been using ngfs since 2014 i know firsthand that the students
entering my class are behind we are asking that an icon for science be added to the dashboard
this will send a clear message to districts to increase funding for science why is more funding
needed currently the vision of the california front framework for science education for all
students is not being met most elementary school teachers as well as science teachers in general
are not prepared to use the new instructional shift and many of them have inadequate instructional
materials to assist them the k-12 progressions outlined in the framework are not possible if
students enter middle school with a science background resembling swiss cheese science
education will not improve unless funding is increased please add a science icon to the
dashboard thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for
the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning presidents don lingham and the members of the board i'm dr huling lee executive
director of authentic preparation today or apt a statewide group that has been collaborating cde
on the state seal civic engagement since 2018 we appreciate and support your articulated vision
of migrating the cci to ccci to include civic readiness when the seal was approved and your
direction to form the civic engagement work group to support this vision however that effort has
been halted due to calc has upgrades the civic field is a very important indicator because high
quality civic engagement projects encompass relevant rigorous and engaging student learning
experiences and authentic assessments that support college career and civic readiness
however given the lack of state support for consistent implementation there are equity
issues playing out in the field so i would like to request for the state to reinstate the civic
engagement work group to ensure that equity and excellence is adhered to and the field will be
included in the dashboard thank you thank you that concludes public comment for item number three
all right thanks to everyone who's called in thanks again to the staff for all of the work
we're now open for board discussion
member roscoe gonzalez
and listening let me make sure and listening to all the comments and and cindy and your team's
presentation um you know i come back and i kind of reinstate some of the comments that i did in
july i mentioned the importance of having a science icon on the dashboard sorry it's hard
to speak with a mask this would provide districts and schools with a clear message that science
results are important and that science instruction needs to be planned and implemented and that
science learning matters when we have discussions about chronic absenteeism i know firsthand as a
science teacher that science gets kids excited about coming to school to explore and work on
hands-on experiments even yesterday during our assessment study session
that was even some of the conversations over performance tasks and them
continuously working on these performance tests in science and it aligns to our principles
focusing on elements that express the commitment to a well-rounded well-supported education
a clear visual visualization and clear communication when it comes to like principle seven
i think it's also critical that the CAS be included on the dashboard in 2023 because
districts are unlikely to make investments and improve science instruction if it's not clear
on the dashboard i know as a teacher when we have conversations around assessments in the dashboard
mostly they're around language arts and mathematics and with a background in science and a father
i mean my father was an engineer i always think of the importance of
continuously bringing shedding light to the to school districts how important
equally important science is so i think that we should look into that as part of the work
that we go we do as we go forward thank you cindy do you want to remind us what the status of
science as a element on the dashboard is sure i'm happy to review science and so we are waiting for
another year of test scores so the 2023 administration that i guess is probably
starting any day now will help to feed into allowing us to look at establishing cut scores
for our science indicator i think what is unclear to us and what we need to explore with you all
in 2024 is where does this live does it live as part of the academic indicator you know how
is it used or is it used in differentiated assistance how is it used or is it used for
identification or eligibility for school eligibility under the every student succeeds act and so
there's some real deep policy considerations that we will absolutely elevate
as we move forward with reviewing those those cut scores and so at this time the way that we
have approached science per your direction is it is available off of the dashboard there is a link
from the dashboard it is one click away i think what what you are asking for member
gonzalez is that we we put it as an icon and an icon for for the for the dashboard means something
there's usually something that looks like the dashboard numbers behind it and because we don't
yet have that available set of data we can't provide the context that we're used to seeing
on the dashboard and so i believe what you may be proposing may lead to some confusion if it was
elevated as an icon prematurely but with that said we have provided support for this for this
metric through through a flyer and i think if anything because we've had so much interest from
the science community is again presenting to to their audiences or to others maybe it's through
cisc just talking about how you know our road ahead and that we welcome everybody's input as
this develops into a potential indicator thank you and i think there's a just to flag for the
board a question that we'll need to take up when we when the dashboard was designed it was designed
with the idea of let's bring the state and federal accountability systems together so what's on the
dashboard is used in the federally required determinations of districts that will be
you know in a supporter intervention context we we can make a decision if we you know deliberate
on it and choose to do so that there would be things on the dashboard that are not used in the
federally required determination that would be a very different decision than the board had made
before which you know they made that decision for good reason to try to bring things together but
you know that that's a part of the context here is what is going into those determinations as
well as what goes on the dashboard the department of education has actually invited states to
revise their plans and to incorporate additional indicators especially of learning opportunities
and they have made it clear that they stand ready to look at those you know
um potential changes and cindy let us know earlier that we will be going back
around some of these things so it's a it's a conversation for us to have on another day
because we won't have time today to have that big conversation and i think it would be very
helpful as we come back to some of these things if you could put the lp slides back up again
because there's a lot of commentary in that and i wonder if everyone is understanding the
indicator the same way so i don't know if you can find those and help us with that again
my understanding is as you explained it earlier was that the progress on the the number of students
making progress on the indicator is determined by how many move from you know like level one to
level two or level two to level three is that correct level three to level four
yeah yes that is that is the calculation and then there are four levels right there are six levels
there are four levels of of lpac and it's translated into six levels for the lp so
you can see on the so just wanted to make sure which slide you were yeah and so if a student
moves up a level in the six levels they are counted as making progress on that indicator
and so the assumption underneath it is that if you have
um moved up a level every year you would have acquired english language proficiency if you
started at the bottom level in six years is that is that the right way to be interpreting that
yeah yes and that's so it's a little more ambitious that many people say five to seven
years is the sort of expectation so it's a little more ambitious than the upper
um tier of that a little less ambitious than the lower tier of that and then when you look at
the cut scores for district identification this is the percent of students making progress
toward proficiency it's not the percentile ranking of the district against other districts
it is the percent of students making progress right okay just want to be sure everybody has
it because i heard it referred to as percentile rankings of districts which is is not what's going
on just so everybody's clear that this is about the movement of students and these are these are
matched students as well so you're we're looking we were able to capture the same student moving
through the the system and what a student changes schools or districts um what is the rule about
where they are counted so we would be able to capture them at their last um school or
or district as reported in the california longitudinal pupil achievement system that's
one of the advantages of having a statewide identifier for every student in public school
in california is to allow for credit to be received at the last place in which the student
was enrolled so um there's a question that um that was bubbling around is whether whether this
is really a criterion reference system it really is a criterion reference system the number of
students who make progress each year the percentage of those is set to the criterion that is on the lp
or on the lpac and then translated over to the lp so it is a criterion reference which means that
the percentage of districts that falls in any one of these categories in a given year will change
based on the progress of the students how many of the students make a category of progress each year
i just want to start the conversation if there is any question about this just with us all being
clear about what's what's going on yes um member terry yashimoto thank you board president
just briefly i wanted to just say about the science assessment um i second your interest
in urgency around it but i now understand that there is a lot of conversation that has to happen
so for another day but that is where a lot of other content areas come together and students
interests um heighten so on the lp
i'm going to separate the conversation around differentiated assistance from the experience of
our young people for just a minute because at the risk of oversimplifying my concept of
differentiated assistance it like a common fairy tale i always think of it as like having too many
schools for differentiated assistance not enough schools identified for differentiated assistance
and the just right amount and it seems like with nclb we had too many schools it seems like now
there may be not enough schools identified and so i'm interested in hearing about the feasibility
of a solution that brings us to a just right amount um because i think we know that multilingual
learners um deserve the expectation to demonstrate annual growth uh to move levels and to address
sort of the experience of a young person their experience is very different if they haven't
reclassified by middle school uh and particularly by high school so it affects programming as you
know as many of you know i mean it affects programming it affects their ability to take
electives it affects their ultimate college and career outcomes and it's not just our multilingual
learners including our multilingual learners many of them are also duly identified as having uh
as being eligible for special education services so it's very nuanced around the supports that our
students need to be able to classify so i say all that to say there is a sense of urgency and i
worry that uh the current norm reference uh that on the status portion alone does under identify
uh supports and from a parent's perspective feels really feels low to me
when we look at the actual percentages of students that we're expecting to show annual growth
i'll pause there and and this may be another one that needs a deeper deeper dive um and um
i wanted to see if cindy wants to offer any comments about that but whether
we should be anticipating diving back in on that question
we look we look to the board for that direction i think we've you know what i've tried to convey
through the slide presentation and in prior presentations is uh the desire of the board to
have indicators that are designed the same and so that you can go to any one indicator and you
can look at the distributions of how they were set up and that it's not an arbitrary we expect
very low to be set at 50 that's that's not how the system was designed if there's a desire to
to change that and to have something that is different for this one indicator you know again
we're here to serve you and so we would we would take that direction i think you will see um you
know opportunities for um this metric to potentially identify more i mean i can't guarantee it because
i don't have i don't have the data for this coming year but with with the adoption of the change cut
scores that's where that's where really a lot comes in the expectation of if you're maintaining
or if you're declining you know you're going to be in the lower end of our performance um color
system on the five by five grid so you know we will be that is absolutely on our our plan um as
we've discussed already um that we will bring back in september but if there's something different
you want us to do with the status cut scores and revisit something that you've already adopted
again we would we would look for direction from from the board on and forgive me if this has
already happened and i you know neglected to attend to it but um i'm wondering if a memo on
this that gives us like the detailed data about the both the history and the current distribution
and the distribution each year would be helpful for people to really get their brains wrapped
around the history and the current status and then in september we can you know we will see
additional data we'll be able to think about what the path forward ought to be does that make sense
yes i think you're asking us to bring together um pieces that we've brought to the board at
various meetings and to their location um we cannot absolutely uh you know i think that would
help us and then when we have our next conversation we'll have all of the background yes i'm member
escapado and i understand that you know there's systems but i think the purpose right is to
hopefully utilize the data to inform instruction maybe create uh different systems and structures
to help students right and when i when i look at the task scores for english learners
they've they seem to be very low however when you look at re-designated students they're much
higher and i and i just wondered where's that sweet spot when you look at percentages moving
from one level to the other where where do they become reclassified and if we can somehow
figure out a way to look at that area of reclassification because really that is the
threshold that we want students to achieve right and and use that perhaps as a end in mind because
this is where we want we know when we look at the the facts that once you achieve reclassification
you're going to do well in many of those metrics so i just may be looking at the system in a
different way to ensure that we are focusing on the successes for students just just enough
that's helpful and i would just also offer i think it would be helpful for you all to be um uh
to know what the other indicators have because we don't have other indicators that have that
high threshold of over 50 for very in a very low status right so you know this operates as a system
and each of these were developed off of each other and so i think again historically it is
very in the you know in the weeds seems like you all want to delve into the numbers and so if we
could also provide the context for the other state indicators as a reference point because i think
one of the callers brought up that um i think some information that needs to be clarified
but yes we can do that as well um member ask about thank you and i don't want to you know
restrict our conversation oh but i do want to let you know we are not on point to get out early so
we're we should try to um you know give direction about what we'd like to have come back to us
remember go to woods so i just would say i think a more comprehensive discussion is needed
what i i fear is us piecemealing tweaking one part of the system and then another part of the system
without looking at the system as a whole so as we look at how to ensure that our english learners
are receiving the supports they need to make the progress and that our system is supporting that
and supporting lea's i think again we need to look at the system as a whole once we have the
performance level grid in place for 2023 that will help complete part of the picture
and then go into a deeper discussion and the other aspect as president darling hammon
acknowledged is us really looking at the intent of our system at the very beginning we were trying
to have a system that was one fold meaning meets both the need of the state and the federal as we
start looking at different areas i think it's part of the board's responsibility to discuss is
that still the direction that we want to convey for our students in our state and again with
the indicators do they all follow the same methodology are there certain indicators that
should follow a different methodology large conversations definitely not to be had today
but again i just encourage all of us to not piecemeal what we're doing but to
have a very comprehensive conversation looking at all pieces at the time in the future
thank you and i think with that um member o'connor do you have a did you want to make a motion
no i can make a comment on a motion like a very quick comment in a motion
okay um just thinking about the um very thinking of what you said about piecemeal
there's lots of places that we have data about how students and schools are doing that serves
for accountability and i think trying to make sure we're not putting everything in one place and
also knowing the breadth of other tools that we have would be useful
so yeah anyway all right i'll talk about that one later and my motion is to
um recommendation we probably should put the recommendation back up
yeah if you put the recommendation up i'd be happy to make it
board president as we're putting the recommendation back up i just wanted to say i
appreciate the idea of being thoughtful about this because it is from a district's perspective
important that we don't ping pong but i maybe would suggest even another study session like
we did yesterday i think this is very nuanced and study session you know on this accountability
set of questions is very uh very good idea i think it would be very helpful to all of us
to have that study session on the lpis and also um so what before we vote what is going forward
on the science icon are we going to um revisit that in our next that would be a conversation
for later we we don't have the data we would normally use to put an icon yet so we have time
to think about you know how that will appear when we have the data okay can can i actually
sneak in one other comment or question just related to the school climate um conversation i
i had raised previously the possibility of whether um examples could be brought forward as part of the
um sort of work in between now and september of looking at the age cohort of tk to five
which is the largest of six grades as compared to three or four for middle or high school
of even highlighting any sort of best practices for incorporating tk to three as distinct from
relying exclusively on fifth graders as the survey climate um this doesn't require a change
and we are also going to take up school climate in the next item right okay i thought we were
doing both okay the recommendation slide is is is up on my screen is it number 80
um yes it's number 80 all right i got it's up on my screen too
so i'd like to move that we
um yeah what it says there i would like to move
what she said that we actually have already provided guidance yeah that's why i'm not sure
what i'm that we are not taking any additional action yeah do we even need a motion my first
motion i'm failing
why don't we move to accept okay i would like to move that we accept the work plan proposed to us
by the department of education with the guidance provided is there a second for that motion
thank you very much uh all how do you want to do the vote uh kim dick do we do do we do a
roll call vote or we just could raise our hands now that we're in person okay all in favor say
aye and raise your hand aye any opposed any abstentions all right the motion passes thank you
so uh because we are going to try to you know accelerate our progress we're going to do some
agenda recovery i'm going to suggest that those who need a break and i'm sure everybody is going
to need a break at some point please take it as you need it and we're going to proceed ahead
and item four is the developing an integrated local state and federal accountability and
continuous improvement system and its recommended action require regarding the local indicator
self-reflection tool for priority six cd recommends that we approve the proposed
revisions to the local indicator self-reflection tool and that we provide further guidance on
these recommendations and this item will be presented by will McGee i will good to see you
please begin when you're ready i am gonna hand the gavel at some point to my vice chair so that
i will take one of those breaks and we apologize for the fact that you will have a moving crew
here no no worries and we understand totally so thank you for the introduction and good morning
president darling hammon vice president glubberwood state board of education chief deputy officer
nicely staff and community my name is william mcgee and i am the division director for the
student achievement and support division and so we will give you all a brief overview of the item
today the background on the development of the priority six self-reflection tool summary of the
recommendations and then comparison of the current tool prompts and proposed tool prompts and then
recommendations of next steps so quick background we were before you all in january of this year
talking about the item and we received information that provided the state board with
the background on the history of the priority six school climate tool based on the discussion at
the january meeting we revise a priority six climate self-reflection tool for use of the
beginning in the 2324 school year and so i'm excited to welcome back one of our administrators
mr dr strong who will talk to us about the recommendations of the changes and information
thank you director mcgee my name is joshua strong i'm the administrator of the local
agency system support office here at the california department of education president
harling hammon board member nicely or chief deputy nicely and board members it's a pleasure
to be with you today so in terms of summary of the recommended changes the recommended
changes are being provided to you in attachment two of the item the current item as it as the
current self-reflection tool as it stands is attachment one for comparison purposes but just
to provide you with an overview of the recommended changes first is to require leas to conduct the
school climate survey on an annual basis as opposed to every other year second to require
that the survey the report of the survey data be disaggregated by student group those would be the
student groups that are required within education code section 52052 the ones that are used within
the dashboard and our accountability reporting as well as calpads data thirdly to add an
introductory section within the self-reflection tool itself that provides a description of the
importance of school climate the research in support of school climate and the needs to use
current school climate data to inform comprehensive planning continuing on the fourth change that we're
recommending is to add instructions that provide lea's local educational agencies with clarified
guidance on how they're to address the narrative portions and then the most
probably the the biggest overall of the updates is related to the narrative prompts whereas before
there was one narrative prompt that was broken in that that had three components
use data use and and meaning we're proposing we're recommending to break those narratives
into three separate prompts each of which would be responded to by lea's the first of those prompts
would be to describe the local data including disaggregating the data by student group the
second would be to report key learnings including identified needs and areas of strength and the
third would be to describe the changes needed to address local needs what we want to do at this
point in time is take you through a brief look at those three particular prompts and compare
the current version to the proposed version so that you can see the differences so in the
current self-reflection tool under the data component the current requirement is to reflect
on key learnings from the survey results and share what the lea learned the proposed revision
to that you can see is more much more substantial describe the local school climate data survey data
including data disaggregated by student groups lea's using surveys that provide an overall score
such as the california healthy kids survey are encouraged to report that disaggregated
student group data as well as the overall student score and then responses lea's are also
encouraged to include an analysis of the subset of specific items on a local survey and additional
data collection tools that are particularly relevant to school climate and conditions
so pointing lea's towards those school climate and conditions piece within this data analysis
secondly within the meaning currently the meaning asks what did the disaggregated survey results
if applicable and other data collection methods reveal about schools in the lea such as areas
of strength or growth challenges and barriers the proposal that we're we're bringing to you today
the recommendation that we're bringing to you today for adoption
is as follows describe key learnings including identified needs areas of strength and what the
data reveals about schools in the lea determined through the analysis of data described in prompt
one including the data disaggregated by student group i do want to specifically point out to the
board that on this slide we're proposing to include a specific clause related to schools
in the lea which the current tool includes but the draft that you have in attachment to
did not include that's taking into account feedback that we heard from some of our educational
partners as part of input we want to ensure that we're not only looking at student groups
but we're also ensuring that there's comparability between schools when we're looking at that school
climate data so that the full picture of that school climate data is is being looked at and
analyzed by the lea so we want to ensure that that data revealed about schools in the lea is included
in that self-reflection tool third the use in the current self-reflection tool
the use is what revisions decisions or actions has or will the lea implement in response
to the results of for continuous improvement purposes why have you already implemented acts
if you've already implemented actions did you see the results you were seeking
the revised what we're proposing as the revision is describe any changes to existing plans
policies or procedures that the lea determines necessary in order to address areas of need
identified through the analysis of local data and the identification of key learnings
include any revisions decisions or actions the lea has or will implement for continuous
improvement purposes and and seeking to really hone in on not just the improvements that are
being made for continuous improvement purposes but within plans procedures policies and how that
overall analysis is informing the lea's decision making across the board at this
point i'll turn it back over to director mcgee in order to present the recommendation
thank you josh for that concise information
and so again board with that information and the feedback that we received from you all in the
community the revised recommendation is as follows beginning with the 23-24 school year the cd
recommends that the state board of education approve the proposed revisions excuse me
approve the repose revisions to the local indicator self-reflection tool for priority six
school climate additionally the cd recommends that the state board of education provide further
guidance on these recommendations and take additional action as deemed necessary and
appropriate so the next steps as well we are working with the comprehensive center to design
a process to explore the possibility of a small subset of standardized questions that can be
implemented per you all's desire and the community's desire and then additional details will be
available upcoming and will provide information via memos and regular updates to the board
and then with that said president darling hammon will turn it over to you
and i'm going to ask vice president clever woods if she has any comments as early as on
thank you and i'd like to just thank director mcgee and the department for being responsive
to the comments that were made at earlier board meetings around this particular item
and lastly just to say we know that the school climate survey for this particular local indicator
is so critical to performance that students make on the state indicators we were just talking about
chronic absenteeism and how students feel connected to school and how they feel about
the conditions at school impact if they come or not which impact the others so again thank
you so very much for these revisions and i turn it back over to you president darling hammon
thank you and i want to ask that we put the public comment slide up so that we can get folks into the
queue if they are going to call in members of the public who want to provide comment on this item
can do so in person or by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the
slide that is shown now and i just want to plus one to vice president global woods comments about
how much we appreciate this moving forward and really building on the comments that we've been
making in the recent board meetings and see if there is anybody in the room who wants to make
public comment or then if not moving to the phone line there is some public comment in the room all
right there is some i'm not seeing anyone did you say there's none or there is some none oh okay
sorry i misheard you i was waiting for somebody to appear
and do we have anybody on the phone line we do it looks like we have four or five callers signed up
i will open the public phone line up now
good morning caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time starts now
now
good morning madam president board members again my name is dr fabiana naranjo gonzalez and i'm
calling on behalf of los angeles unified school district we are grateful for the ongoing improvements
in school climate indicator we have always administered the survey annually and have
disaggregated survey results since 2019 and have posted them in publicly accessible dashboard
we have preliminary concerns about the possibility of standardizing the survey items that would be
used by all leas as cd staff continues to explore what the process for developing these items will
be los angeles unified staff welcomes the opportunity to be a part of the conversation
to help inform the outcome we'd like to share a perspective on the total number of questions
that may be added to ensure it will not result in survey fatigue the types of questions since
we have reservations about more open-ended qualitative questions rather than quantitative
and how these standardized questions would resemble the existing questions and efforts
already being administered by our district we expect the concerns in many of these questions
we have will be resolved and answered over the coming months as this process continues to move
forward and we look forward to being part of these ongoing discussions thank you thank you
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts
now good morning patty Herrera on behalf of the association of california school administrators
axel supports cde's recommendations and believes the edits will help lea's better understand
where their strengths and weaknesses are thereby creating a sustainable positive school climate
that fosters student success if the state were to explore the development or standardized questions
however axel would respectfully request to be part of the conversation we believe that it is
important to include the input of practitioners to administer these surveys interact and interact
directly with students and their families furthermore as the state continues to make
edits we would ask the state remain cognizant that there is a cost to utilize the survey
instruments and the and any adjustments to them thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning again board members this is luz guillen with public advocates
i want to appreciate the very quick turnaround of this item from the february board meeting
and especially the making the changes around the administration of the test from
every year to every year from every other year and also for making the change today
on the disaggregation of school level data we still have concerns though about some of the
other language in which we believe is still too permissive so for example in the introduction
yes the measurement of school climate provides lea's with critical data that can be used to track
progress it should be used to track progress and also in prompt one lea's using surveys that
provide an overall score are encouraged to report the score and they may include an analysis of a
subset of specific items we think this language should be strengthened to require that they report
the overall score thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning president darling hannan members of the board this is lindsey tornatory calling
on behalf of the california county superintendents express appreciation to william and josh for your
presentation and work to ensure students and staff have voice in ensuring their schools a safe place
arguably the most important indicator we use to measure our school success we would like to express
our support to the proposed edits to the lea self-reflection tool and also again express
appreciation to the board and cd for continuing to honor the local control flexibilities for lea's
to choose the tool that makes most sense for their unique communities also if the standardized items
are explored we request to be a part of this process thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi this is robert mandolin from children now i wanted to thank the board for
raise the deep dive that you did in january and following up so rapidly with these changes to the
tool and specifically for making the adjustments based upon feedback to add the school sub sub
analysis we look forward to continuing to make progress towards identifying standardized questions
a subset of standardized questions that can be included on all surveys we think that will be
really critical and being able to benchmark school climate against other schools and look
forward to working with staff as as that work continues thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning this is sarah lillis executive director of teach plus california and i also
want to echo the appreciation for the work of staff and the board in turning this around so
quickly we're really thrilled with the changes that have been made we're particularly supportive
of increasing the required cadence of survey administration from every two years to annually
and we appreciate the the quick response on the need for school level desegregation we also are
really eager to learn more about the process in developing the possibility of implementing a small
set of standardized survey questions as we shared previously meaningful accountability for improving
school climate for students requires that lea's analyze and report their climate data in
standardized ways and even more importantly that they use standardized surveys or at least
a set of standardized questions and we really appreciate the board's leadership on this
and we hope to also be included in the process our educators are very they they share
turnatory's idea that this is one of the most important measures in school performance and hope
to be a part of it so thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for
the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning again president darlin hammon and members of the board angelina gatera is
representing the alley county office of ed lego supports the cde recommendation for changes to
the priorities six school climate self-reflection tool and appreciates the maintenance of flexibility
so that ali may continue to choose which tools that meet their unique needs
and that concludes public comment for item number four thank you very much
we are very grateful to the staff for getting us to this point and appreciate all of the public
comment is there any more discussion
so i just wanted to add on to the next slide which i think is 13
um certainly also actually let me start by saying thank you to director mcgee for the
presentation and also appreciation for the move towards annual and disaggregated school
and student group data as we think about sort of the next steps in your work with the comprehensive
center and i just wanted to add on to the next slide which i think is 13
if there's the potential to highlight how some of the tk3 tk2 districts are actually looking at
the school climate work for the younger ages i think that that's a really streamlined way
to actually incorporate how to do this for districts that may not be doing it currently
so it's it's more looking forward but otherwise i'm very supportive of the motion
do we have a motion
i move that we approve the proposed revisions to the self-reflection tool
as outlined in the cde recommendations for this item i'll second it all right thank you very much
uh all of those um in favor say aye any opposed any opposed no
just want to be clear any abstentions all right the motion passes unanimously
all right and i really thank everyone for helping us move this along and we are going to continue
and uh there is going to be lunch served in a little bit and we're going to go out sort of
two by two and grab our lunches um and uh when will that happen at noonish okay around 1215
so meanwhile we're going to go right on ahead and take up the uh item five which is the state seal
of civic engagement program update and i think the cde staff are hanging in there with us on this
uh accelerated pace
good morning and thank you president darling hammon vice president glever woods
state superintendent of public instruction tony thurman and members of the state board
i'm cheryl cotton deputy superintendent of the instruction measurement and administration branch
at the california department of education the mask is very difficult to talk and breathe
at the same time
it's okay well okay thank you for inviting us today to share program updates about the state
seal of civic engagement or ssce you'll hear that a lot today we're especially happy to be here
during the first national civic learning week during which superintendent thurman was honored
to participate on a national virtual panel examining the role of civic seals and reaffirming
the civic mission of schools superintendent thurman and our civics team at the cde have been
excited to see the growing attention paid to civic learning and engagement at the statewide
level in recent years most notably with the passage of assembly bill 24 in 2017 which paved
the way for development and adoption of statewide criteria for the ssce in september of 2020 we've
been so excited to see the ssce develop since the 2020-2021 school year the first year the insignias
were available we will share more details about the ssce with you today but first i'd like to
briefly spotlight a few of the other civic initiatives that the superintendent and the
cde have been supporting the imab our instruction measurement administration branch continues to
work with the california court's power of democracy steering committee to promote the
annual civic learning awards and the popular judges in the classroom program the cde also
facilitates the annual u.s senate youth scholarship competition a highly competitive program that
recognizes high school students each year for their exceptional civic leadership and learning
the cd also promotes voter education and engagement efforts led by the secretary of
state's office including the california student mock election and high school voter education
weeks and finally the cde educator excellence and equity division or triple ed is also excited
to collaborate with california volunteers on the new california serves program which aims to
increase access to the ssce through high quality service learning you'll hear some more general
updates about california service program as well today
we'll begin with a general overview of the ssce as well as some information regarding the current
status of the ssce implementation and insignia requests i do want to share looking at the screen
this is a recent graduate from centennial high school in bakersfield current county he earned
the seal in 2021 through his exceptional civics engagement the student helped pass a board
resolution to recognize the loris where today in bakersfield city school district he led substance
abuse prevention programs for middle school students and hosted holocaust survivor talks
that's what this is all about
as established by the california department i'm sorry as established by california education code
sections five one four seven five one four seven zero through five one four seven four in 2017
the cde and state superintendent of public instruction worked with a variety of educational
partners to draft statewide criteria to guide local education agencies or leas in awarding
the ssce to students the state board of education adopted statewide criteria and implementation
guidance for awarding an ssce in september of 2020 this adoption opened the doors for leas
to develop and implement local programs to award the ssce to eligible students in their communities
soon after adoption of the criteria statewide organizational partners began supporting leas
throughout this process
and continuing the state the adopted statewide criteria states that students must earn an ssce
by being engaged in academic work in a productive way demonstrating a competent
and understanding of united states and california constitutions functions and governance of local
governments tribal government structures and organizations the role of the citizen
in the constitutional democracy and democratic principles concepts and processes the picture
displayed on the screen is an example of what the actual seal looks like
the adopted statewide criteria continue with participate in one or more informed civic
engagement projects that address real world real world problems and require students to
identify and inquire into civic needs or problems consider varied responses take action and reflect
on efforts it also includes demonstration of civic knowledge skills and dispositions
through self-reflection and exhibiting character traits that reflect civic mindedness and a
commitment to to positively impact the classroom school community and or society
leas may still choose to adopt additional local criteria but nevertheless all students who earn
an ssce must at minimum meet these five criteria to share more about this work i would now like
to introduce monique mcwayne she is director of the educator excellence and equity division here
at cde monique will provide an overview of the ssce implementation since the statewide criteria
was adopted in fall of 2020 and we'll also talk about updates related to the cal service program
and the ssce data collection thank you for the the invitation and this opportunity monique i'll turn
over to you thank you all right so good morning president darlingham and vice president glover
and um chief deputy nicely and thank you for letting me present today i am monique mcwayne
as sherald introduced and i have additional details on our state seal of civic engagement
so i'm going to start with the implementation components
local educational agencies that choose to offer the state seal of civic engagement are responsible
for developing their local programming before offering the award to eligible students local
programming refers to all local resources infrastructure requirements and procedures
that need to be determined in order for students to earn a state seal of civic engagement this may
include but is not limited to specific student requirements such as coursework assessments
civic engagement project guidelines requirements service learning expectations and or reflections
internal application procedures that students follow to earn apply for and receive the state
seal insignia and record-keeping procedures at the site school site and the local educational agency
because these decisions are made locally the requirements and process
for earning the state seal of civic engagement differ from district to district
the state seal of civic engagement is an optional opportunity local educational agencies at the
district or county level must have adopted local state seal of civic engagement programming in
order for the students to earn the seal students may not apply for an insignia directly from the
californian department of education all right some data i will now review the data on the state
seal of civic engagement insignia requests for the 2021-22 school year and the 2020-21 school year
this data is based on insignia requests submitted by local educational agencies in the spring of
2021 and 2022 in making these requests lea's or local educational agencies do not identify
the specific students anticipated to receive the state seal of civic engagement this data is not
collected via calpats or the californian longitudinal longitudinal public pupil achievement
data system the table shows data outlining the total number of insignia requests for each year
the state seal of civic engagement has been available and it breaks down these requests
based on the development on the document to which they will be affixed so diplomas general
education development or ged certificates certificates of completion grade 11 transcripts
or grade 12 transcripts please note that for a 2020-21 school year requests for transcripts
were not broken down by grade level so we do not have that data on our table
this data is posted each fall on our state seal of civic engagement webpage and then i would
i still like to highlight a couple of elements from the data one the total number of insignias
requested roughly doubled from 2020-21 to 2021-22 the number of the local educational agencies
also more than doubled from 28 local educational agencies to 65 local educational agencies
the number of insignia affixed to diplomas rose from 4794 to 8354 comprising an 83 percent
of total insignia requests for the 2021-22 school year no insignias were affixed to ged
certificates for 2021-22 while there were six in 2020-21 however the number of insignias
affixed to certificates of completion rose from seven to 59 1630 insignias were affixed to grade
level 12 transcripts for the 2021-22 school year and 61 were affixed to grade 11 transcripts
one of the challenges to earning the state seal of civic engagement in grade 11 is fulfilling
criterion two which requires students to demonstrate an understanding of the united states
constitution this is traditionally something students focus on in grade 12 local educational
agencies continue to develop strategies to help students fulfill the seal criterion two which
criterion two which also requires a student to demonstrate an understanding of not just the
california or the united states constitution the california constitution as well as tribal
systems of government as i mentioned in reference to the statewide state state seal of civic
engagement insignia data local educational agencies do not identify the specific students
anticipated to receive the insignia and it is not collected via calpads the state board of education
also discussed this while reviewing so and adopting the statewide state seal of civic
engagement criteria and recommendations that the cd and recommended sorry and recommended that the
california department of education investigate ways to incorporate additional criteria for
recognizing civic engagement in the college career indicator on the california school dashboard
okay sorry is that better
since adoption of the statewide criteria in september 2020 the ed my division the educator
excellence and equity division has worked internally with the analysis measurement and
accountability reporting division to facilitate a civic engagement work group
it met several times in 2020 and 2021 to invest what this possible additional
criteria may look like and develop recommendations for the incorporation of the civic learning and
engagement into the college and career indicator internal meeting internal teams are meeting
periodically to check in the work group reconvened in august 2022 to share updates and review
statewide state seal of civic engagement data while the re-architecture on calpads continues
at the county level the 2021-22 school year saw a significant increase in the number of counties
with local educational agencies that offer the state seal of civic engagement
11 more counties submitted requests for the first time in 2022
this is in addition to the 14 counties that requested insignias for both 2021 and 2022
general trends of course there have been a small number of local decreases in insignias
requested from 2021 to 2022 however the overall numbers of students earning a seal and the number
of local educational agencies offering the state seal of civic engagement has increased
this is especially notable given that the first two years of implementation coincided with the
covid-19 pandemic and the related school closures those local educational agencies that requested
insignias in 2021 but reported a decline in students earning the state seal of civic
engagement in 2022 or did not have students who earned a state seal of civic engagement in 2022
mostly attributed this to student educator and administrator exhaustion or stress
staffing shortages at county district and site levels have also created challenges
in implementing the state seal of civic engagement the map on the right side of
the screen shows location of insignia requests statewide in 2022
this is at the school district level you will note that requests are concentrated around los
angeles san diego as well as the san francisco bay area and sacramento regions this was also
the case in 2021 it is apparent that rural or otherwise hard to reach regions will require
additional outreach and support in order to develop local state seal of civic engagement
programming recent grant funding made available in 2022 budget through the california service
program may also help regions implement the seal finally there is also a need to refine the process
by which local educational agencies submit corrections to the requested data or sorry
the requested insignias statewide and state seal of civic engagement request data is drawn from
the online insignia request form the alias submit in the spring some local educational agencies were
reported requesting an excess of insignias in 2020-21 in case additional students ended up
qualifying this resulted in them asking for fewer this year the state seal of civic engagement
insignia request form also allows for corrections and local educational agencies are to use that
form to make the corrections to the insignia requests the form is open through the summer
however it can be challenging to ensure that all the corrections are submitted
and we are working on increasing communication before and after insignia requests to address this
so expanding our view of it california is one of several states that has developed or is developing
ways to recognize students for civic engagement and learning last year the california department
of education supported the national council for the social studies in developing some general
resources to support states seeking to offer civic seals as part of that research the national council
for the social studies is to track which states offer the civic seals and what those opportunities
look like california arizona georgia new york and ohio have statewide civic diploma seals for
qualifying students ohio's is the newest program which is on its pilot year in addition to a
citizenship seal ohio also allows local educational agencies to develop and offer
the seal to recognize community service as well as a seal to recognize student
extracurricular engagement several states recognize schools with active civic programs
this includes kansas tennessee and illinois arizona appears to be the only state that offers a seal
to both schools and individual students and each state approaches the civic seals differently
however most states that offer the civic seal restrict seals to graduating students
require specific coursework and performance on assessments and instruct students to engage in a
project and or complete a set of number of service or volunteer hours of the states that all that
offer seals for individual students california is the only state that allows juniors to earn
seals that does not factor in grades that does not use a standardized statewide assessment
i will now move on to share more information related to the local state seal of civic
engagement implementation including information about the new california service program
and on this slide there are two students from riverside stem high school explaining a recycling
program that they developed over three years for their school district and they used this program
for a state seal of civic engagement
first i'd like to briefly share how our division approaches the state seal of
civic engagement implementation throughout the year there's a timeline on of the slide
after updating the insignia request form and stocking up on the insignias
we post an online insignia request form for the first two years it was posted in march
but we were able to post it in february this year division staff then fulfills the request
throughout spring and into summer and with the majority of the requests being processed in april
and we're processing insignia requests right now throughout the summer division staff processes
the insignia request data including requesting the lea smith corrections as needed
this statewide data spreadsheet is posted onto the
state seal of civic engagement webpage each fall after corrections are processed
division staff also supports local state seal of civic engagement implementation throughout the year
if they provide technical assistance they present on the state seal of civic engagement promote
resources and opportunities provided by state seal of civic engagement partner organizations
share information on the state seal of civic engagement to internal and external organizations
and facilitate internal and ongoing partnership to investigate incorporating the civic learning
and engagement into the college career indicator
although students in grade 11 and 12 are eligible to earn a state seal of civic engagement
a key purpose of the legislation was to create pathways for pupils in elementary and secondary
schools to become civically engaged in democratic governmental institutions at both at the local
level the state level and national levels encouraging long-term civic engagement was also
the theme of a november 2022 civic learning summit which brought together students educators
administrators lawmakers and the judicial branch to recognize and celebrate bright spots in
student civic engagement at all levels for example to encourage students to begin this
process in elementary or middle some local educational agencies are developing pathways
for students to become civically engaged before reaching high school
anaheim unified high school district is partnering with feeder elementary school districts
to facilitate vertical learning to encourage civic learning that begins in kindergarten
fresno unified school district is implementing the state seal of civic engagement regionally
with fresno high school as the epicenter that works with middle and elementary schools
in its region to integrate civic learning opportunities vertically participation in
fresno unified school districts fresno state bonner award also incentivizes schools to
encourage students to pursue civic learning in younger grades orange county department of
education created a civic learning pathways document and slide deck to help support projects
for students to earn civic learning pathway certificates in elementary and middle schools
sacramento county office of education is exploring options for awarding local
intermediate civic engagement seals to elementary and middle school students
and sacramento county office of education leadership has been openly supportive of
implementing the state seal of civic engagement locally as a civic experience that starts in
kindergarten and feeds into programs offered at every school level
in addition to encouraging long-term civic engagement pathways
local educational agencies also are also developing programming to support students
in alternative education settings seeking to earn a state seal of civic engagement i'd like to
highlight two of those santa clara county office of education and sacramento county office of
education santa clara office of education developed a state seal of civic civic engagement
implementation toolkit that guides local educational agencies implementing the state seal
to ensure that no student is excluded from an opportunity to earn a seal based on academic
ability alternative school setting or unique or unconventional expressions of engagement
santa clara's local state seal of civic engagement programming includes options for students in santa
clara's county office of education special programs it's developed through a special programs
advisory committee which is dedicated to providing equitable and inclusive opportunities for all
students to earn a seal this includes students in court and community programs the opportunity
the opportunity youth academy and the special education department santa clara county office
of education also developed special programs criteria to provide examples for local educational
agencies to implement the state seal of civic engagement in ways that support all students
sacramento county has also developed local programming that supports access to the seal
in alternative education settings this includes developing programs based on what it means for
students in alternative education programs to earn a seal through learning to navigate
local work and service systems for instance sacramento city unified school districts local
criteria includes guidance and specific examples to support students in alternative learning
programs to work towards a seal
we are also seeing increased support in for civic learning and engagement in the state
legislature and the governor's office this became evident with the 2022 education omnibus bill
which included language to establish the california serves program beginning this
fiscal year school year this appropriates five million annually to the california department
of ed to develop and administer the california serves program it's in collaboration with
california volunteers and it's for purposes of promoting access to effective service learning
for pupils in grade 12 with the goal of expanding access to the state seal of civic engagement
through service learning this includes five million dollars annual grant program in which
eligible eligible local educational agencies may apply for grants to support the implementation
of the state seal through local local service learning programs
we posted the request for applications for this program on january 26 2000 oh sorry move my slide
on january 26 2023 applications are due this friday and we held a webinar for
local educational agencies that are interested on february 3rd 2023
following the readers conference for this program we will post the intent award we
anticipate posting it on april 21st and with the final awards posted on may 12th of this year
the intent is that this is a pilot year of the grant and it will form the basis of an
innovative continual program to support equitable access to the state seal of civic engagement
for eligible california school students moving forward see as we continue with year three of
the state seal of civic engagement implementation the our division is focusing on the following
areas improving the accuracy of data provided by local educational agencies and reported
statewide each fall posting the insignia request form earlier for those students who are graduate
earlier improving the state seal of civic engagement access in rural areas under served
areas and for students in alternative education programs and supporting and promoting examples
of local educational agencies that have implemented civic engagement pathways for
students in elementary school and middle and also where possible address issues related to
consistency among the local state seal of civic engagement programs to make it easier to analyze
from community to community including the quality of local programs and how equitably the students
are accessing the seal
we're also exploring the incorporation of the state seal of civic engagement into the college
and career indicator we continue to work internally to investigate ways to recognize and incorporate
the state seal of civic engagement into the indicator and is and we're excited to move
forward with this project in the future we anticipate that the department will also provide
updates on this project in a future state board of education meeting this year and finally our
division is also moving forward with implementing and growing the california serves program along
with the state seal of civic engagement and thank you for inviting us to share this information
today my colleagues wd superintendent cotton and sarah smith an education programs consultant
within the educator excellence and equity division are here with me i would like to
take a moment to acknowledge sarah smith today she leads this program on behalf of the department
she does an amazing job she's very dedicated to civic engagement and she was recently honored
by the california council for the social studies for her work highlighted and
and
so thank you for the conversation and we're happy to take any questions you have at the appropriate
time thank you so much monique and sheryl let's put the public comment slide up if we may
and we'll open the phone line for the public comment queue members of the public who want
to call in may be so in person or by calling the telephone number and using the access code
that is on the slide that is shown now and while we're waiting for members of the public
to call in i want to ask our liaison member yoshimoto terry if she would like to make a
few comments thank you board president i think the fact that we're one of 10 states
that have a civic seal is very promising i wanted to make three quick points
no it's a speaker we have an echo over here the creation of promising practices are exciting
so thank you for recognizing the county offices and the districts that are doing this work
which can provide support both for the less urban adjacent districts and also for whom's also for
students whom traditional instruction hasn't been as effective secondly it's exciting that juniors
and seniors are eligible for this because students could put it on their resumes in their college
applications i think that's really important and then lastly i did want to connect the seal
of civic engagement to yesterday's dream session on assessments there was a lot in the civic
engagement seal that can really be connected with real life culturally relevant giving back
to the community and demonstrating civic mindedness so i think for the future that
might be something for us to explore thank you board president and are there any speakers in
the room who wanted to give public comment there is no one signed up in the room for public comment
right and do we have anybody on the phone yes we do we have five callers in the queue i will open
the phone line now good afternoon state board of education please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
caller ending with the last four digits five four nine one
you are unmuted please start your public comment now
okay moving to the next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now
i believe we're having a problem with the phone line um i know i'm not sure if i'm still muted or
not um i will try the next caller though
caller with the last four digits five five nine six please start your public comment you are live
good afternoon this is liz gian with public advocates and also with the lcfs equity coalition
lcfs equity coalition we really appreciate the work that's been accomplished so far
and all the information provided to lift up the seal of civic engagement we wanted to just
emphasize what the staff memo made clear that the original intent of ensuring equitable access for
all students is not being met currently and i would expect the board to provide direction to
help the department try to get more lea's involved and especially those that are in
um uh areas such as rural areas um we also appreciate the lifting this up as a potential
measure of accountability however until there is student group data on the recipients of this
field we would be concerned about adding this metric to the college and career indicator
it seems like there would be a lot of work to do before we get to that point
thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now uh good afternoon i'm huling lee executive director
for authentic corporation today we appreciate the state board and cd's commitments to this work and
our collaborations um with cd on this given the equity implications of inconsistent state seal
civic engagement implementation in the field we would recommend that the state
one reinstate the civic engagement work group to improve and refine the seal criteria requirements
based on local promising practices and needs to revise the seal criteria to prioritize the
civic engagement projects student reflection and evidence with more specificity so these
requirements are not watered down unintentionally three require not just recommend the lea's meet
the state baseline state seal criteria and lastly four to use a 10 california certified to provide
high quality examples and resources as guidance across the state and to determine a process for
state oversight to ensure equity and consistency of excellence across the state thank you thank
you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now
good afternoon thank you president darling hammond i'm john trisvinia
california senior advisor for generation citizen who promotes
youth civic engagement nationally and in california schools throughout the san francisco bay area
want to express our strong support for a full equitable implementation of the state seal and
availability of academically rigorous and civically conscious programs i associate myself
with the remarks of miss liz gianna miss healing lee on on these subjects particularly in terms
of equitable access schools and local educational associations need strong support strong straight
support to make civic engagement a reality especially for pathways up to grades 11 and 12
the numbers that we're talking about thus far in the first few years of implementation are very
strong very weak and and really in order to have make an impact and make an impact of this critical
time following with january 6 we we need the state leadership in order to support all the school
districts in in in being able to have this program california should be a leader much more needs to
be done to reach out to all students we look forward to assisting wherever we can thank you
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon members of the board my name is katiana pitman a senior at sunny side high school
in fresno california and i'm a core member in california for justice i'm calling in about the
seal of civic engagement getting this bill will allow me to show that not only did i make a
difference in my school but also in my community as a young student of color through my work at
toronto's peace mural and how it led to decrease student conflict and brought a sense of belonging
getting the sale also recognizes the work i've done at cfj and gathering data on issues that
are important to students and making sure students know they're right students should have more
opportunities to create projects and also more clarity on qualifications because there are so
many students that qualify for it but don't know they do we want this state so civic engagement to
be more accessible to students of color and those income students like myself and get there
and to get there we could collect more information about schools and students
that are that is available to fill thank you thank you next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
so
caller ending with the last four digits five one five six you are now live please start your
public comment yes hello this is time for community schools correct
no i'm sorry this is for item number five if you don't mind calling back in thank you
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time starts now
caller ending in the last four digits seven one four five you are now live
please start your public comment thank you my name is erica hodgin with the civic engagement
research group at uc riverside i want to thank the board and cde for their commitment to use civic
engagement and support for the state seal of civic engagement i'm calling to share three
preliminary findings from a study where we assess the extent to which this new civic initiative is
accessible throughout the state and how the landscape has changed and to urge the board
to support district implementation and collect additional data to help us and districts promote
this kind of high quality civic learning in this study we examined district l caps and mission
statements and we did the same study in 2020 and then it compared to 2022 and the first finding
that we see is that civic and democratic goals have increased only slightly in california
district mission statements and l caps and we also find that there's comparatively less staffing to
support history social science and civic agendas the fact that many districts have no individuals
focused specifically on civics or very few in social studies may be constraining implementation
of the seal the second finding that we've been looking at based on available data is that the
seal is being adopted by districts of varying sizes but the state's 10 largest largest districts
only four offer the seal and when we compare the 12th grade population of the districts that have
adopted the field we found that on average districts are only requesting 11 percent thank
you your 12th grade population to earn this deal so we urge you to think about collecting
more data and equity and access around the field thank you that concludes public comment for item
number five thank you very much this is not an action item it's a information item but if we
have comments that we want to make for the staff as they move forward this is the time to do that
yes naomi so thank you so much truly for the work that you've been doing it is so impactful
so i wanted to make two quick comments first in my own service learning leadership class we
participate in this thing called a 20-time project which we dedicate 20 percent of our time in class
towards a passion project similar to those that would count towards the seal and this has been
wildly successful and so many students want to take this course simply because of this project
and students have created mental wellness kits sorry taught art classes and re-engaged in hobbies
that they no longer felt they had time for given rigorous course schedules and other time
commitments and i believe that when students have autonomy over what we want to dedicate our time
to and directly impact how we measure success in our project directly kind of parallels to
member yoshimoto tauri's point of the conversations that we had yesterday about ensuring
that students are workplace ready so i think that providing examples of successful projects
for the seal is important so students can get an idea and some guidance of successful projects
and kind of how to turn their ideas and their passions into tangible product projects and then
secondly with a different perspective a few student board members from across the state
have reached out to me about their districts being wary about the seal being used as a tool
solely to write on college applications or to build a resume rather than its intent which is
to bolster civic engagement and understanding and really encourage that and so i'm curious
if there is data about this and the seals effectiveness or if that's just something to
consider for future updates just want that to share um i think what makes california unique
is that we do not require gpa we don't require any of those things in order for students to earn
their civic seal of engagement i think that that's one positive and i i agree with you that the
focus is on encouraging student learning but one of the the byproducts is also student engagement
and school climate and making school a more fun and engaging place as you're describing
with your passion project for students as well thank you yes member mccullin yes thank you for
the presentation i'm so thankful that you've included tribal students understanding their
own tribal structures and tribal organizations it's really good it's such a refreshing item
and overdue i'm reminded just a couple of weeks ago i saw students at a peaceful civic
protest or to bring attention to the missing and murdered indigenous peoples that was happening
over at the state capitol just two weeks ago and i saw some high school students as a part of that
so it's great that they will possibly be acknowledged academically for that involvement
i also hope that we will be tracking and getting numbers of who's applying and what
subgroups are applying for this seal also in the future thank you
any other advice or commentary vice president glover woods thank you just to build off a
board member mccullin statement i again thank everyone for all that they've done this is just
a wonderful opportunity for students and i've just strongly encouraged us to look at how we
can get to some student level data to address the issues of equity that might be in place
and also to utilize that information to help determine how we can support leas that may not
be offering these opportunities to students especially if we're going to look at including
this as one of the criteria on our college career indicator thank you so much for the
work that's been done and i look forward to future information around this topic thank you
member holcomb thank you for your presentation today and all the work on this and anything that
gives member porter the opportunity to share her good work i'm in favor of but i also just
wanted to build on what vice president glover woods just said about the link between access
between this program and access and equity from a different angle which is the ways in which
encouraging and rewarding civic engagement amongst our youth particularly
in a way that is equitable and really supports some of our vulnerable and disadvantaged
populations to participate actually is a helps us build the tomorrow that we want so i think
there's been a lot of talk about how this is good for students to engage in but i think
remembering to frame this work around that it's good for us as a society to encourage and to reward
because it's going to help us have more democratic institutions in the future
is important and i think we know from history that our youth are often where the real solutions
come from and so i think there's a lot more to be gained by growing this program than for example
college resumes thank you so much so i think that we're moving toward the place where we can consider
this as part of the seal of as part of our college career and civic engagement index that will
encourage people in the field to take it up i think once that is now something that could
possibly count obviously we've heard a lot about the need to create a support system to figure out
how to make this a meaningful element and so we're going to look forward to seeing you again soon
with some of those answers and we just want to applaud keeping the work moving forward thank you
so much and i'm going to now reopen item two because state superintendent tony thurman is
here and it is time for his report thank you tony madam president thank you to the members of the
board madam vice president and i just want to thank our team for the presentation and thinking
about the more than 10 000 state seals that have been provided in california and it was
an honor for me to join a conversation with state superintendents from across the nation
and to be able to say that our state does not require a gpa that we think that the state seal
should be eligible available to all students and so thank you for your leadership and for
making it available for all of our students as always i want to start by being in gratitude
to our teachers and our classified staff and to our students our family members for all that you
do for our six million students and acknowledge again that it's women's history month and i would
like to plus one all the things that i heard president darling ham and say about the real
life mathematicians who for whom which the film hidden figures was created and just acknowledge
the incredible leaders on this board if you look around we have incredible leaders here
and it's an honor to serve all of you and just to thank you i'm also reminded about a school
visit last month to robla elementary school district where i was given the honor to present
to some students the ruby bridges award and the room was full of many young students who appreciated
that ruby bridges had to sacrifice so much to make education possible for us all you know being
escorted by police officers and troopers and just the kind of hate that she experienced and sacrificed
to ensure that our students would have access to an education with equity and so i'm grateful to
all who continue to support our students and i'm happy to share just a few reflections from
my visits again it's national school breakfast week and this week i had the opportunity to spend
time with the first partner and with the u.s secretary for agriculture
to at betty reed saskin middle school betty reed saskin middle school is named after
the oldest park ranger in the nation a hundred a 100 year old woman an african american woman
who's been a trailblazer as we talk about women's history month and at the school a great
conversation about how we provide healthy nutritious meals to our students as you all know we provide
universal meals for our students and it was great to see the meals prepared by the staff and students
and working with farmers and others to make sure that great resources are provided to our schools
to provide healthy sustenance for our students it is also national school social worker week
and i want to acknowledge all the school social workers and as take a point of personal privilege
as a social worker i'm grateful for what you do and i know that later in the agenda you'll hear from
deputy superintendent zimmer and our team from alameda county office of education some updates
about community schools and want to welcome them today and and we'll continue the conversation
about the great work that social workers do and other mental health clinicians do and remind those
that anyone who wants to become a mental health clinician and work in a school california offers
a 20 000 grant to do that and we are excited about our ability to support our school staff
i also this week had the pleasure of participating in a capital visit with students from
palace verdes peninsula high school the home school of our own trustee naomi porter
and i saw in action what we see in action here all the time well informed students who are very
well researched and they came to the capital very focused on how we expand mental health services
and their perspectives were incredible and i think that we need to do all that we can
to to follow the suggestions of our students we all know we have a shortage we all know that of
mental health clinicians and we know that there's still stigma in the world and that we can do more
to help our students and on that note i'll just mention as i always do that anyone who needs to
talk to a counselor can do so 24 hours a day seven days a week by texting or calling 9 8 8
you can text or call 9 8 8 to talk to a counselor 24 7 and again it was a great visit
thank you board member porter for allowing us to spend some time with your colleagues this week
i do also want to acknowledge that today we're being visited by students from the california
school for the deaf in riverside this is one of the schools managed directly by the california
department of education there are six and seventh graders here go cubs and they are doing a makeup
visit and just like how the board has come together to be in person again these are students who were
not able to do their fourth grade trip during the pandemic and so this is their makeup visit
and next month we will be visited by the actual fourth graders from the california school for the
deaf in riverside and so big shout out to our school there and to our students at the california
school for the deaf in fremont and the california school for the blind in fremont big shout out to
all of our students as you know many of our schools are still grappling with weather related
closures hundreds of schools are impacted tens of thousands of students difficult times but i want
to acknowledge the resilience of all of our school leaders and students the office of emergency
services our emergency team at the california department of education our deputy superintendent
abel guian who's visited many of the schools and the work of our director elizabeth dierstein and
her team trying to support these schools and helping them to get to safety and to not be
worried about questions related to ada but focus on what can we do to support our schools also want
to remind you that we continue our efforts around recruitment as you know we've established a what
i'm calling a one-stop information and referral system where we can help anyone who wants to
learn about what it means to be a teacher we've established a public service announcement that
you will soon see where our california teachers of the year are featured in that psa i also want
to share with you that remind everyone that we have the golden state teacher grant
a twenty thousand dollar scholarship for anyone who wants to become a teacher we have a partnership
with college core which has three thousand folks working in schools as tutors and mentors
and they receive a stipend and money to go to college and anyone who wants to learn more about
any of these resources can reach us at teach in ca at cde.ca.gov i want to also acknowledge
president darling hammond for joining us just a few weeks ago on a great webinar discussion
about what we do to support california schools in reducing discipline and addressing disproportionate
discipline and the department is putting out guidance to support our schools thank you for
being a part of that webinar to to show our districts how to use programs like restorative
justice and others that we know allow us to address the needs of our students in an appropriate way
i also want to acknowledge that upcoming we will continue our conversations around
literacy and how we help our students reach literacy by third grade and on march 23rd
at 4 p.m. there'll be a webinar focused on many aspects of literacy including the english language
arch english language development framework and again i want to thank the president of our board
for your work to help to lift this up and conversations about creating a literacy
roadmap so that we have ways to make sure that every educator knows about the e l a e l d
framework and so thank you for your leadership there there'll be updates on new requirements
from the ctc for teacher credentialing programs in terms of how we prepare
teachers to teach reading we'll be talking about freedom school an afro-centric evidence-based
literacy intervention program and some grants that we hope to provide to school districts
we'll be talking about primary promise if you follow any of the remarks from
president darling hammon you know that our largest district in this state la unified
saw improvement in fourth and eighth grade literacy on the nape in terms of their nape scores
we'll be talking about ways to engage english learners and to support bilingual education
as part of that webinar that webinar is also an opportunity to introduce two new state co-directors
for helping california students reach literacy by third grade some of them are folks that you
know i want to acknowledge the addition to our staff nancy brindleson who most recently
has served as a consultant to the ctc and as a primary writer for the e l a e l d framework
and her her co-director dr bonnie garcia who's worked at the desert mountain selpa with more
than 40 school districts including work to support their literacy efforts and she works
as a literacy dyslexia interventionist and so you'll be meeting them and hearing from them
and we're formally introducing them on march the 23rd one additional new hire is our new
computer science coordinator katherine go yet who has worked for nearly a decade as the educational
technology and integrated studies consultant for chilleri county office of education
and was the primary writer for california's inaugural computer science standards and so we
want to invite you to welcome them to the department and to acknowledge someone who's
not new to the department but new to the role as our new as our chief general counsel we're excited
to announce the elevation of len garfinkel who many of you have had the chance to work with
in his role who's worked in our cde legal office since 2011 it's without it's needless to say he's
jumped right in and it's continuing the incredible tradition of work that we get from both the
department of education and our partnership with the state board of education so we ask that you
welcome these new folks and new folks in their role and i'm happy to share these highlights
and this is my report i'm not sure if lens in the building len is in the building so once again
for len garfinkel who is in the building um he'll probably sue me for that but that's okay um
our our two new literacy uh statewide directors are already at a nationwide training on statewide
literacy programs with some of our staff from the department of education welcome this completes
all right terrific thank you so much uh we're now going to take a five minute break uh we're
going to reset the phone line so that it will operate properly and the board members will get
their lunches and bring them back and we can all go at once and do that and be back in five minutes
so
but we are going to continue to barrel on ahead uh and um i am uh aiming for the i'm aiming to
have us out of here by three so that we can get ahead of the worst part of the storm so that's
that's what we're aiming for uh we're now going to take up the regular consent items uh six through
eight and we will open the phone line for the queue for public comment and can set items six
through eight members of the public wishing to provide comment on those items may do so in person
or by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown
now do we have any speakers sign up for public comment in person yes we have lorraine richards
signed up for item six all right is lorraine in the house
okay there we go
thank you um great to be back um my name is lorraine richards and i'm a classroom teacher
representing the california teachers association cta would like to express our continued concerns
with the funding determination process with non-classroom based charters there is a significant
disconnect with the state level process and it was on display at the february a ccs meeting
in which some commissioners raised significant concerns regarding the funding determination
process and the intersection of the authorizer chair walsh expressed it is clear that there is
still work to be done on the process and the systems and becoming clearer about the charter
authorization responsibility the these disconnects open the door to bad actors such as the people who
ran the a3 charters and others who have taken advantage to steal hundreds of millions of
dollars in public funds cta looks forward to working with cde state board of education and
ccs to fix this broken process thank you thank you are there any other in-person speakers
seeing none do we have any callers on the phone line it looks like we do have one caller in the
queue i'll open the phone line now good afternoon please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
thank you good afternoon my name is michelle romaine and i am the head of school of
virtual preparatory academy at lucerne we are an independent charter school operated by a
non-profit public public benefit corporation serving 700 students in grades tk through 11
in partnership with our chartering authority our school serves an array of non-traditional
students and families who require alternatives to traditional classroom-based learning
we're proud of the growth of our students experience at our school and our commitment
to sound operations last year our school began working with a highly respected california-based
fiscal advisor to support excellence in all aspects of our fiscal operations we appreciate
the state board of education's approval for funding determination thank you for your time
thank you okay that concludes public comment for regular consent items zero six through zero eight
all right thank you given that there's no further public comment i'll ask for a motion on consent
items six through eight do i have a motion and a second member yoshimoto tari i saw you trying to
get your hand up there all right all of those in favor please say aye any opposed any abstentions
all right motion carries thank you very much and we're going to move to item nine
the california community schools partnership program which is approval of the second cohort
of planning grantees and an update from the state transformational assistance center the cd recommends
that we approve the cc spp cohort two planning grant awards and this item will be presented by
steve zimmer and pete callis of the cde and then navdeep purewell from the alameda county office
of education steve it's great to see you please begin our state superintendent
and my gratitude to to him we we celebrated his inauguration at the rfk campus in los angeles one
of the flagship community schools really across our nation looking forward also to a visit that
we have together with the superintendent on on on march 30th where in fullerton
california in orange county they will be opening their new community school center
and the the superintendent will be cutting the ribbon and helping to inaugurate that program
it's an honor to speak to you today we have a very simple item we are asking you for
we are asking the board for the approval of our second cohort of planning grants
we will be recommending 226 planning grants today is in your your attachment and this is
this is a more than 30 more that we had in our first round and i want to acknowledge that
we have together with community partners together with our lead state transformative
assistance program we have really done a lot of outreach as as we we committed to you
last year to try and make sure that this program is reaching all parts of our state
and as you know the the with this recommendation all of the the lea's that we are coming
to you for recommendation today meet the qualification of 50 or higher of their
their students with that are designated as unduplicated or a few of the other qualification
guidelines set forth by statute and in this board we are we're pleased with the diversity
of these planning grantees that we will present today and and look forward
to answering any questions you might have about our our process a brief brief overview you have
more in the item i i know flying into the atmospheric river this morning i i know that
while i respect your process in terms of being able to get out and get everyone home safely
today so there's more information in the item a brief reminder we it's a 4.1 billion dollar
allocation for planning grants implementation grants to transform and support community schools
within lea's and and also to provide a robust infrastructure at the county level the regional
level and the state level to support strong statewide implementation and i think if there's
a theme that i would have for today's presentation it is that implementation is happening we came a
year and a half ago with a program we were just launching and i think that we can say today and
we'll touch on this in his presentation and you'll see it from dr pure wall from from alameda
county implementation is happening this is taking hold so far you have approved 193 lea's last year
for planning grants 76 lea's for implementation grants and 458 individual school sites
38 county offices of education to support grantees in their county a lead technical
assistance center or transformational assistance center i should say and eight regional technical
assistance centers and now i'd like to introduce to you our lead partner at the alameda county
office of education dr navdeep dr navdeep pure wall and i just want to say in as nav comes up
this partnership has been really extraordinary we as i as i shared with you that we would
a few months ago our teams meet multiple times a week the collaboration is
it is both intentional and it is it is detail oriented as well
and i can't speak highly enough about nav and her team and the work that they have done to date
she's going to detail it for you right now but just on behalf of the superintendent on behalf
of our team at cd i just want to express my gratitude at how this relationship has developed
and the partnership that we have dr pure wall with your team with no further ado let me introduce
thank you steve good afternoon president darling hammon and board members
i'm delighted to be here on behalf of the state transformational assistance center
i also want to share that since the update in november our alameda county superintendent of
schools alice castro has joined us and has been tremendously supportive of the work and the
transformational vision of the s-tac today i will touch on the topics listed here in the overview
and i'll be closing with the next steps that are on the horizon for the s-tac
since we started our work in july we have facilitated seven webinars six communities
of transformative practice and 27 collective learning spaces all grounded in the california
community schools framework the webinars designed for grantees educators students families and
community members have been a space for us to share how to create community schools that are
racially just relationship centered and foster shared decision making we have also been intentional
about representing our diverse state by lifting best practices and strategies from practitioners
who represent our rural communities as well as our tribal communities we have also engaged our
county offices of education in our communities of transformative practice trying to really identify
the opportunities for coherence from the grantee levels of the school sites to the lea's as well
as our county offices of education to really support this transformational implementation of
programming at our school sites we have encouraged our 31 county offices of educations who have been
receiving grant allocations to support grantees in their areas to join us in this community of
transformative practice and also invite all other county offices of education through
presentations at our california county superintendents meetings as well as our
curriculum and instruction steering committee meetings that engage leaders from the county
office of education level in the 27 collective learning spaces as well as our phone calls and
email support we have been able to really provide more of the targeted and intensive support
to differentiate the needs that our grantees have on the ground as they are implementing and
planning community schools we are extremely elated that we have eight partners in this work with us
along with our phenomenal cde team the eight regional transformational assistance centers that
have been approved throughout our state we have been engaging with our rtacs we visited each rtac
in person over the last several months to really strengthen and to begin this relation build
relationship building process we've been able to really glean and learn about how these regional
transformational assistance centers have been leads in their counties in their in at the stand
at the state level to really determine how we're going to be able to maximize that expertise
as we implement community schools across our state a few notable strengths that we've already
identified that can really be supportive of this work is rtacs who have who are the state leads
right now for medic al billing we also have a state regional transformational assistance center
that is the community engagement initiative lead we also know that one of our county offices of
education that's an rtac has themselves set up medical clinics across their county that's just
to name a few we are very excited really trying to just lift the strength and the capacity we have
to really implement this program to be meaningful student-centered and serving families and
communities we've also established monthly meetings with these county offices of education
just to continue the alignment and coherence of ta across our state
we also find it important to develop a shared understanding among our s tech as well as our
rtac partners in december we invited our rtac partners to engage in a ucla community school
study tour where we went through a community school we were led by students as well as
administrators in learning more about what that community school looked like what the planning
process was an implementation and how they are continuously learning from the community members
and students on how to really support the access and success for these students and families
we're also excited to share that we will be engaging in another shared understanding opportunity
funded by the actually the the stewart foundation who is getting together other leads
statewide leads who are focused on secondary programming such as the dual enrollment the
golden state pathways that have been mentioned as we'll be coming together to really engage
in a deep learning experience in april and we're very excited to continue that shared understanding
work now i'm going to switch to our implementation growth chart which as part of our s tech contract
we were been asked to develop a rubric one thing i want to name that you know we really thought
about the word rubric and thought gosh how can we really talk about and express that this is you
know it's not an accountability measure it's this is supposed to be used as a tool so how are we
using a growth chart to really lift and identify that this is a process implementation is going
to take time it's going to be iterative so in response to our grantees that we have heard from
through our collective learning space through our emails and our phone calls we have created a
growth chart that's very soon about to be released which is tethered in the values of
the california community schools framework but it also highlights this california way
and when i share that i want to just really lift the multitude of investments that are coming our
way in our schools in our lea's and how can we really think about sustainability and implementation
in this new california way we have so many opportunities to bring together funding and
investments to support this this meaningful work additionally we acknowledge that we are
providing chronological guidance while recognizing this non-linear nature of implementation
really wanting to meet folks where they at as grantees and planning and implementation grads
so this growth chart actually includes resources and tools such as self-assessments and they ask
questions related to for example health care services that are going to be you know provided
for students and what access they have also summer learning experiences what's being put in place for
students in the summer and also other aspects such as other student services that families
and students may need so the self-assessments will help to really shape and inform the needs
for implementing implementing community schools we have also received feedback from our advisory
board our regional transformational assistant centers as well as the cd our cd partners to
really adjust and iterate this process of creating this growth chart we as we release it we are
wanting the community to engage and to provide us feedback as they are using this tool as a
resource to design their community schools the implementation growth chart is tethered to the
four overarching values that you see here that operate operationalize the california community
schools framework classroom community connections really emphasizing emphasizing that we are
continuously linking classroom instruction to the broader community and that the school is rooted
in the assets of the students families educators and local community members racially just
relationship centered spaces are another value that we want to lift in this growth chart
and that's really spotlighting the authentic the importance of authentically valuing diverse
cultures perspectives and strengths in our communities co-ownership really speaks to the
and the grounding in the belief that schools belong to all of us students educators families
community members and that these spaces are democratic recognizing and building towards
shared ownership and deep engagement and finally a focus on continuous improvement can't stress
this enough we are going to iterate we are going to listen and we are going to continue to try to
meet the needs of our students and our families in our communities the growth chart contains nine
capacity building strategies that are actually within three phases of growth and development
visioning engaging and transforming and these capacity building strategies are associated
activities that build the structural and organizational capacity for collective efficacy
and action in meeting the shared goals and values listed in the previous slide
now i'll be moving on to an implementation plan template that was recently released to the field
this implementation plan template was derived from the implementation growth chart this has been a
very strong collaboration between our s tech and our cde partners we had a lot of back and forth
and how to meet the needs of our grantees it is in response also to the cohort to community schools
partnership program implementation grant rfa requirement which now requires that each site
include an implementation plan so we really wanted to provide this trans this ta to support
applicants in wanting to really engage in this work moving forward we have also as an s tech
facilitated two webinars in the last two weeks receiving you know many a lot of great feedback
and support around how this tool is going to help them with their applications and that those
webinars really focused on the purpose and use of this template next i'm excited to share that we
have i mean we are engaging this part process as an s tech around transformation partner deep dive
sites very excited and and really the purpose of these deep dive sites are a way for our team to
partner with three ccspp implementation grantees over a period of time to really capture a vertical
slice of the broader system from the school the district the county and the arctic we're really
looking to understand implementation from a systems perspective and build collective capacity to learn
improve and transform and really support grantees across the state we plan on doing this by
collaborating at each level of these deep dive sites from the site to the county office to the
arctic and really building this understanding and shared understanding of what implementation
looks like in response to what we're hearing in asset mapping gap analysis through our advisory
board and steering committees and also finding those nuggets of how do we think about sustainability
and how do we leverage the investments of several of the allied reforms that we have here and how do
we do this in our california way very excited to now announce that over the past four months
we have analyzed the cohort one implementation grantee abstracts coded them identified them for
evidence of the california community schools framework really thinking about whole child
principles of learning sustainability and collaborative leadership and we've conducted
interviews with six finalists that we selected based on this these analysis of abstracts and
after much deliberation we are very excited to share with you all today that we have selected
these three deep dive sites our shasta consortium the anaheim union high school district as well as
the west contra costa unified this unified school district together these three deep dives sites
provide a diverse geographic and programmatic context within which to learn and assist the state
in its transformational goals and so the next steps on our horizon which we are very excited
about we will be hosting our first community annual community school summit on june 16th
very excited to plan with that we'll be working with our regional transformational assistance
centers as well as other partners to lift this the great work of this summit that we are planning
we are also focusing our work on cohort one planning and implementation grantee surveys
for our planning and implementation grantees and so really thinking about for planning grantees
with the end goal after the two years being that they're creating an implementation plan that
they're going to execute so really seeing what is the progress on on them completing this
implementation plan for our implementation at grantee progress reporting we're thinking about
questions and data around so in addition to the california school dashboard data
you know of absenteeism of academics we're really thinking about what are the services
what are the services that students are getting access to and are actually utilizing what are
those services for the families and community members so dental vision health checkups so this
this reporting will be a little bit more detailed and it'll help us get a baseline for for annual
reporting we are also working with west ed on a on surveys for our planning and implementation
grantees which should be released shortly to also collect more data around how this year and how
planning and implementation has been going alignment among allied reforms i've mentioned this
really thinking about coherence and sustainability we are going to be having meetings with children
youth behavioral health initiative our partners at cde that are implementing expanded learning
opportunities program universal pre-kindergarten to really recognize models where these reforms
are in coherence and how sustainability of brand the blading of sorry braiding and blending funding
and layering is helping to support these schools and communities and lastly we are excited to
continue our transformational assistance and really maximizing the expertise of our regional
transformational assistance centers i want to thank you for your time today that concludes
my presentation and i will pass it on to pete callis
thank you that's the time i'm going to bring up pete right now thank you dr pure wall thank you
also to the board members for having lunch with community schools today we we hope we we provide
you good companionship for for the good nourishment of the of the heart and the soul and the mind
um i do want to bring up our division director pete callis i want to introduce you as well
to our our new educational administrator for community schools ahamed razawi who
who is here with us and also thank alisa rhymers who many of you know i just want to say as i bring
pete up the work that this division has done is really extraordinary on community schools to
to to really get us from vision to action to implementation and i can't tell you
how hard they've worked a small team to really bring this to fruition director pete callis
thank you steve so a brief overview of our planning grant awards originally from the
original amount of money the 3.1 billion 10 of that was set aside for planning grantees so just
over 287 million dollars was set aside for planning grants for 2021-22 and 2022-23 program years
up to two-year grant period for each of them some of them may choose to get all of their
planning done in one year and move forward to an implementation grant each of them received up to
200 000 dollars per qualifying entity lea's they had to be lea's with no existing community
schools in place so in 2022 sbe approved 193 lea's for planning grants for a total of just over 38
million dollars for cohort two we had 226 lea's right we're recommending 226 lea's for planning
grant awards there was an error in the item we had put in 227 we've made that adjustment in
the item so we'll be reposting the item with the correct amount we had 140 school districts 10
county offices and 76 charter schools included in this 226 the total planning grant allocation
for cohort two is 44 million 894 thousand 432 dollars the cd will allocate the funding to
cohort two for them to begin their program work on their planning for the 2023-24 fiscal year
from the original 10 percent that was set aside for planning grants we have just over 204 million
dollars left which should roll into some of our other work for implementation grants
cohort one implementation grants is a brief overview sbe approved 600 just over 625 million
dollars to support 458 schools in 76 lea's cohort two the rfa was posted on january 24th 2023
applications are due on march 21st 2023 the cohort two rfa include includes a submission
of an implementation plan for every school site listed in the application the submission of
artifacts showing that each school site has conducted a community asset mapping and needs
and gap analysis established a shared decision making council and evidence that the activities
are aligned to our framework for community schools
next steps for cde is to process and send grant award notifications for cohort two planning grant
awardees present cohort two implementation grantees for approval at the may 2023 state
board of education meeting release a formative evaluation rfp in spring of 2023 conduct outreach
to cohort two planning grantees for technical assistance complete contracts with the eight
regional technical assistance centers that we've selected and disperse just over 12 almost 13
million dollars to county offices of education for the 2022-23 fiscal year and determine next
year's funding after the cohort two implementation grantees are determined
so we've had
you want to do now
sorry
thanks alex we've had to make an edit to the recommendation based on the error that we had
from the 227 originally in the item to the 226 along with the total dollar amount and the total
dollar amount changed because one of our school districts we actually had to recalculate their
budget and it came out to actually 200 000 data had actually submitted less than 200 000 so we
wanted to make sure that was reflected in the recommendation so the new recommendation is the
cd recommends that the state board of education approve the cc spp cohort two planning grant awards
is set forth in the item but amended as follows total award amount is 44 894 432 total number of
2022-23 grant awards is 226 and rockland unified school district was the budget that we had to
amend as a 200 000 so that's our recommendation for approval
thank you thank you so much not only for this report but for all the work that you have been
doing to get us to this point it's really quite impressive we're going to open the public comment
phone line for your setting up that queue the members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so in person or by calling the telephone number and using the access code
provided on the slide that's shown now and while we're made waiting for members of the public to
call in i want to ask member yoshimoto tauri if she has some initial comments
i'll be very brief board president but again i want to thank not only the department team but also
the collaboration that's happening at this happening and being modeled at the state
transformational assistance center and it's profound that we're calling it transformational
as opposed to technical because community schools is an opportunity to tie in
everything around mtss expanded learning opportunity grants it's ongoing funding
the new arts and music dollars community engagement it brings it all together to braid everything
so we're continuing to be excited about that and thank you for modeling the distributed leadership
and i will simply add a plus one and i'm especially excited about the three
three district county offices that are going to be sort of demonstration sites if you will
to really model the practices it's a very innovative and helpful idea do we have any
public comment in the room yes lorraine richards
um good afternoon um state board of education members my name is lorraine richards and i am a
classroom teacher representing the california teacher association cta continues to appreciate
the work of the cde and state board of education in helping the state progress further down the
path of community schools implementation cta is appreciative of the updated
information that we've received from the state board of education and state board of education
cta is appreciative of the updated rfa for the cohort two implementation grant and strongly
believe the requirement of artifacts will help the fidelity to the california community schools
framework and to ensure lea's are authentically engaging in shared decision making cta is impressed
and supportive of the stac and feels that alameda county and ucla have been tremendous leads for
this work their work continues to be grounded in the framework and is cognizant of ensuring that
all four pillars are ever present we would like to recommend that each of the our tax and the
county offices of education receiving coordination grants establish their shared decision making
structures so they can be seen as models for grantees thank you there uh any other public
comment in the room or on the phone there is one caller in the queue i will open the phone line now
good afternoon please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now good afternoon diana neaver with the community schools learning exchange
cslx has been working directly with several lea's regional ta centers as well as planning
and implementation grantees to support the development of strong and effective community
school strategies our comments today are from this on the ground vantage point
regarding the current implementation grant rfa and the new requirements to submit artifacts
related to needs assessments and advisory councils at the site level and for all sites
as part of an lea's application while we understand how these requirements reflect the practices of a
mature community school we also see that such requirements when tied to a competitive grant
application incentivizes a compliance orientation for potential grantees for example having to
complete site-based needs assessments before they have adequate funding and staffing infrastructure
like site coordinators to do this work well thank you very much for your consideration cslx is here
to help thank you okay that concludes public comment for item number nine okay thank you
very much at this point if there's any other board comment questions or discussion vice president
global works just a quick question as it relates to lea's that receive planning grants are they
then required to apply for an implementation grant or can an lea receive a planning grant
and not move not do anything else as it relates to establishing a community school
we certainly hope thank you for your question vice president cloverwood we certainly hope that
they would apply for implement implementation grants that is the intention and that is where
our and and i want to get this right i i always say i still revert back to technical assistance
where our transformational assistance is directed it is the case however that because our planning
grants are at the threshold of 50 percent and our implementation grants have at least to date been
a much higher threshold in terms of our our equity threshold for implementation grants
that we do see the possibility that the work of the planning grants and in in many lea's
we hope will be if you'll forgive me of using the term wall-to-wall we hope that we hope that lea's
will consider a community school implementation for all of their schools
we want them to prioritize the schools that they select to implement first we want them to prioritize
in equity lines we understand that our implementation grants have funded those schools
that have the the greatest needs and that an lea may have schools that don't qualify
qualify so in in terms of our expectation absolutely we would expect that planning
grantees then become our implementation grantees but because planning grants are lea are are at
the lea level implementation is at the site level we know that or we expect that some of the work of
planning will be applied to school school sites that don't end up as school site implementation
grantees i will also note that there is a two-year timeline for the for the planning grants so and
this relates a little bit to the public comment that came in
and planning grantees are not required to apply for implementation grants
one year after they receive the planning grants they can apply you know throughout the cycle
of our rfas for implementation grants planning grantees are are welcome to apply for for those
grants so i hope that i answered your question i what i want folks to understand is is that
the work of the planning grant process may apply to schools that that are not necessarily funded
for implementation grants and so you know we we're going to be interested to see this will be our
first kind of data set if you will this year how many of our planning grantees how many of their
schools then became in this next cohort implementation grantees but we won't know
that until may i'm going to look forward to sharing that data with you thank you i look
forward to hearing that and that data as well and i do believe everyone has the most positive
intentions when applying for the planning grants and it's it's helpful i think for our board to
know if there are those who do apply for the planning grant but it does not come out in
fruition to actually establishing a community school or bringing those practices pervasive in
their lea or school thank you thank you any other questions are clarifying um yes member
Roscoe Gonzales and then member Patito Bronson i just have a comment my comment is in the
requirement of artifacts as outlined on the rfa i think this is good this will help ensure
there's adherence to the california community schools framework and help to ensure that the
lea's are authentically engaging in shared decision making because i think that's where
the core of this transformative education in community schools is just shifting so i think
that will be that shared decision making key to this process member patil bronson also in the
category of comments i just want to thank you for the presentation and also for
highlighting the shasta consortium as one of the three deep dive sites and flagging that it would
be great to hear more as you learn more about their pre-k to three focus thank you and at this
point yes member mcclellan yes thank you for the presentation it's great to see the list of places
like happy camp and willow creek and these trinity valley these really remote on top of
remote locations but the breakdown in terms of remote applicants for the planning phase are
is it are we on task there are we fairly representative we are i think we'll always
have more work to do and and i think we always have to have our i think we we always have to
look very very carefully and kind of get very granular you're right we we we do see a larger
number of uh of rural communities in this round than we saw last year
are there still as i described it are there still deserts there are still deserts and trying to
understand um you know where we have potentially qualifying lea's that are still not subscribing
if you will it's something that we're continually reflective on we do see more uh more applicants
from our our small and rural lea's um and i think the deep dive into shasta i think that
the attention that we're we are given to giving to making sure that this is in the uh in the in
the consciousness uh in the intentionality of the planning for the regional transformative
assistance centers um will we hope we'll have a high correlation going back to vice president
glover woods question between planning grant uh between planning grant process and implementation
grant applications but again um we're going to have an interesting data set for us all to look
at in may um when we when we look at that correlation um so it is a work in progress
but i'm happy to report that we are doing better this year than we were last year
i wonder if we could get a motion to um adopt the boards of the cde recommendation
um thank you very much member lewis and a second thank you very much um at that uh all in favor
please raise your hands say aye aye any opposed any abstentions the motion carries thank you so
much we really appreciate it we're going to move right on ahead to the waiver consent calendar
uh we will put the public comment slide up if we might for the uh waiver comments
i'd like to uh take up uh waiver consent items w1 through 12 and we'll open the phone line for
public comment and we'll give a little bit of wait time so that people who are trying to come on the
phone may and are there any in-person public comments there is no one signed up for public
comment all right let's give it a minute and see if we get any buddy on the phone
anybody calling in uh no we do not have any callers all right thank you uh so given that
there's no further public comment i'll ask for a motion on consent items w1 through 12
thank you uh vice president global woods and may i get a second thank you very much member forter
at this point uh all in favor say aye aye any opposed any abstentions
please
was that an aye okay i thought maybe you were accusing yourself or something
all right we're moving moving on to uh item 10 item 10 is the time community school
consider issuing a notice of violation pursuant to california education code section 47607 g
uh the cde recommends that we consider issuing a notice of violation to time pursuant to ec
section 47607 g as time has failed to exercise prudent fiscal management and we generally accepted
accounting principles and i will leave the rest of the proposal to stephanie farland who is going to
present the item along with staff from the los angeles county office of education
education uh when the state board authorized this charter school the board delegated oversight and
monitoring to the la county office of education therefore cde and lacoe are jointly presenting
the staff recommendation stephanie please begin great thank you good afternoon uh president
darling hammon vice president glover woods board members and chief deputy mary nicely um
um so as mentioned we are uh requesting a consideration of the issuance of a notice
of violation to time community pursuant to ed code section 47607 g the oversight um of time
as mentioned by president darling hammon um is being conducted by the los angeles county office
of education's charter schools office in previous action uh the state board voted to approve time
in july of 2020 and in july 14th of 2022 we did come before this board and ask the same uh to
issue a notice of violation to time um that motion failed to gather six votes it was a five to four
vote and we need six to have an action so the sbe in effect took no action that day and a no
notice of violation was not issued over the course of its oversight um duties lacoe has expressed
their concerns regarding times fiscal sustainability a lot of this um was presented to you in july it
has not changed it has only deteriorated laco has consistently collaborated with and provided
guidance to time in an effort to bring the school into a more stable fiscal position
despite lacos issuance of numerous letters of concern to time the school's fiscal condition
continues to deteriorate and the school isn't even a worse fiscal position than it was in july 2022
so as stated our recommendation today is to uh is to ask the state board of ed to consider issuing
a no to time pursuant to 47607 g for um our purposes today we did want to provide uh a
definition of fiscal mismanagement fiscal mismanagement is the term used in ed code
in ed code to describe the condition that we can use to issue a notice of violation
and for our purposes a failure to appropriately manage an agency's finances thereby creating a
substantial risk of the to the agency's ability to function or accomplish its mission possible
indicators of fiscal mismanagement for charter schools may include one or more of the following
unreliable or insufficient budget development monitoring or updates inadequate cash management
mismanaged employee compensation continuing deficit spending inattention to enrollment
and attendance reporting inadequate fund balance and reserve for economic uncertainty
ineffective internal controls and fraud prevention lack of multi-year planning
inattention to debt and risk management so those this is a definition that we're using obviously
on occasion fiscal mismanagement can include fraud but in this case it does not but i think
you will see throughout the presentation that time uh charter does meet many many if not all
of the indicators listed here
and i'm going to hand it over to indra chicarelli um to present uh their oversight and their
concerns thank you so much
so good morning board members my name is indra chicarelli i am the director of the charter
school's office at the los angeles county office of education as you know time community school
began instruction in july of 2021 in monabelo california within the boundaries of monabelo
unified school district in its first year of operation time planned to enroll 260 students
in grades nine and ten however the school opened with only 27 students eventually enrolling a total
of just 41 students for the remainder of the school year for the current school year as of
december 2022 time had 65 students enrolled the school's mission is displayed on the slide in
front of you the operating entity is time community education since times authorization
laco has taken many steps to support the charter school including nine site visits by laco staff
including the charter school office our facilities unit pupil attendance accounting and compliance
los angeles county selfa and even our laco board members have visited the school
two comprehensive meetings with the executive director and members of the time governing board
monthly fiscal monitoring bi-weekly zoom meetings with all county authorized charter schools
and of course regular meetings calls and emails with their laco assigned coordinator
unfortunately time has been unwilling to implement much of the fiscal guidance offered by laco staff
based on laco's extensive experience with new charter schools therefore despite this widespread
support laco staff were prompted to send two notifications of concern
delivered to the time board on january 26th and june 28th of 2022 i'll now pass the presentation
over to my colleague dr brown to review some of our fiscal concerns with the time school
thank you and good afternoon board president board members the following fiscal concerns
were listed in the laco january 26 2022 notice of concern time failed to demonstrate fiscal
viability for the 2122 school year and subsequent fiscal years due to its enrollment shortfall
deficit spending potential cash deficiencies reliance on debt and a negative net ending position
for the 2122 school fiscal year laco sent time a second notice of concern on june 28 2022
based on continued unrealistic enrollment and average daily attendance projection
which grossly impacted revenue and school operations additional concerns were documented
in the notice including the school's projected fiscal insolvency debt accumulation and unreliable
cash projections
the current concerns regarding time community school are listed on the slide in front of you
and will be detailed in the slides to follow one more thanks now we're good
pardon me the current concerns regarding time community school are listed on the
slide in front of you and will be detailed in the slides to follow of note is the fact that
the school's adopted budget for the current school year again included unrealistic enrollment and
88 projections in spite of guidance from laco to plan more conservatively based on the enrollment
and attendance shortfall from the previous school year this pattern of planning will continue to
perpetuate a structural deficit and fiscal insolvency despite any significant one-time
funds secured by the school
both laco and cd staff found that time's budget and multi-year projections are based on unrealistic
enrollment and 88 projections in addition time's fiscal and salt fiscally and time is fiscally
insolvent excuse me for the current school year and subsequent two fiscal years due to
structural deficits inadequate cash and continued accumulation of debt
the table before you illustrates time's unrealistic enrollment and 88 projections
for the last fiscal year and current fiscal year in 2021-22 time projected an ada of approximately
156 students but a certified p2 report showed an ada of approximately 34 students a shortfall of
122 students or 78 percent below the projected ada in 2022-23 time projected an ada of approximately
104 students but its reported p1 ada showed approximately 55 students a shortfall of 49
students or 47 percent below projected ada it should be noted that in correspondence to the
it should be noted that in correspondence to the state board on july july 8 2022 time stated that
enrollment for its second year included 70 fully registered students with an additional 15
registrations in progress for a total of 85 students however time began the 22-23 school year
with 63 students in addition the school is considering projecting 125 students for next
school year which is almost double its current enrollment
the table before you summarizes time's financial projections for the last fiscal year and current
fiscal year times 2021-22 adopted budget projected an operating surplus of approximately 375 thousand
dollars and an ending net position of approximately 468 thousand dollars however the school ended the
fiscal year with a deficit of just over 378 thousand dollars and a negative ending net position
of 268 thousand 436 dollars times 2022-23 adopted budget projected an operating surplus of
approximately 509 thousand dollars and an ending net position of approximately 285 thousand dollars
however the school's first interim report updated its projections to incur a deficit
of approximately 68 thousand dollars and an ending net position of negative 336 thousand
748 dollars for the 22-23 school year times actual revenues and expenses from july 1 through
december 31st reflect an operating deficit of 424 thousand 269 dollars and an ending net position
of negative 692 thousand 704 dollars laco remains concerned with times fiscal insolvency status
due to the level of deficit deficit spending rising debts and cash deficiencies times reserves
for economic uncertainties is negative 23.3 percent which is substantially below the three
percent minimum reserve required pursuant to the laco monitoring memorandum of understanding
the table before you summarizes the changes in times fiscal position based on reported actuals
from july 1 through december 31st due to deficit spending as previously discussed times total
assets have decreased from 226 663 dollars to negative 19 432 dollars a decrease in total assets
by approximately 246 thousand dollars the negative net assets of 19 432 dollars is due to the sale
of future state aid receivables of two hundred and 247 thousand and 600 dollars offset by other
assets including cash a cash balance of fourteen thousand one hundred and eighty nine dollars
times total liabilities increased from july 1 from a july 1 balance of approximately
four hundred and ninety five thousand dollars to 673 273 dollars as of december 31st an increase
in total liabilities of approximately 178 thousand dollars or 36 percent total net assets decreased
by 424 269 dollars
as previously stated times unrealistic projections have contributed significantly to
its current fiscal position the school's adopted 2223 budget included approximately
two hundred and forty seven thousand dollars in revenue from subleasing space within the
school's facility leco staff met with time to express concern regarding the school's ability
to secure subleases totaling the budgeted amount the amount was later revised to 150 thousand
dollars in anticipated subleasing revenue time has actualized just 16 140 dollars in subleasing
revenue through january of 2023 which projects a shortfall in subleasing revenue of approximately
101 thousand dollars i will now turn the presentation back over to mr chicarelli
thank you dr brown
so this table further illustrates times ongoing realistic revenue projections i know
dr brown just talked a little bit there about the leasing but i want to highlight that this is sort
of an ongoing issue with the school so in 2023 their adopted budget for the school year projected
two hundred forty seven thousand five hundred dollars in annual revenues for subleasing as
dr brown just said at the start of the year these leases had not been executed and a revised budget
in october then projected 150 000 despite still having un-executed leases in december school
leadership assured leco that a january lease for ten thousand dollars a month was forthcoming
in january this was revised again to begin in february and in february revised yet again to
begin in march now for six thousand rather than ten thousand just as times projected lease revenue
in year two was unrealistic so too has their budgeted attendance rate despite historic data
to the contrary time budgeted at a 95 attendance rate this year
this significantly impacts the projected and budgeted aba
this slide here illustrates the concerns with debt accumulation and cash management
as of december 31st 2022 time has a total liabilities of approximately six hundred
seventy three thousand dollars comprised of the following six promissory notes totaling over
two hundred seventy nine thousand five of which are due to the executive director
and one to a private individual and all of which have been defaulted for at least six months
accounts payable and accrued liabilities totaling over three hundred seven thousand
and a california school financing authority loan balance of over eighty six thousand
additionally time has not submitted a plan to retire this outstanding debt
as of december 31st 2022 time had a cash balance of just over a little a little over fourteen
thousand or just four days of operating cash the school has been late on several facilities
lease payments incurring late fees and so due to its structural deficit rising debts and inadequate
cash time may not be able to meet its financial obligations including payroll and related expenses
in the current and subsequent fiscal years
lastly the time boards approved fiscal policies included in the charter petition
state that the governing board will approve all loans from third parties
on january 31st 2023 laco received a promissory note for a loan to time executed on january 12th
2023 the school's executive director confirmed that the board approved the promissory note
after it was executed and in direct violation of the adopted fiscal policies this matter poses
concerns regarding the school's adherence to the checks and balances delineated in the fiscal
policies so as this board can see we have serious concerns with time's ability to meet its fiscal
responsibilities we understand that there have been challenges having been a charter leader myself
i was often faced with challenges that were beyond my control good school leaders don't lead problem
free lives they're simply able to respond to challenges and adjust accordingly unfortunately
at every point where time leadership is given the opportunity to adjust their budget according to
real numbers they refuse to do so they do not use historic or baseline data and therefore fail to
manage their money accordingly this is why in two years the school's debt has ballooned to almost
700 000 without a realistic plan to remove this debt time continues to have a structural deficit
such that even if the school were able to receive significant one-time funds
this structural deficit would maintain its fiscal insolvency we've given advice our seasoned and
experienced fiscal advisors have given advice we don't want any of our schools to fail we would
love to see time's latest plan come to fruition which includes income from community bingo
maybe the non-profit will start making five thousand dollars a week from bingo
however we can't ignore historical data evidencing an inability to follow through
we cannot in good conscience simply hope for the best without planning for the worst
a positive vote from you today doesn't close this school again the non-profit could start
making five thousand dollars from bingo next week and when the actual closure vote comes in may
you could be looking at a very different financial picture we sincerely hope that's true
but we need to advocate for the students and staff that will suffer if it's not we need to
stop this debt train before there is a mid-year closure that would be devastating to this
community again your vote today does not close this school we urge you to issue a notice of
violation today and give the school one last chance to make good on its promise to this community
i'll now hand the presentation back to the cde staff thank you
thank you so the conclusion and recommendation is that time has failed to meet generally accepted
accounting principles and has engaged in fiscal mismanagement the cde recommends the state board
consider issuing a notice of violation to time pursuant to ed code section 47607 g upon the
chartering authorities issuance of a no the school is provided with a reasonable opportunity to
remedy the violations and that concludes our presentation thank you so much very much appreciated
while this item is not a public hearing we would like to provide an opportunity
for the charter school to make a brief presentation dr gabriel ramirez the executive
director of time community school now have five minutes to address the state board
and i believe he may be zooming in may may i share my screen yes you're you're with us we see you
um
dr hammon can you see the screen yes i can see you and i can see your slides
great thank you i'll begin uh good afternoon good afternoon president darlene hammon state
board members and dr thurman my name is dr gable ramirez and i'm the executive director and founder
of time community schools a charter unanimously approved by the state board in july 2020 to serve
the underserved community of monobelo i'd like to reacquaint you with who we are and who we serve
we are a community where only 30 of students upon graduation are eligible to apply to a four-year
university after the age of 25 only 16 percent have a degree of a or higher approximately 70
of the students who have come to tcs come with an average gpa of 1.5 in our first year 45 percent
of our students were el and 40 percent were sped students both rates are 10 higher than the
districts here's what we've accomplished in our first two years after year one our students had
an average gpa of 2.5 this year year two after semester one our students had an average gpa of
2.8 ninth grade students scored higher than the national average on nwa in english 100 percent
of our students participate in our dual enrollment program with east los angeles college 100 percent
of our students pursue cte pathways and internships 100 percent of our students participate in clubs
100 percent of our students receive tutoring time is fully wask accredited tcs has been accepted
into the league of innovative schools the first single school to receive this honor tcs was just
awarded a 78 000 grant so its teachers can participate in the modern classroom project
a grant typically given to district schools were awarded to tcs because of our innovative model
tcs has identified and secured partnerships with six middle schools to promote our school and to
allow us to recruit on sites tcs has established 25 community-based organizations and businesses
that have committed to promoting time to all its families and providing internships i will now
review with you where we departed our understanding of the issues from what is written in the board
item the october 6th and 11th letters from laco were not letters labeled letters of concern and
they did not warn about replication they were letters following up on a submitted on submitted
reports asking for additional information and plans no further follow-up to these letters
were made which we reasonably understood to mean that laco was satisfied with our response
we do not have declining enrollment our enrollment grew 50 in year two we currently have 60 new
applications with the goal of acquiring 125 applications of these time needs approximately
30 students for next school year to remain viable and address our financial deficits
our preliminary budgets were not unrealistic we were constantly updating them as actual
enrollment was determined it is important to understand that a key problem here is not
mismanagement but rather the failure of laco and cde to provide the mandatory letter of good
standing in order for us to obtain the funding our students are otherwise entitled to our fiscal
shortfalls are not a result of mismanagement or failure to follow accounting principles
they are a result of being denied a letter of good standing which impacted several funding streams
typically available to new charter schools including pcsgp sp740 prop 39 the revolving
loan denial of these funds required legal intervention and legal bills totaling over
140 000 of first year up our first year of operation 2122 monabella offered substandard
inadequate prop for 39 facilities we agreed mid-year to settlement which the district then
breached so we had no real school year during the 2122 school year you considered a notice of
violation in july 22 but voted against us to allow a chance to operate in a new facility
the january 23rd letter identifies a due date of march 9th today to respond any action today
seems premature but i'd like to address the concerns in the draft notice the draft notice
states at time is in default but this is incorrect no lender has claimed default on any loan for
non-payment new agreements have been approved to allow an extension of repayment and one a lender
has agreed to a gift their to gift their portion of the loans totaling over 218 000 the remaining
notes are intended to be addressed this school year cd staff also states that the final audit
for the 2122 states that time is in default with loans but again this is incorrect the audit had
no findings the audit does mention that recurring deficit as a going concern but the audit further
states that the leading cause is due to enrollment issues in part due to the pandemic to clarify
cde's misstatement regarding defaults per the audit the charter school revolving loan is not
in default monthly payments are deducted from our monthly apportionments from state aid lastly the
audit does recognize the school's plan to reduce the deficit in regards to enrollment we have
conservatively budgeted for the next two years starting with 2324 with an enrollment of 92
students 30 more than we have now at an 88 rate of 90 which mirrors our p1 numbers allowing us to
end the year at a surplus of 209 000 in the 2425 we intend to eliminate the cumulative of all
year's deficit to meet the minimum moe reserve of three percent by enrolling 160 students and
maintaining the conservative 90 80 which is 143 students beyond state aid we have two other
revenue streams in the forms of sub leases and fundraising via bingo if bingo revenue materializes
as plans to be able to address debt this year in the coming years reducing debt sooner than
expected as you can see your time is up thank you thank you very much for that presentation
members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item they do so in person or by calling
the telephone number and using the access code on the slide that we are about to put back on the
screen public comment slide
and while we're waiting for members of the public to call in i want to ask our liaisons
vice president glover woods and member oaken if they have any initial comments
and then i'll ask board members if they have any clarifying questions before we go to public comment
thank you president darling hammon and i'd like to start my comments by thanking dr ramirez for
his presentation and also thank you to the laco staff and cd staff this is always a very difficult
conversation for a board to have i just want to point out to the board that we as was shared in
the presentation have been here before if you will and the fiscal situation is worse than it was
when it was before us we had some concerns about the language around fiscal mismanagement and i
believe the cd staff and their definition have helped to clarify what that means the other
aspect of it is we if my memory serves me right we were recognizing the impact of the pandemic
on the enrollment unfortunately again as we see the numbers the enrollment has not reached by the
desired ada that the school has and the hole is getting deeper and deeper and deeper so i just
bring all of that before you for consideration i will close with the statement that was made
from our staff from the staff from laco any vote that we put forward today for a notice of violation
is not closing the school it provides opportunity for the school to come back to the board
provide additional information and then determination can be made on next steps from that point
and i will conclude my comments and give the rest of the time to member oaken if
i didn't take everything and i do i apologize i can always come up with something
um i also want to thank all of our presenters today um this is a serious and um weighty
um issue before us um as we listen to um the presentation from the school you hear so many
positive impacts on kids and um you know that's ultimately what we're about and at the same time
at the same time as the authorizer of this school we have a responsibility
and so i want to just take a quick second to review what that responsibility is
because it may be new to some of us so as we've heard this is a school that was authorized by us
the state board and in fact it was one of the last charter schools that was authorized by the
state board before ab 1505 changed our role as an authorizer um and as you can see uh as you heard
la county office of education is the is providing the oversight and monitoring rather than the
district um and this is the second time that we've had before us this um recommendation that we issue
a notice of violation um so just to explain the statement explain the notice of violation
all charter authorizers are required by ed code to notify their charter schools when a violation
takes place and that's important because schools need to know when they are in serious jeopardy
when the issue arises at one of the state board authorized charter schools
the responsibility for issuing that notice of violation lies with us
the board also has the obligation to provide its charter schools with a reasonable opportunity
to address concerns so as we've heard a couple times this notice of violation would not mean
that the school closes immediately it means that they would be back before us to try and address
some of the issues that we heard today and specifically if we issue a notice of violation
today time will appear will appear before our advisory the advisory commission on charter
schools in april and to share their plans to address the issues that we heard about today
they would also it would give them time and opportunity to demonstrate their plan
and strategy for fiscal stability which is ultimately what this is about
and so that's sort of the big picture and they would return before us in may
it would allow time for the accs cde and laco to consider this the strengths of time's plan and
return to the full board in may with a recommendation regarding next steps for us to consider
all right that's the end of my comments all right and do we have any public comment in the room
yes there is one person signed up for public comment thank you
what a surprise i'm back all right um good afternoon state board of education members my
name is lorraine richards and i'm a classroom teacher representing california teachers
association i am also a teacher from monabella high school where time was co-located
originally cta supports the cde recommendation to issue a notice of violation to time community
school there is substantial evidence time has not engaged in prudent fiscal management and has failed
to meet generally accepted accounting principles resulting in projected revenues that are
insufficient to meet its operational expenses and financial commitments this will be the third
instance in which time has been in front of the state board of education and each instance the
cde has expressed significant concerns with their financial models the additional concerns regarding
the personal loans made by the executive director to time are extremely troubling and the fact that
the recent loan in january 2023 did not follow the adopted fiscal policies exasperates these
concerns cta supports the cde recommendation to issue a notice of violation to time community
school thank you thank you it looks like we have about 15 callers in the queue i will open the
phone line now
good afternoon state board of education please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon state board of education members my name is david navar and i am president of
monabella teachers association mta supports the cde recommendation to issue a notice of violation
to time community school all students deserve a quality free public education education dollars
are mismanaged students are denied what they deserve it seems public education dollars are
making their way to bankers to lawyers property managers where it is clear public education
dollars are not going to students in case of cd recommendation it's time to issue a notice of
violation and community schools and time to move forward revocation thank you and have a
great rest of your meeting thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now alexandra soto
hello good afternoon my name is alexandra soto and i'm a board member for time community school
for three years that i have served on the board it has been an uphill battle for that we face
and overcome year after year i have seen pcs go from being an idea to sharing physical space with
a district school to standing on its own in the building it is located in now in a similar way
that other industries are struggling coming out of this pandemic so our schools an analysis by
the associated press stanford university big local news project and stanford education professor
thomas d found an estimated 230 000 students in 21 states whose absences could not be accounted
for they didn't move out of state they didn't sign up for private schools in short they're just
missing and this is just schools all in general so you can understand that a school that was born
in a pandemic facing extremely adverse conditions could not be should not be penalized for surviving
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now
good afternoon president hangman and board member my name is osiel canales and i'm a student at time
this is my second year at tcs i'm a student who has never really liked school to be honest it is
still not my favorite but ever since i've been coming to this school i have been doing better
dr amiris and teachers never give up on us even when we're missing a lot they always support us
and if it wasn't for dr amiris and time i don't think a lot of other students he will be doing
well somewhere else the students here need this school we want to be successful please support
time and vote no thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
your time starts now
caller ending within the last four digits five three five seven you are now live please start
your public comment hello my name is jessica as well and i am a teacher from monabella high
school as well as a member representing the monabella teachers association mta supports
the cde recommendation to issue a notice of violation to time community school time continues
to be brought up before you for wrongdoing while co-locating at monabella high school the site in
the district worked collaboratively to meet time's request however its inability to be responsible
with their budget is leading to failed promises to students students that represent the community
of monabella unified one of the many examples of failed compliance is time continues not to provide
a counselor with the proper credentials issued by the state of california which was an issue of
concern last time they came up to board this mismanagement of funds that brings time before
you is taking away from students who represent some of the neediest in the state from being
provided an equitable education this is concerning with the needs of students in mind it is time to
issue a notice of violation and time to move towards revocation thank you thank you next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon my name is missa morenco
go ahead and start your public comment you are live
thank you state board of education members my name is mrs. morenco and i'm the principal at
monabella christian school i have a master's in education as well as as a bachelor's in business
management economics i want to thank you in advance for your opportunity for my voice to be heard
it is imperative that you understand what a positive impact time committee school has been
in the monabella and la county community i think it's imperative parents have a choice in options
on where to send their children for high school and time has been that choice for our own alumni
students with a short time of existence time has been a place for our students to flourish
have their voice heard and a place where they finally feel like they belong not everyone can
afford a private education trust me i know and unfortunately the public high school options are
slim and unappealing in our community and time has been literally a lifesaver for many of our
graduates i leave you with my favorite quote flowers bloom where they find room and so do
children and i urge you to vote no on the violation so the students can continue to attend time where
they have found their room to flourish i also want to address the quote where it says that
dr americh should be a good school leader thank you your time is up leaders need support i ask
you to stand with him and be that support thank you thank you next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi my name is caving in i'm the assistant superintendent of educational services with
the monabella unified school district i'm calling the comment on the notice of violation for time
community school from the beginning of the proposition 39 process with time which began
in november 2020 time barely met the minimum threshold for in-district students to qualify
for prop 39 the district approved shared use of facilities with time to provide equal and comparable
facilities equipment and furniture to time throughout the school year times enrollment
did not meet their prop 39 projections in fact their enrollment declined the district went above
and beyond to meet the requests that time had for facilities we installed new and separate network
just for time installed a new phone system provided laptops to all students and staff rented a copy
machine for the time administrative office and gave them microscopes for the science classes
because of times under enrollment which caused them to have excess facilities the district was
able to charge an over allocation fee to time per prop 39 however the district decided not
to seek payment of approximately 230 000 in a way the district saved time close to a quarter
of a million dollars to blame the decline in times enrollment or financial woes on the district is a
fallacious argument thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
so
caller ending with the last four digits eight eight three eight you are now live
please start your public comment
okay moving on next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
it
hi my name is dylan smith and i'm from charter school capital we've worked with time since just
before they opened doors in fall of 2021 charter school capital as a financial partner does
extensive underwriting areas of fiscal responsibility educational progress and
authorized relations time has been proven to be an incredibly transparent and dedicated partner
and shared the concerns of laco in the fall we did not feel they were true layers of concern
as they would have triggered further underwriting processes and cessation of fundings from for the
school until those concerns were alleviated dr ramirez and his leadership team have dealt with
every challenge the start of charter school normally faces as well as a multitude of others
every time they've experienced lower than expected enrollment they make the financial adjustments
and share those updated budgets quickly and accurately we also evaluate those and feel the
school has demonstrated positive fiscal management i also like to know the charter school capital
consider purchasing the school's facility as is currently for sale and want to reiterate their
lease is secure for the next for the full five-year term no matter who ends up purchasing the
facility time has been a phenomenal member of his community with one of the strongest leadership
teams i've had the pleasure of working with over working within the charter space thank you thank
you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now hello my name is sarah aurora i am the english teacher at time community schools
i want to start by expressing my gratitude for being able to be a part of the dynamic team here
what we are a part of at time is truly unlike anything i've seen we have an innovative model
we are community oriented and we focus on building strong relationships with our students
i take pride in the fact that we know each and every one of our students by name we know the
challenges and struggles they face in and outside of the classroom and most importantly our students
trust us time is a truly special school because our because of our pursuit of individualized
learning which is the benefit of having a smaller school i urge the state board to vote no on the
notice of violation and to support the operation of time to do otherwise would be a disservice to
our students and to the community of montevallo thank you for listening thank you next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon president arnie hammond members of the board my name is nicholas watson speaking
on behalf of the california charter schools association because they oppose the issuance
of a notice of violation at time time was authorized in 2020 and has not yet completed
the second year of operation during which time has been forced to overcome numerous obstacles
including montevallo unified's refusal to provide a reasonably equivalent school facility
and the refusal of montevallo and laco to allow time to fully access critical state funding programs
including the public charter school grant program the charter school evolving loan program
and the charter school facility grant program despite these challenges time is providing a
quality public school option to students in need enrollment is increasing and time is working to
address the financial challenges that have resulted from the school's inability to access
funding programs available to other schools time should be able to continue the great work it's
doing with students without the issuance of a notice of violation thank you thank you
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time
starts now
caller ending with the last four digits two five two eight you are now live please start your public
comment good afternoon my name is alandre munoz and i lead the outreach community here for time
community schools i have more than 25 years of experience and have assisted doctor minors with
the establishment of many new community partnerships including the montevallo youth institute which
includes a round table of over 20 very public organizations i want to say that the hypocrisy
and and uh audacity of montevallo is staggering really enrollment seems to be down everywhere yet
we're being told we're down in enrollment counselors there's protests in the streets
for counselors yet we're being told we don't have equality counselors they're saying the system is
management when how can you have system is managing when the scenario you're trying to the people
you're counting on to give you an offer of good standing are refusing to do it and then accuse
you of mismanagement and uh this is really dr minors is not just a good leader he's a great
leader the whole community knows that montevallo i'm sure the high school knows that as well
and i was there when we asked them if we could use the water for the chemistry for the lab to do
to do scientifically and they said they did not have water thank you your time is up i mean that's
it thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have
one minute your time starts now
yes how you doing my name is mike mendia my son is a current sophomore at time community
this school has been a godson for my son's academic career and mental health my son's
grades have went from straight s in the local school district to a's and b's at time the school
and administrators have built up my son's self esteem and taken his academic success
to a complete 180 he could not get any help in his previous schools no matter how many times
we reached out the school has made a huge impact in his life right now as well as lighting fire
under him to want to go to college the staff administrators have are always there to talk
and the resources that provided tops here they truly care about each student individually
his previous school just looked at my school as a number whereas time looked at a child whose
skills were not tapped into and the and they have made such a positive impact in their life my
child has flourished under their tutelage and will be impacted both academically and his mental
health will take a huge hit if the school is taken away from him he used to have to go to therapy
to cope with school since he started time he does not need a therapist or medications are for
scrambling because if you get through school and i feel administrators are directly responsible
for his increase in confidence and better your time is up next caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi my name is Ruben Yiriyar i am the master here at time i want to express my deepest appreciation
for being a mathematics teacher here at time community schools as an educator i take pride
in being part of a team that is dedicated to providing high quality education for students
in the montevallo area i want to express my enjoyment working with the students here at
time the amount of enthusiasm and curiosity that pours out of this group of kids shows much how
much they want to learn as a teacher it motivates me to be the best version of myself for them and i
appreciate it i believe that closing or placing any kind of limitations on time community schools
would be a disservice to its students this school provides a valuable educational experience for
those that enroll and teachers and staff alike are dedicated to creating a safe and supportive
learning environment that fosters personal and academic growth i appreciate the students the
support provided by the school and the opportunities for professional development i urge you to consider
the value that time provides to the montevallo area and to support its continuation thank you
for your time thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have
one minute your time starts now
caller and good afternoon president and board members my name is amita dios
and i'm a student at time community schools i am a ninth grader and i want to share my experience
at time time is a good school that makes academics come first not only are we taking classes
that get us ready to apply to college but we are also able to take college classes now
dr amaya's and the teachers are always supporting us by providing opportunities like college
classes having experts come talk to us helping us get internships and by helping us explore all
careers everyone here cares about our success and is why i see students including myself do
better each day please support our school and vote no thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon my name is marisol madrigal uribe and i'm a school board member for the
montevallo unified school district because it does appear that time community school is attempting
to blame part of its fiscal mismanagement on montevallo unified i do feel compelled to provide
public comment on this matter the montevallo unified has always and we continue to abide by
the requirements of proposition 39 to claim to claim that a failure to do otherwise is a direct
to claim that a failure to do otherwise is a direct cause of times fiscal mismanagement
is disingenuous and a continued attempt to shift blame rather than taking responsibility
for its failure to recruit a sufficient number of students to its program
as evidence um i'm sorry i'm just rather than to acknowledge that its program cannot draw nearly
as many students as they would hope as evidenced by its continued struggles in its own facilities
other public comments claim time's ability to recruit students was negatively impacted due
to not being able to tell potential families where the school would be located this is simply
untrue and was provided facilities foreign excess of the needs of its initial 17 in district ada
for the entirety of the 2021 2022 school year thank you caller your time is up thank you caller
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now
parents
hi i'm a parent um i'm sitting here who has formally been in the la us school district
or two different schools and was assaulted for two different schools
we had very bad grades and we were homeless throughout those three years and the last year
of homelessness we we started at time community with the support from time community with the
programs with the individual support versus the big classes from the district my child is now one
of the top students he went from living in skid row and bad grades as one of the best students of
all of his classes i ask that you not issue a financial violation to time communities
and give the school more time to recruit more students who have struggled just like mine give
another child a chance to a better future just like mine thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
caller and good afternoon go ahead caller i apologize good good afternoon president
hayman and board members my name is isabella navarro and i'm a student at time community
school i'm a 10th grader and this is my first year at time prior to coming to time i was doing
bad in school in fact i was failing every single class after my first semester at time i got seven
b's and one c i feel excited about school now because i know that i can succeed here i like
all my teachers and my classes everyone supports me and makes sure that i get what i need please
support time and vote no today thank you thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
parent
see uh
yes
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
Yes
yes
Thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Yi Lin and I am a CEO of Take a Break Events, a party planning service.
I am also subleasing space within the school. First, I would like to say how much I enjoy
working with Dr. Ramirez and the students of Time. In fact, the program is so amazing that I
find myself volunteering my time and resources more and more each day. I know there are financial
concerns for Time. However, I would like to share how I will be contributing to Time financial success.
The base rent I am paying Time is $6,000. However, I am filling up my calendar with clients
and soon I will be providing Time anywhere between $10,000 and $15,000 each month. Further,
I am committed to introducing my family to Time as a school option because I want Time to succeed.
Lastly, as a parent of a child who had an IEP, I want to say how happy I am that there is a
school like Time. They really focus on the individual. Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. My name is Veronica Navarro. I am a union officer for the class of
our employees in Montebello. I just wanted to express that we agree with the CBE recommendation.
Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record. You have one minute. Your time starts now. Hello. My name is Adriana Dugan. I am from the
Montebello Chamber of Commerce. I am the director here. I am calling in support of Time Community
School. They are a Chamber member and they have been very involved from the time that they moved
here into the community. They have become a great asset for the Chamber. We do interns with their
students and delightful children that come in to help out with anything that we need help with,
social media, filing, etc. I know that other businesses in the community have also used them.
On a personal level, I am in support of the Time Community School here in our community.
Being a parent of a child with special needs in the past, it's nice to have another option for our
students. Not all children. The curriculum in a public school is not always... Thank you. Your time
is up. The district is not always the... Thank you. Your time is up. Next caller, please state your
name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Monica Maynard. I am a teacher with the Montebello Unified School District. I support
science at Montebello High School. The district made prioritizations for the needs of the
time students with equipment and space such as microscopes and classroom space. Since the last
time that time came before you, they have had the time to improve their program to ensure that they
provide students with the quality education that they deserve. The enrollment and the academic
growth data is missing. Students should not be the casualty of fiscal mismanagement. This takes away
from our community. I am a member of the Montebello community, support the CDE recommendation to issue
a violation to Time Community School. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Lamar Brown, president of Time Community School. Our school has made great
strides and we have been extremely successful connecting with our community, our parents,
and students. We have worked very hard to be the best school, and this is something we continue
to dedicate our time to, to ensure not only the success of our students,
but also the success of parents and the community. We have had unnecessary hurdles, but who doesn't?
We continue to be dedicated. We continue to work hard. We continue to make great progress,
and we continue to have success stories with our students, our community, and our parents.
Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You
have one minute. Your time starts now. Good afternoon, President Holman and board members.
My name is Iglali Spinoza. I am a student at Time Community Schools. I am a ninth grader,
and I love this school. This school has given me the opportunity like taking college classes.
We appreciate it in the clubs and every day. We get to be interns. This year I have been an
intern for a tax company, and I learned so much. In fact, my experience has been so good that the
owner wants to give me a job when I'm able. Time supports all students. They take the time to get
to know us. They support us individually. Please support Time and vote no. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You
have one minute. Your time starts now. Caller, ending in the last four digits,
2642, you are now live. Please start your public comment.
Hi, my name is Teresa Lopez, and I'm a community activist in Moravello with Moravello Blue Hearts
and Moravello Latino Unidos. And the reason is my call is to support the school because
they have a very great program who can send a lot of the kids, other students to universities,
which is that's going to increase the importance of education in our community. And I
think they're doing a good job, and I'm here to support them. Thank you. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, it's Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center. Good afternoon
to everybody. We understand you have a tough vote to take today. We really hope that
when you do that, you will give direction to staff to take every step possible to see to it
that the school receives the facilities, grants, and other funding that it deserves,
and so that the school is in a much better position to turn its finances around. Also,
bigger picture, we would urge the state board to reopen the regulations that govern the Prop 39
program and insert the binding arbitration provisions so that disputes such as the ones that
have made this school start problematic can be resolved in a much more
cost-effective and timely fashion. Thank you. Thank you. Okay, that concludes public comment
for item number 10. Thank you very much. At this point, we're open for board discussion.
Thank you. Member Lewis, are you moving your microphone because you wanted to speak?
I just appreciate all the callers calling in, and I think it's so touching to hear from the students
and the passion they have from the school. Just looking at, I appreciate the report by the LA
County Office of Education and the CDE staff that really laid out the picture of what's physically
going on at the school, and I think I appreciate the framing comments from Vice President Glover
Woods that if you do take a vote today to issue the notice of violation, that it doesn't mean
we're closing the school, that we give them an opportunity to come back before us. So again,
thank you. I think the joy is hearing from the kids and the success that they're having.
Senator Glover Woods?
I'd like to preface. I'd actually like to make a motion, but preface my motion with thank you to
the parents and to the students that called in, also again to the executive director of the school.
The school is based upon those comments making impact for students, and the goal of the
conversation today is really to ensure that it's still able to do so. So with that being said,
I move that we vote to issue a notice of violation to time pursuant education code 47607G.
Is there a second? I move Rodriguez. Is there any further discussion?
I'll just associate myself with the comments that we really do appreciate the
virtues that the school has been able to pull together, that we also hope that whatever
opportunities can be made available to them to continue the work will be made available, and we
will proceed on the basis of the unfortunate finances that we have had presented before us.
Any further discussion? If not, I'll call for the vote. All in favor of the motion as stated,
say aye. Aye. Aye. Any opposed? Any abstention? The motion carries, and we will
continue a pace, and if anyone needs to take a break, please take an individual break,
and we'll see you when you come back. We're going to put the public's comment slide up again,
and we're going to do, this is for general public comment. This is for any members of the public
wishing to provide comment on items that have not been on the board's agenda. Are there any
speakers signed up to provide public comment in person? Yes, there are two people signed up for
general public comment. Okay, thank you very much.
Good afternoon, board president and members. My name is Wilda Lee. I attended public schools in
LA County, California in the 80s. To add a tiny drop into a vast ocean of success stories,
I'd like to mention that I have two master's degrees. I received a graduate certificate
in theology, and I have a private pilot license. I had a very dedicated, super dedicated English
teacher who, when I was in school, mentioned that because they voted God out of school,
that he couldn't. He had to figure out how to introduce some of the life-defining guiding truths
into our curriculum, sorry, that which I longed for all semester I did. And then the story of
seeing guards that were never saw in school yards. So today, I'm very grateful for all the
educational opportunities I've had. I just wish I didn't have to feel like something deep and
profound was missing in my school education because God, God our creator was rejected,
and the seemingly reality. Thank you. Your time is up.
Thank you. We have another commenter. Yes.
Hi, my name is Hezekiah. Peace be with you all. And I'm here, my objective is to get people to
recognize that the reason for the growing violence and the mass shootings that have been occurring in
our society and in our schools are because people have failed to acknowledge God, our creator,
and I hold there is one God who is the creator of the world, that he's both good and just,
good in the sense of giving his air, water, and sun to all of us here, good and evil,
yet he's also just in that he judges everyone at some point in time according to their deeds.
Now, 3100 people have been shot in mass shootings in 2022 alone,
which has been recorded as among the highest in history according to CNN.
And since Columbine in 1999, more than 338,000 students in the US have been experiencing
gun violence at school. And in 2022 alone, 34 students and adults died while more than
43,000 children were exposed to gunfire at school according to the Washington Post.
President Hammond, we've been waiting all day. Do you mind if I have just a couple more moments?
I'm almost done. Thank you. What a child is taught does make a difference. And when a child is taught
that they come from the same ancestor as an ape 10 million years ago, why do we expect our children
not to act like apes? But to the contrary, when our children are taught that they're made in the
marvelous image of God and that God sees all things and judges each person, that can help
brittle the lusts of evil actions in our society. There's no evidence that we came from apes,
but we do have evidence of God by the fact of us being made in his image. Thank you.
More sentences there. Appreciate that. At this point, we are going to reopen
item two to take action on the preliminary report of actions draft January 2023 meeting minutes
to take up appointments to the advisory commission on special education and to report on our liaison
assignments. And again, we have the public comment slide up while we're waiting for any members.
Oh, there's more on the phone. I'm sorry. Yeah. Is there more public comment on the phone?
There is one person on the line, although I think they spoke towards the last item,
but I will answer it. Okay. Thank you. Good afternoon. Please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, this comment was for the item W03 sale of or lease surplus property by a Hayward Unified
School District. Good afternoon, members of the board. My name is Yun Chang and I'm speaking on
behalf of the Key Academy Charter School. One of the sites listed in the Hayward Unified School District.
Pardon me. I'm sorry, caller. Unfortunately, this is on this general public comment,
so it's only comment on items that were not agendized. You would have had to call in for
the waiver item to speak to that item. Thank you very much. I meant to call. I meant to call,
but then somehow the web live was a lot, I mean, delayed, so I wasn't able to call in time for the
request. I apologize. The action's been taken.
All right. Any other, anybody else on the phone line or we'll move ahead. Okay. We're reopening
item two to take action on the preliminary report of actions draft January, 2023 meeting minutes,
take up appointments to the advisory commission on special education and report
on our liaison assignments. And I think we need to put the public comments slide up yet again
for one of these later items. Yes. When we get to the special education advisory commission.
And while we're waiting on that queue to form, do I have an emotion to approve the January, 2023
state board of education draft preliminary report of actions slash meeting minutes?
Remember all good. All right. Thank you very much. And the motion is seconded by board member
Alaska Gonzalez. And is there any public comment? No public comment. Okay. Any further discussion?
All those in favor say aye. Aye. Any opposed? Any abstentions? All right. Motion carries.
I'm going to ask vice president Glover woods as chair of the state board screening committee
committee's recommendations for the appointments to the ACSE. And the public comments slide goes
back up again. And when after you've provided your overview, we will then go back to public comment.
Thank you, president Darling Hammond. I preface my comment by thanking everyone who applied for the
seats on the ACSE. Thank you so much for your interest. The screening committee would like
to recommend the appointment of the following individuals to a four year term for the ACSE.
Russell mitchell and I apologize if I mispronounced your name, sir,
who will be representing charter schools and Matthew Wilkins, who will be representing
parent of a child with disabilities. And do we have any public comment in the room or on the phone?
There is no one in the room. Sign up for public comment. And no one on the phone.
Is there anyone on the phone? We do not. All right. I'll ask members Lewis and Escobedo,
who also served on this year's screening committee, if they have any initial comments for us.
No, we just had just an amazing number of participants that we had to review and screen
just so many worthy candidates and really appreciate all those who submitted their
paperwork and appreciate the team. I believe this is our final round. Perhaps we'll see,
but it's just great working with this amazing team. So thank you.
Say ditto.
Well, we're fortunate to have so many people willing to contribute their time
and knowledge and expertise to our commission. So thank you very much for reviewing and recommending.
So we're open for board discussion. Is there any further discussion on this item?
And if not, may I get a motion to adopt the recommendations of the screening committee?
I move that the board accept the recommended
appointees for the ACSC. I get it. Thank you. Did you catch that? All right. All in favor say aye.
Aye. Any opposed? Any abstentions? The motion passes. Thank you so much Vice President Glover
Woods and members Escobedo and Lewis for that review work. And now I want to invite our
state board members to report on their liaison activities that are not related to items on the
March agenda. And I'm going to go in alphabetical order starting with member Escobedo and then down
the alphabet. I just want to remind the board that I'm part of the planning committee and meeting with
NASVY, the National School Board Association on this Tuesday. So if you have any items you'd
like to see in our annual October meeting, which will be held in San Diego, please, please send me
send me an email. As part of my duties with Wested, CEO Glenn Harvey after I believe
been in that position for over almost two decades, maybe three decades. She is
retiring and so we're working on obtaining a search firm to find a CEO for Wested. As you
well know Wested is one of the premier research organizations and they've done a lot of great
work here in California as well as other states such as such as Arizona and Nevada and so forth.
So that is all I have to report. Thank you. Vice President Glover Woods.
Thank you President Darling-Hammond. Just two quick updates. One for the Instructional Quality
Commission. Member Lewis and I had an opportunity to attend the January 25th and 26th meeting.
The first day was a phenomenal one for the commissioners to get to know themselves and
to get to know their work. There were a lot of wonderful orientation activities and again kudos
to the CDE staff, Dr. Torres and others for that work. We also took time to issue the oath of office
to the newest commissioners as well during that time and Lily Jarvis was selected as the chair
for one year term. Lindsay Gotanda for vice chair will serve as vice chair.
As it relates to the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, I just want to share with
the board that the CCEE continues to work diligently to provide support to our LEAs and
others in the state. The Community Engagement Initiative is in its third year of implementation
and is continuing to provide support as is designed and they are utilizing improvement
science and they are developing a plan for community and family engagement and currently
they're supporting over 600,000 students. They are also working, CCE is also working on the
Learning Acceleration Systems Grant and there are three grantee projects that are contributing to
those sustainable learning networks. And lastly, the CCEE is continuing to facilitate support for
the statewide system of support and continuing to work to build coherence amongst all of those
entities of the statewide system of support. That concludes my update for the CCEE. Thank you,
Member Lewis. As Vice President Glover Woods mentioned, the California Department of Education
facilitated a discussion to solicit input on potential edits to the current IQC bylaws which
had not been amended since 2012 and they were given a summary of the bylaws and had the
opportunity to suggest amendments which they will bring back to the meeting next Tuesday on
March 15th. There was a lot of valuable input provided regarding the virtual meeting options
for the future and also, oh I'm so sorry, he's in my key voice, sorry. Okay, can you again,
the members of the commission submitted suggestions for revisions to the bylaws that included
amending language about the student member and also virtual meeting options and language related
to increased collaboration with the state board. It was a very rich discussion and if the IQC
determines that further edits are needed during the March meeting next week, then
SBE action may take place in July instead of at our May meeting. Otherwise, they'll be brought
to our May meeting. I think that's it. Member McQuillan, and I'll remind everyone to use your
mics. Yes, I'll be brief. My report is on the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory
Committee. The overview is the Joint Pathways Advisory Committee, C-W-P-J-A-C, and I'll only
say that once, is a collaborative between California Department of Ed, CD, and the California
Community Colleges Chancellor's Office, CCCCO. The committee meets quarterly and works to address
systems alignment policies specific to career pathways within the context of recent and future
state and federal investments. I think of the two electric cars I drove in to get here from way up
north and who's going to work on those in the future, and I think of the problems I had on
getting on the computer this morning, you know, the folks who are going to work on those in the
future, and then our health care and my own health, my family's health, and the skills-based
positions for that. That's what we're talking about when we're talking about CTE.
One of the primary areas of focus for the 22-23 committee is to provide guidance on the draft
California State Plan for CTE. Note this plan is different from California's
20-23 Federal Perkins V State Plan. The plan we're talking about aligns all state funded CTE
initiatives. The draft plan will go before the committee on March 10th. Tomorrow we have a
meeting for approval, and then the CCCCO, the Chancellor's Office, will present the approved
plan as an informational item to the Board of Governors meeting. This summer we'll kick off
state-level activities in support of the plan.
This year there was $300 million allocated or available for allocation from CTIG funds.
In our January meeting, we approved 375 grantees or $265 million to go out to LEAs.
Because funds continue to be available, there was an 8B round, which we just approved in our
consent agenda today, which was five new applicants. And that's all I have to say. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Member Olken.
Thank you. So I am, one of my, a new assignment is I'm the liaison to environmental literacy
for the state. I mentioned that briefly last month. And due to the climate experience we're
having, I'm going to keep my comments about environmental literacy short. Thank you for
getting the humor there. Yeah. So it's been really exciting to get my arms around the work
that's going on related to environmental literacy in the state. And as we come together every month
that it's clearer and clearer why this work matters. And so just to give a quick framework
around the type of work that's happening, there's sort of three big buckets. There's work that's
related to environmental literacy itself, what students are learning, experiencing,
how they're understanding the role they can play in relation to the environment and
long-term sustainability. So that's sort of classroom-based, curriculum-based,
experience-based. There's also work that's related to how the system of schools,
think about all the buildings and buses and concrete yards that we have contribute,
can contribute in a positive way or can continue to
degrade our environment. So there's sort of the bucket around buildings and grounds
and the footprint of schools. And then I think a through line and all of the work is related to
environmental justice and the ways in which we need to look at the different experiences
of our young people in different communities in relation to the types of environmental impacts
and climate change that they're facing, the types of experiences that they're having
to grow their critical thinking and their opportunities as parts of the solution.
And specifically in the, so that's the big picture. I think the part I'm supposed to be
focusing on specifically is related to the first bucket, what's happening in classrooms. And so
as a result of, in California, the work around environmental literacy and
climate change in our classrooms has been going on a long time, but there's been some very specific
work recently. Most recently in the budget act of 2021, $6 million were appropriated.
Actually, I'm not sure if that's the right language. There were $6 million set aside
to create K through 12 standards-based curriculum that would be free for
schools across the state in grades, in grade levels K through 12. And so I started
attending the meetings that are quarterly to oversee that work and to sort of check
in about where it's going. And it's really incredible work with partners around the state
who are developing a unit at each grade level that will be supporting hands-on problem-based,
rich experience-based curriculum. And so I'll continue to share out on that as we continue.
And I'm going to talk quickly about two other things. One is I'm continuing to attend and
participate in meetings related to the statewide IEP template that we're working to develop. And
that's incredible work with the goal of ensuring that as a state, we have a consistent way of
leading, documenting, and thinking about our team meetings to support our students with
disabilities. And we have a full day retreat coming in June to continue that work. And so
I'll report out on that further. And then the last thing is when we were
talking about the state seal of civic engagement, and also some of our work yesterday when we were
talking about the assessments and performance tasks that are real world and get kids and young
people excited about the work and seeing their relevance in the real world, it reminded me of
a couple of sessions I've been to recently that were put on by the early math initiative
in California led by some folks in the room. But where they're really trying to,
the most recent seminar, the tagline was play more, learn more. And so it's really about how do we
help students see themselves as mathematicians and scientists and problem solvers. There's an
activity, there is a video of, well, there's an activity where we all built ramps and rolled
things down them to show even for our youngest learners that they can understand and make
educated guesses around complicated mathematical and scientific standards. So it's just really
good stuff, and I'm excited to be part of it. Thank you. Member Rusko Gonzalez.
Well, yesterday I shared out quite a bit on assessments, and Member Olken actually said
a little bit about what my gem of yesterday was. So I just wanted to share out that part, which is
I always say gem because it's like the highlight of the day. My gem of the day in the assessment
system should be designed to be culturally responsive and to ensure that every student
can see themselves in the assessment experience and that it guides teachers in the class on how
to tailor instruction. And I loved the experience of having that study session because I think
it allows all the members to participate in the experience and to give input and we can all learn
from dialogue and collaboration, so great experience. Thank you. Member Patillo Bronson.
I'm going to try and hold to the one-minute rule that other public comments have to do.
If we do that, we'll make it by three. The Universal Pre-K Mixed Delivery Quality and
Access Workgroup has met twice now since the new year, and I'll flag two trends which I think are
really powerful for us to consider in future meetings. One is that as focus groups were done
for parents, psychological and emotional safety was named the highest priority of incoming parents
where parents themselves asked, is this a setting where my child may face the same racism or
discrimination that I have faced? And that's just powerful to grapple with, especially in a 60-second
format. The other thing that they have uncovered is that there are wide disparities in terms of
child outcomes depending on setting, and I think it sets up thinking about the different systems
of support that exist in the K-12 system that also could be brought to bear in early childhood and
early learning. And then the last is a quick update on the California State Summer School
for the Arts, which the headline is, they are back. In person this summer, they had a significant
dip in enrollment and applications during the pandemic, and they came back with a roaring
almost 40% increase in applicants and will be at effectively the same enrollment numbers as they
were pre-pandemic. And that brings my report to a close. Perfect. Thank you. Lots of good news there.
Member Porter. Thank you so much President Darling-Hammond. Good afternoon board members
and members of the public. One of my main goals as a student board member this year was to further
connect student board members to each other and to educate students about ways to take initiative
and full advantage of opportunities. So first, I was able to meet with over 200 students from
Los Angeles Unified School District, Corona Norco Unified School District, and Fremont Unified
School District to get that diverse perspective of student voices from across the state. I was
also able to connect with state student board members from Pennsylvania and Maryland to discuss
different methods of advocacy. Second, I presented at CASCS Region 10 Conference to 58 high school
students at the Orange County Office of Education, where I facilitated two sessions about leadership,
building teams, starting nonprofits, and how to find one's passion and turn it into someone's
life purpose. Lastly, one of the highlights of the past few months was being guest teacher
at the LAUSD Science Academy STEM Magnet School, where I presented to 430 middle and high school
students about the intersection between science, education, and taking initiative. I received
questions about my position on the SBE ranging from how public comment shapes policy priorities
from a high school senior to my favorite question from a sixth grader, can I fit in your suitcase
to Sacramento? And that concludes my report. Member Rodriguez. Thank you. And did you bring
the sixth grader? Not this time. We haven't checked. Good afternoon board members and members of the
public. I have a few short CTC related updates. Last month the CTC heard a very informative
presentation from staff in West Ed on California's implementation of teacher residencies.
Residencies are a collaboration between LEAs and educator preparation programs
to create a hands-on preparation experience alongside a mentor teacher. And research establishes
that residency prepared teachers are better prepared to teach diverse students and are more
likely to stay in the classroom. Residents in California are racially diverse and are being
prepared in several credential areas including special education. West Ed has launched a residency
dashboard and the CTC item itself has rich data on student demographics, completion rates,
and stipends being provided to teacher candidates. It's very exciting that soon the CTC will select
a residency TA center. The RFA is due on Friday to support statewide implementation. The CTC also
reviewed and adopted the literacy program standards and teaching performance
expectations for education specialists. Credential to teach literacy to students with visual
impairments, the deaf and hard of hearing. Experts and advocates for these unique learners were
consulted through focus groups and came to inform the commission staff. Incredible work in this area.
It means a lot when the legislature directs the CTC to update its literacy standards. The next step
in assembly bill 488 implementation will be preparing the new literacy performance assessment
for field teaching for the myriad of credential holders who will be able to take this improved
assessment of their ability to teach literacy. And this item was incredibly humbling for me by the way.
Lastly as you know I'm on the NASB PEP public education position committee and we chose our
the items that we'll be exploring and presenting at the conference in October in San Diego that
member Escobedo referred to. And we chose accountability, accreditation, and school
improvement. Rethinking state accountability systems, designing student academic and non-academic
measures, developing school quality indicators, and supporting school continuous improvement.
And these are national so there we come together and present these to NASB. And then the second
item is high school redesign which I'm on this team. Graduation pathways, graduation requirements,
and course taking patterns, career and college readiness. The same day right before the PEP
meeting I was invited in my role as teacher and SBE member to participate in NASB's office hours.
There was a presentation by Educators Thriving, an organization in partnership with AFT has designed
a survey tool to define the most predictive factors of educator well-being and help measure
educator well-being to inform policies and practices to support and sustain educator well-being.
The organization is working with several school districts across the country and in our state
to implement professional development for educators that is meaningful and increases
their well-being and they're also working with induction programs. The presentation covered the
latest survey findings. The six most predictive factors of educator well-being. They shared how
educator wellness is important for attracting and retaining teachers and the ways in which
policymakers can use this data to inform policy making and ensure that local districts work to
ensure PD that matches what the educators need and desire. And the six predictors, and I'll end with
this, responsive leadership, supportive culture, acceptance, adaptability, professional growth
orientation, personal well-being, and absence of depletion. Thank you so much. That concludes my
report. Thank you so much. Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Hi. So I have two reports today. Again, brief. English learners, our regional English learner
specialists were in person in Sacramento in February 15 and they had a chance to talk about
how they're going to measure their own effectiveness as it relates to the work that
they're doing in the state. The OPTAL is an observation protocol to help teachers
assess academic language for English learners and we are still looking for teachers of all grade
levels to help pilot that assessment, particularly Northern California and elementary teachers. So
please put the word out. And then finally, the Advisory Commission on Special Education,
if you have a pen, write this down. The El Dorado County Office and SELPA colleagues presented
the system of improvement leads work and the URL is systemimprovement.org.
So an LEA across the state can find their data and drill down to see the percentage of time
students are spending in general education versus special education and also there's a data center
that allows LEAs to desegregate information by multiple variables and compare performance to
state indicators. So I would just encourage folks to visit that systemimprovement.org website and
take a look there. And then finally, David Toffsten was selected as the vice chair of the AXE
and as our own board member reporter demonstrates the power of youth leadership,
the AXE is preparing to select two new student members to serve on its commission. Thank you.
Thank you. And I'll just reinforce that the NASB conference that you've heard about from both
Francisco and Aide is open to all of our board members. So you should be hearing from NASB about
that and it will be in October in San Diego in our state. I hear from the NASB folks all the time
how thrilled they are with the board members who are representing us in their various committees.
So I think we can go and both learn and teach in that context. And with that,
I'm going to adjourn our March 2023 state board meeting at 3.02 p.m.
Thank you and I look forward to seeing you at our May meeting.